AND I'M VERY PLEASED TO WELCOME
OUR AUGUST VICE CHAIR KANSEN CHU
SOME OF THE CANCER KANSEN CHU
WHO'S HERE HE ALSO CHAIRS.
THE COMMITTEE THAT OVERSEES
ARTS ISSUES ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
AND I SPENT A GREAT PARTNER AT
THIS.
JOINT COMMITTEE.
AND I WANT TO FIRST ACKNOWLEDGE
AND THANK TODAY SPEAKERS AND
MANY OF WHOM ARE VETERANS WERE
VERY MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO
THEIR TESTIMONY TODAY WE'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING AT THE QUESTION
OF VETERANS IN THE ARTS.
AND HEALING LIVES THROUGH
CREATIVE
EXPRESSION.
HOW WHICH WILL WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT?
A AND IN THE SECOND BUT I'D
FIRST ONE I THINK MEMBERS
REPUBLICAN JOINEDUS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL ALSO THOSE WHO ARE
HEARING THEY.
THAT THIS THIS SIZE
MISINFORMATION HEARING ONLINE
THIS IS ACTUALLY THE SECOND IN A
SERIES OF TO ARTS HEARINGS THAT
ARE COMMITTEE THE JOINT IN THE
ARTS IS HELD OVER THE PAST TWO
WEEKS.
AND I CERTAINLY VERY MUCH THINK
LAUREN UP PIES REMAINS ARE
FANTASTIC.
CONSULTANT WHO HAS WORKED
REALLY HARD TO PULL TOGETHER TO
REALLY TOP NOTCH HEARINGS LAST
WEEK AS YOU. MAY RECALL WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT CALIFORNIA THE
HUMANITIES AND.
AND AND BRING UP ALL SORTS OF
WONDERFUL STORIES FROM ALL OVER
THE STATE. THAT.
ARE IN THE SPACE OF HUMANITIES.
AND THEN TODAY WE'RE GONNA BE
TALKING ABOUT VETERANS ISSUES
FOCUSING ON AN IMPORTANT
POPULATION IN OUR STATE THAT
DESERVES OUR DAILY APPRECIATION
AND OUR UNWAVERING SUPPORT. OUR
VETERANS
AND TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS WILL
EXAMINE.
THAT MANY PROGRAMS THAT ARE OUT
THERE THAT SEEK TO SUPPORT OUR
VETERANS BY MARRYING THE HEALING
POWER OF THE ARTS.
WITH THE NEEDS OF THOSE WHO
REALLY SERVED OUR COUNTRY.
IN A FEW QUESTIONS AND OF COURSE
IT'S VERY APPROPRIATE THAT HERE
WE ARE JUST A COUPLE DAYS BEFORE
MEMORIAL DAY. ONE WERE ASKED TO
REFLECT ON THE SACRIFICE.
THAT THOSE WHO SERVED. HOA HAVE
GIVEN TO OUR COUNTRY
SO THERE'S A FEW QUESTIONS AT
THIS HEARING ARE GETTING US TO
THINK ABOUT SUFFERS A HOW DO WE
DEFINE HEALING.
WHAT EXACTLY DOES IT MEAN TO BE
HEALED?
I THINK WE WANT TO USE THE TERM
SHIELD WE MUST USE IT
RESPECTFULLY BECAUSE WE REALIZE
THAT HE ONLY HAPPEN STEP BY STEP
IN.
OVER A LONG PERIOD OF TIME FOR
MANY OF OUR TO PLAY VETERANS
THEIR WOUNDS BOTH PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL.
THAT ARE DIFFICULT TO COMPLETELY
HEAL.
HOW THEY SURVIVE SUCH TRAUMA
HOWEVER HEALING IS A JOURNEY OF
PROGRESSION ON THE PATH TOWARDS
A BETTER PLACE IN WITHOUT
THERE'S HOPE?
I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE'LL LEARN
TODAY ABOUT ARTS PROGRAMS THAT
ARE CREATING HOPE AND
HEALING PATHWAYS FOR OUR
VETERANS.
SPEAKERS WILL SHARE INFORMATION
ABOUT ARTS PROJECTS OR THERAPIES
THAT ARE SUPPLEMENTING OTHER
MEDICAL PROTOCOLS.
OR THOSE THAT HAVE SHOWN UNIQUE
ABILITIES TO SOOTH DAMAGE
SPIRITS AND MINES.
POUND MORE SOME OTHER FORMS OF
OF.
OF THERAPY THAT ARE ENCOURAGING
MOVEMENT THROUGH DANCE AND FEAR
OR THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE
CREATING A SENSE OF COMMUNITY
AND LESSEN ISOLATION AND
LONELINESS BY CREATING. ART IN A
GROUP SETTING.
THESE BENEFITS ARE POWERFUL
THEY'RE IMPORTANT AND THEY'LL
DEMONSTRATE THE UNIQUE SPACE OF
THE ARTS OCCUPY AND VETERANS.
AND RECOVERY HOW OFTEN AND WELL
BEING.
TWENTY SIXTEEN REPORT BY THE U.
S. OFFICE OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUICIDE PREVENTION IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION.
THE HIGHER RATE OF SUICIDE AMONG
VETERANS THAN.
AMONG THE NON VETERAN
POPULATION
I KNOW THAT.
DOES THE SENATE HAS HIGHLIGHTED
THE FACT THAT THERE ARE.
YEAH TWENTY TWO SUICIDE DEATHS
IN OUR COUNTRY BY VETERANS EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
WE'VE GOT OF ENORMOUS POPULATION
VETERANS HERE INSTEAD THE
CALIFORNIA WHO NEED OUR HELP.
I'M CERTAINLY MY SENATE DISTRICT
AT I SHARE WITH MY MY DEAR
FRIEND VEDOMOSTI ON HIS THE HAD
A CAL THAT.
IT'S HOME TO MANY VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES WE'VE GOT THE HOW
THE LA AIRFORCE BASE IN EL
SEGUNDO ONE OF THE LARGEST
VETERANS AFFAIRS.
MEDICAL CENTERS IN WEST LOS
ANGELES NEARBY THERE'S LOS
ANGELES NATIONAL CEMETERY I WAS
JUST THERE. THIS LAST WEEKEND
PLANTING FLAGS AND FLOWERS ON ON
VETERANS GRAVESITES.
ON FRIDAY WITH THE IMPRESSED AND
SHARP AS A YOUNG MAN WHO
FORM THE FLAGS AND FLOWERS.
PROGRAM.
I ALSO SPENT TIME WITH VETERANS
IN THE ANNUAL TORRANCE ARMED
SERVICES OPERATE THIS LAST
SATURDAY AND.
SO THAT YOU KNOW THAT WE'RE
LEADING INTO MEMORIAL DAY AND IT
CERTAINLY WAS A MOMENT FOR US TO
REFLECT.
GREAT DEAL ON ON ON ON THE
ISSUE STONE OF IT WE CAN DO TO
HELP OUR VETERANS.
LET ME MAKE SURE TO THINK
SCULPTOR AND VETERAN REGINALD
GREEN ARTISTIC.
YES SHARE IMAGES OF THEIR
ARTWORK AND
SUPPORT OF TODAY'S HEARING SOME
OF THEM ARE ARE ON VIEW HERE IN
OUR OUR BOOKLET A WONDERFUL.
A COMPILATION OF ARTICLES AND
WORKS OF ART BY VETERANS.
HOW VERY BEAUTIFULLY DONE AND?
A VERY POWERFUL AND WITHOUT A
LIKE TO TURN YOUR VICE CHAIR
KANSEN CHU WILL OFFER A FEW
WORDS.
BEFORE WE STARTED PANELS.
FOR A GREAT SENSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. ARE YOU ALSO WANT
TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
THANK ALL THE VETERANS FOR YOUR
SERVICES TO OR. A NATION AND
MOST CASES TO KEEP PEACE A.
AROUND THE GLOBE YOU KNOW I
CAME FROM A VETERAN FAMILY MY
FATHER WAS ONE OF THE. FLYING
TIGERS
AND.
THE FAULT OF THE THE SIDE TO
SIDE BY SIDE ORDER. OF FLIGHT
THE BOAT. OVER THE HUMP WITH
THE.
GENERAL CHENNAULT AND AND AND
HIS TEAM. AND MY GRANDFATHER ON
MY MOTHER'S SIDE. WHO WAS ALSO
THE OF? WHAT'S ACTUALLY TRAIN
AND IN THE BY THE UNITED STATES
HIM HERE WAS ONE OF THE
DISTINGUISHED. A HOME ALONE AYE
FOAM OF. VMI VIRGINIA MILITARY
INSTITUTE.
AND HE LOVED THE CROWN TRUE AND
SIDE BY SIDE. THOSE WHO WAS TO A
GENERAL STILWELL AND OPEN OF
ROOM AND LEADING THE CHINESE
TROOPS. AND OPENED UP THE LEGAL.
HIGHWAY ON THE KNOWN IF YOU ARE
FAMILIAR. WITH THAT PART OF
HISTORY AND WILL OR TO END OF
CBI THEATER.
SO I THINK I AM I KNOW THAT.
COLLARDS INDICATES. OUR THERAPY
WHO BOTH SUGGEST MUSIC AND ARE
CHEN AND POETRY PUFFY WHO BUT IT
WORKS FOR A. POSITIVE TO THE
POSITIVELY IMPACT FOR THE MOTION
AND HELPLESS TO PTSD. I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM THE
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES ON
HOW ARTS THERAPY HAS HELPED THEM
FITTING TESTED REALLY REALLY
GOOD TESTIMONY. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY I MEAN TO STATE AND
LEARNING HOW CALIFORNIA
CAN PASS USE ALL OUR RESOURCES
TO CALIFORNIA ARTS. COUNCIL
THOUGH I IT DVDS HERE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS.
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
VETERANS
WHAT'S SAD AGAIN THANK YOU
SENATOR ALAN FOR PUTTING THIS
HEARING TOGETHER. AND DUH THE
FAULT WITNESSES WHO COME FORWARD
TO SHARE YOUR PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES.
THANK YOU AS A VICE CHAIR.
TO COVER PANELS WE NOW WE WILL
HEAR FROM PRINT OVER WILL HAVE
AN OVERVIEW WHERE WE WILL
FEATURE.
THE AGENCY LEADERS CAPITA MEMBER
INSECTIVOROUS AFFAIRS.
THE DUMBASS YUMMY
HI WELCOME TO THE DIETS AND ALSO
COVERED ARTS COUNCIL DIRECTOR
AND BROWN CLUB CRAWFORD WHO WILL
GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF THEIR
DEPARTMENTS ARE PERSPECTIVES.
ON THE VALUE VETERANS ARTS
PROGRAMS IN GENERAL AND THEN
WILL DRILL DOWN ON HOW WE'RE
WORKING.
AGENCIES.
IN SUPPORT OF THE ARTS COUNCILS
VETERANS IN ARTS PROGRAM.
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BE HEARING
FROM GENERAL NOLAN BILLIONS.
I HE CURRENTLY SERVES AS
MILITARY IN ARTS COMMUNICATE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT ADVISOR FOR
A NATIONAL PROGRAM THE CREATIVE
FORCES INITIATIVE. WHICH IS A
COLLABORATION OF THE NATIONAL
DOLLARS FOR THE ARTS AND OUR NEW
DEFENSE
SO WE'LL BE HEARING FROM.
BOTH A STATEMENT FOR THE
FEDERAL PERSPECTIVE AND WE'D
LIKE TO WELCOME IS REVEALED TO.
THE FRONT OF MY PRESENTS OR
COMMITTEE.
WE'LL START WITH YOU DOCTOR
MUST.
AND ALWAYS WEARS IMPECCABLE CHO
TIES.
I THINK IT'S JUST.
.
WHAT MORE NECESSITY? AS A
SURGEON THAT AS A FASHION
STATEMENT.
BUT I GOVERNOR'S CHAIRMAN NOW
AND AM VICE SO TERRIBLY ONE HAVE
TO PERFORM SURGERY TODAY. ABOUT
OPEN UP TO.
.
AND.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ABOUT
VETERANS IN THE ARTS ONE OF THE
FIFTEEN GRANT PROGRAMS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL.
YOU GET UP ABOUT MY CREDENTIALS
AND WHY I SHOULD SPEAK AT ALL TO
YOU TODAY. IT'S TRUE I DID SPEND
MUCH OF MY CAREER IN THE
MILITARY AS AN ARMY PHYSICIAN
AND SURGEON. BUT BEFORE THAT I
STARTED IN ACADEMIA. I RECEIVED
MY UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE IN
MUSIC.
AT NEW YORK'S STATE UNIVERSITY
AT FREDONIA NEAR BUFFALO NEW
YORK I EARN MY MASTERS DEGREE
AND A PHD IN MUSICOLOGY FROM
CORNELL. AND I TAUGHT MUSIC
HISTORY AND HUMANITIES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF FLORIDA. AND AT
MIDDLEBURY COLLEGE IN VERMONT
WHERE I ALSO HAD OCCASION TO
WORK WITH THE VERMONT COUNCIL ON
THE ARTS. NEEDLESS TO SAY I AM
AN ARDENT SUPPORTER OF THE ARTS.
TEACHING MUSIC AT SEVERAL TWO
AND FOUR YEAR COLLEGES
REINFORCED MY BELIEF IN THE
VALUE OF THE ARTS. PARTICULARLY
IN ITS ROLE IN LIBERAL EDUCATION
AS IT SEEKS TO SHAPE AND FORM
CITIZENS.
THERE'S INHERENT VALUE IN
CULTURAL ENRICHMENT AND EXPOSURE
TO THE ARTS AND AS YOU WILL NO
DOUBT HEAR TODAY THERE'S
POTENTIAL FOR SO MUCH MORE THAN
THAT. THERE'S THERAPEUTIC VALUE
ESPECIALLY WHEN ART PROGRAMS ARE
PART OF A BROADER WRAPAROUND
SERVICE. SERVICES FOR VETERANS
REINTEGRATING INTO CIVILIAN
LIFE.
THE ARTS CAN PROVIDE ALTERNATIVE
MODES OF THERAPY AND CULTURAL
ENRICHMENT FOR VETERANS.
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
MANY ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
FEDERAL VA HAVE BEGUN OFFERING
ARTS THERAPY AS A MEANS TO
COMPLEMENT ESTABLISHED TREATMENT
PLANS FOR PTSD AND TB AYE.
INJURIES WHICH ARE BECOMING A
DISTRESSINGLY MORE COMMON
CHARACTERISTIC OF THE MODERN
BATTLEFIELD. THESE PROGRAMS
FOCUS ON DEVELOPING SELF
EXPRESSION SELF KNOWLEDGE AND
RELAXATION. OFTEN IN THE COMFORT
OF THE VETERANS OWN HOME.
SPEAKERS FOLLOWING ME WILL
AMPLIFY AND PERSONALIZE THESE
POINTS
IN A FAR MORE CONVINCING VOICE
THAN I CAN. BUT LET ME SAY THIS.
NO PLACE NEEDS THE SUPPORT OF
THE ARTS AS MUCH AS CALIFORNIA
DIES.
BECAUSE WE ARE UNIQUE.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE
NATION'S LARGEST VETERAN
POPULATION WITH ROUGHLY ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION VETERANS.
HALF OF OUR VETERANS ARE OVER
AGE SIXTY FIVE. TEN PERCENT ARE
UNDER AGE THIRTY. AND A QUARTER
OF OUR VETERANS ARE DISABLED BY
THEIR SERVICE TO SOME DEGREE.
A QUARTER OF THEM HAVE NO MORE
THAN A HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION AND
THEIR MILITARY TRAINING.
BUT YOU'RE AWARE THERE ARE
CHALLENGES AMONG OUR NATIONS AND
OUR STATES VETERAN POPULATION
INCLUDING PTSD. TBI. VETERAN
SUICIDE HOMELESSNESS AND OVER
REPRESENTATION IN THE PRISON
SYSTEM.
ACCORDING TO THE MOST RECENT
NUMBERS.
WELL WE CALIFORNIA HAVE TEN
PERCENT OF THE NATION'S VETERANS
WE HAVE TWENTY NINE PERCENT OF
ALL HOMELESS VETERANS.
FORTY NINE PERCENT OF THE
NATION'S ON SHELTERED VETERANS
RESIDE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
FORTY NINE PERCENT.
WITH SO MANY ORGANIZATIONS%
HELPING TO ADDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES AND SERVING VETERANS
IN CALIFORNIA THE IMPORTANCE OF
A COORDINATED STRATEGIC APPROACH
TO PROVIDING ASSISTANCE TO
SERVICE MEMBERS VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED.
SO LET ME TAKE A MOMENT TO
DESCRIBE A NEW PROGRAM WITHIN
CAL THAT.
THAT IS POSITIONED TO FURTHER
THE REACH AND THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE ARTS COUNCILS VETERANS IN
THE ARTS PROGRAM.
LAST YEAR THANKS TO THE VISION
OF OUR GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE WE LAUNCHED THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSITION ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM OR CAL TAP.
THE FIRST OF ITS KIND STATE
PROGRAM EDUCATE SERVICE MEMBERS
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES
ABOUT THE BENEFITS THEY HAVE
LEARNED THROUGH THEIR MILITARY
SERVICE.
NO EVERY YEAR TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE HANG UP
THEIR UNIFORMS SOMEWHERE IN THE
WORLD AND COME O CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THEY MAKE THE TRANSITION
FROM THE MILITARY TO CIVILIAN
LIFE.
AND CAL TAP IS DESIGNED TO
CONNECT WITH ALL OF THESE
VETERANS. RIGHT WHEN THEY ARE
SEPARATING FOR SERVICE AND TO
STAY CONNECTED WITH THEM FOR
LIFE.
WE ARE CURRENTLY HOLDING CAL TAP
SEMINARS ON ALL THIRTEEN ACTIVE
DUTY MILITARY INSTALLATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WERE USING
AN INNOVATIVE THREE STEP
STRATEGY TO CONNECT CONTACT AND
COMMUNICATE WITH VETERANS IN A
NEW WAY. AND THIS CONSISTS OF IN
PERSON AND ONLINE CLASSES THAT
WERE DEVELOPED IN RESPONSE TO
DATA DRIVEN ANALYSIS OF WHAT
VETERANS IN DIFFERENT REGIONS OF
THE STATE. WITH DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND AT DIFFERENT
STAGES IN THEIR LIFE WHAT THEY
REALLY NEED WE PROVIDE
INFORMATION THAT'S SPECIFIC TO
CALIFORNIA.
THE COUNTER PROGRAM ALSO
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE WITH OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
SERVING VETERANS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SUCH AS THE VETERANS IN
THE ARTS PROGRAM. THROUGH CAL
TAP.
WE COULD HELP SPREAD THE WORD
ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES AND
INCORPORATE GRANTEES INTO OUR
TRAINING PROGRAM WHEN
APPROPRIATE. WE CAN ALSO ASSIST
THE ARTS COUNCIL IN NAVIGATING
THE NUANCES OF REACHING ARE
TRANSITIONING SERVICE MEMBERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. SO I WANT
TO THANK THE ARTS COUNCIL FOR
INCLUDING CAL THAT IN THEIR
PROCESS HE'S TO DATE. HARD TEAM
WAS INVOLVED IN THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN GRANT PROCESS
FOR VETERANS IN THE ARTS.
HELPING TO REVIEW NEARLY FIFTY
PROPOSALS REPRESENTING A RANGE
OF PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
IN MANY CASES THE APPLICANT'S
WORKED IN COLLABORATION WITH
THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND ESTABLISHED VETERANS SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT'S KIND OF COLLABORATION
PROVIDES A MECHANISM TO PROPERLY
IDENTIFY VETERANS.
WHO COULD BENEFIT FROM THE
PROGRAM? AND TO VERIFY THAT
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE THE
NECESSARY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ACKERMAN.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT ARE MOST
DESERVING VETERANS RECEIVE AN
ARTS PROGRAM EXPERIENCE THAT
WORKS IN CONCERT WITH TREATMENT
PLANTS ALREADY ESTABLISHED
THROUGH EVIDENCE BASED MEANS.
I BELIEVE THESE TYPES OF
PARTNERSHIPS
ALONG WITH IMMIGRATION WITH
EXISTING SERVICES PROVIDES THE
GREATEST PROMISE FOR EFFECTIVE
THERAPEUTIC ARTS PROGRAMS.
AND THIS WILL ENSURE THAT WE
SERVE VETERANS IN NEED AND THAT
SUCH PROGRAMS ARE HIGH QUALITY
RESULTS FOCUSED AND PROVIDE
MAXIMUM IMPACT.
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
THROUGH THEIR VETERANS IN THE
ARTS PROGRAM IS ONE SPOKE IN THE
WHEEL OF PROVIDING COORDINATED
SERVICES TO VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
TOGETHER. WE CAN WORK TO ENSURE
THAT THE NEEDS OF VETERANS ARE
PRIORITIZED IN A WAY. THAT
PROVIDES COMPREHENSIVE AND
HOLISTIC CARE WHILE MAINTAINING
EFFICACY.
SO FINALLY I WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE FOR
YOUR ONGOING COMMITMENT TO
SUPPORTING ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WE ALL SHARE THE GOAL OF
ENSURING THAT OUR STATE KEEPS
ITS PROMISE TO THOSE WHO SERVE
ON OUR BEHALF THANK YOU.
JEFF.
BUSINESS FROM CRAWFORD.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
NICE ADDITION OF THE TIE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HOW WE KEEP AMERICA?
REALLY THOUGH. BECAUSE OF HOW
FROM TOP TO WEAR TIED TO STATE
ON THE DATA.
OKAY SO.
WE'RE NOT TELL.
HOW FAR BACK TO MY NOTES?
HE'S BEEN ARTSY IN IS UNLIKELY I
ONLY APPRECIATE NTULI.
YEAH I'M GOOD AFTERNOON TO BOTH
OF YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MISTER VICE
CHAIR
THANKS FOR CONVENING THIS.
HEARING TODAY WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME AND A FOUR YEAR
COMMITMENT TO THOSE WHO SERVED
THIS COUNTRY.
YEAH I'M A FOR ALL YOU DO TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ALONG WITH ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN BENEFIT FROM
THE POWER OF CREATIVE EXPRESSION
AND THE ARTS.
I'M AND BOUND CRAWFORD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL. I'M HONORED TO HAVE
BEEN APPOINTED TO THIS POSITION
IN DECEMBER BY GOVERNOR BROWN
WHO CREATED THE ARTS COUNCIL
MORE THAN FORTY YEARS AGO. ON
THE BASIS THAT THE ARTS ARE
CENTRAL TO THE LIVES OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
WHERE THE STATE'S ARTS AGENCY
DEDICATED TO ADVANCING
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE ARTS AND
CREATIVITY?
I THOUGHT A LOT ABOUT THAT
MISSION I GET ASSET FREQUENTLY
WHAT DO YOU DO. OUT WE ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE ARTS AND
CREATIVITY.
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT WE CANNOT
TRULY ADVANCE AS A STATE AND AS
A SOCIETY IF EVEN ONE INDIVIDUAL
IS LEFT BEHIND.
THE ARTS ARE UNIQUE TO ALL THAT
BREAK DOWN BARRIERS THEY DEEPLY
CONNECT PEOPLE AND ALLOW
EVERYONE TO FIND THEIR OWN
AUTHENTIC VOICE.
A SUBSTANTIAL BODY OF NATIONAL
RESEARCH HAS ESTABLISHED THE
ARMS ENGAGEMENT. AS YIELDING
PHYSICAL COGNITIVE AND AN
EMOTIONAL BENEFITS SUCH AS
RECOVERY FROM INJURY ILLNESS AND
IMPROVED INNER PERSONALITY.
INTERPERSONAL RELATIONSHIPS AND
OUTLOOK ON LIFE HISSES
REFERENCED IN THE MATERIALS IN
FRONT OF YOU.
I'VE EXPERIENCE THE POWER OF THE
ARTS FIRSTHAND AS AN EDUCATOR.
TEACHING HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
FOR FOUR DECADES.
STARTING IN THE BAY AREA AND
ENDING UP IN THE NORTHERN MOST
VERY RURAL PART OF THE STATE IN
HUMBOLDT COUNTY.
I KNOW THAT THE ARTS HAVE THE
POWER TO LAND PEOPLE AGENCY
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN MARGINALIZED OR ALIENATED.
PEOPLE WHO CARRY WITH THEM
PERSONAL STRUGGLE AND CHALLENGE.
THE ARTS ARE EFFECTIVE IN
REDUCING THE SENSE OF ALIENATION
AND FRAGMENTATION THIS OFTEN
FOUND IN OUR CONTEMPORARY
SOCIETY.
BY NOURISHING CREATIVITY WE CAN
BEST TO NOURISH HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES AND INFORM A STRONG
CIVIL SOCIETY.
AT THE CORE OF OUR MISSION AT
THE ARTS COUNCIL ISA BELIEVES
THAT ARTS
CULTURE AND CREATIVE EXPRESSION
HAVE A DIRECT AND LASTING IMPACT
ON THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS. AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES GOVERNOR BROWN AND
OUR STATE LEGISLATURE HAS
REASSERTED THEIR FAITH IN THIS
MISSION THROUGH A STEADY
INCREASE IN OUR ITS INVESTMENT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEE.
FIVE YEARS AGO WHEN THE FIRST
BUDGET INCREASE CAME TO OUR
AGENCY THE COUNCIL IMMEDIATELY
PRIORITIZED CALIFORNIA'S
VETERANS.
OUR COUNCIL DISCUSSED THE
CHALLENGES AND REALITIES THAT
DOCTOR EMBOSS YANNI'S JUST SPOKE
OF.
AND FELT A SPECIAL CALL TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES AND AMPLIFY
THE VOICES OF THIS UNIQUE AND
VALUED CALIFORNIA POPULATION.
OUR COUNCIL MEMBERS BELIEVE THAT
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES
COULD GREATLY BENEFIT FROM
COMMUNITY ARTS PROGRAMMING.
THEY IDENTIFIED MANY ASPECTS OF
THE VETERAN EXPERIENCE THAT
COULD BE ADDRESSED THROUGH
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE ARTS
INCLUDING FAMILY RELATIONS.
CIVILIAN AND SOCIAL
REINTEGRATION EMPLOYMENT
HOMELESSNESS MULTIPLE DEPLOYMENT
ASPECTS COMBAT RELATED MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES AND OTHER
DIFFICULTIES.
THROUGH MY OWN PERSONAL STORY I
CONNECT TO THE ARE.
TO THE ARTS IN WAYS THAT ADDRESS
THE VETERAN EXPERIENCE.
I WAS BORN ON THAT KODIAK NAVAL
AIR BASE AND HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH AND WATCH MY FATHER CREATE
ONE CREATIVE COMMUNITY
EXPERIENCE AFTER ANOTHER.
THROUGH HIS MILITARY IN PUBLIC
SERVICE.
ALL INVOLVED CONNECTION AND
HEALING.
I'VE MENTORED HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN NAVIGATING TOWARDS
THEIR FUTURE MANY WHO CHOOSE TO
ENLIST.
THE STUDENTS OFTEN COME TO THE
ARTS WHEN THEY HAVEN'T FELT
CONNECTED TO ANY OTHER PART OF
HIGH SCHOOL FOR THE GREATER
COMMUNITY. IN THE ARTS THEY FIND
A COMMUNITY WHERE THEY ARE
VALUED.
FOR MANY CONSIDERING MILITARY
SERVICE IS A NATURAL SEGUE TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE AND BE PART OF
A GREATER COMMUNITY.
THE ARTS COUNCILS VETERANS IN
THE ARTS PROGRAM WAS INTRODUCED
AS A PILOT FOR YEARS AGO.
THROUGH ARTS TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL ARTS
AGENCIES AND VETERANS ASSISTANCE
AGENCIES ARE BE AYE A PROGRAM
SEEKS TO INCREASED EQUITY.
ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
VETERANS TO PARTICIPATE IN
QUALITY ARTS PROGRAMMING. THAT
IS SENSITIVE AND RESPONSIVE TO
THEIR UNIQUE EXPERIENCES.
THE I AEA HAS IS ONE OF FIFTEEN
GRANT PROGRAMS CURRENTLY OFFERED
BY THE ARTS COUNCIL.
NINETY FIVE GRANTS WERE AWARDED
IN THE FIRST THREE YEARS OF OUR
V. I. AID PROGRAM. EACH YEAR THE
COUNCIL HAS INCREASED ITS
INVESTMENT IN THIS PROGRAM
BEGINNING WITH THE ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PILOT PROGRAM TO ANNOUNCE SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. IN THIS CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR. ON JUNE SEVENTH OUR
COUNCIL WILL AWARD THE FOURTH
YEAR OF V. I. EIGHT GRAMS.
AS I GOT TO KNOW OUR VIP
GRANTEES I'VE BEEN STRUCK BY THE
CREATIVE AND INTEGRATED CONCEPTS
FOR LOCAL PROGRAMS.
I WAS INSPIRED BY THE APPROACH
OF THE SHAKESPEARE CENTER OF LOS
ANGELES WHO PARTNERED WITH A
LOCAL VA TO RECRUIT TRAIN AND
PROVIDE PAID INTERNSHIPS FIRST
THIRTY CHRONICALLY UNEMPLOYED
VETERANS. TO WORK ON UNION
CONTRACTED THEATER PRODUCTIONS.
PARTICIPANTS ALSO ENROLLED IN
SANTA MONICA COLLEGE.
IN THEIR TECHNICAL THEATER ARTS
COURSES AND RECEIVE JOB
PLACEMENT SERVICES. THIS IS THE
ARTS IN ACTION.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO EMBARKING ON
FUTURE OH EVALUATION AND
ASSESSMENT THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THAT OUR GRANTS OUR MOST
EFFECTIVELY MEETING THE NEEDS OF
VETERANS IN OUR STATE.
WE'RE ALSO FOCUSED ON
IDENTIFYING NEW PASTOR AND
PARTNERS TO MAXIMIZE THE BREADTH
AND THE REACH OF THE
PROGRAMMING.
THE DE MAYA DEMAND FOR V. I. A
GRANTS HAVE INCREASE EACH YEAR.
WERE PROUD TO SERVE THOSE WERE
ABLE TO FUND AND AS WITH ALL OF
OUR GRANT PROGRAMS WE KNOW THAT
THERE IS IMPORTANT WORK THAT
WERE UNABLE TO FIND.
WE HOPE TO SEE THIS PROGRAM GROW
IN THE FUTURE TO ADDRESS THE
PRESSING NEED TO REACH MORE
VETERANS THROUGH LOCAL
PROGRAMMING.
WE'RE DEEPLY HONORED THAT THE
EXPERIENCES OF SOME OF OUR V. I.
ES GRANTEES PARTNERS AND PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS WILL BE HEARD BY
YOU TODAY.
THESE REMARKABLE INDIVIDUALS
WILL SHARE WITH ALL OF US ALL OF
THE IMPACT THE ARTS HAVE HAD ON
THEIR LIVES IN THEIR OWN VOICES.
GREATER THAN I COULD EVER BE
COUNTY.
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
ARTS COUNCIL TO HONOR DOCTOR
BUSS YANNI AND GENERAL BEVANS.
AND ADAM CHRISTOPHER'S PHYLLIS
AMBER ELIZABETH REGGIE MAMBO AND
REBEKAH ALL OF WHOM I MET
EARLIER TODAY BEFORE THE
HEARING.
I'M HERE TODAY TO LISTEN
MINDFULLY.
IN CLOSING I'D LIKE TO THANK
GOVERNOR BROWN FOR CREATING THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX.
AND FOR STILL HAVING A STRONG
BELIEF IN THE ARTS TODAY AS
DEMONSTRATED MOST RECENTLY BY
HIS MAY REVISION PROPOSED
FUNDING INCREASE TO SUPPORT ARTS
COUNCIL PROGRAMS LIKE VETERANS
IN THE ARTS.
THANK YOU TO SENATOR ALLEN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU FOR YOUR
EXCEPTIONAL LEADERSHIP.
AND ALL MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE WHO ARE HERE TODAY
AND WHO SUPPORT THE ARTS AND
CREATIVE EXPRESSION IN THIS
BUILDING AND IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
TO OUR SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN PAST
AND PRESENT IS A PRIVILEGE TO BE
CHAMPIONS FOR YOUR EXPRESSION IN
YOUR EXPERIENCE.
TO YOU AND TO THE ARTIST AND
COMMUNITY LEADERS TESTIFYING
HERE TODAY. THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR VOICE.
YOU THINK YOU CREATURE THAT I.
YOU KNOW IT CAN'T HELP BUT
NOTICE THE APPROPRIATENESS OF.
THE OPENING OF THIS HENRY THE
FOURTH.
.
PERFORMANCE ON ELECTION NIGHT
JUNE FIFTH. YEAH. BUT.
FALSTAFF WILL BE LOOKING DOWN
UPON THE VOTERS. THOUGHT LET ME
WITH THAT ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
THE FANTASTIC PRESENCE OF FILE
AND OF MY COLLEAGUE IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY CITY COME UNDER WHO
ACTUALLY REPRESENT THE WEST LA
VIA BELIEVE.
AND WHO LSO WAS WITH ME AT THE
LOS ANGELES VETERANS.
AT THE CEMETERY THE NATIONAL
CEMETERY LAST FRIDAY FOR THIS
FLAGS AND FLOWERS IT MEANT THAT
I MENTIONED EARLIER.
YOU'RE WELCOME A COUPLE COMMENTS
BUT IT WILL RUN BUT.
OKAY WHAT WILL WILL CARRY ON
WITH THE.
WITH THE PANEL THAT WE NEXT HAVE
KNOWN DEFENSE AS A BREEDER
GENERAL WITH THE US ARMIES THAT.
HAVE RETIRED BUT THEN HE. COME
FROM GUY YOU BASED OUT OF
WASHINGTON
BECAUSE DC WASHINGTON DC. WHERE
HE THE? GUY IS A MILITARY ARTS
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT ADVISOR FOR
THIS COLLABORATIVE CREATIVE
FORCES INITIATIVE WHICH.
BRINGS TOGETHER AT THE
DEPARTMENT DEFENSE WITH THE
NATIONAL FOR THE ARTS AND WE'RE
VERY PLEASED TO HAVE YOU HERE.
WE THINK IT'S A VERY MUCH.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR SENATE ALLEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU AND OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
FOR HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY ALSO TO
THE DISTINGUISHED PANEL THANK
YOU.
FOR THAT AND I KIND OF FEEL A
LITTLE THEIR RESPONSIBILITY.
VETO SAID HE'S A COLONEL SO I
FEEL A LITTLE RESPONSIBILITY TO.
AS THE SENIOR GUY HERE TO KIND
OF RECOGNIZE ALL THE OTHER
VETERANS IN THE AUDIENCE.
AND SAY TO THEM THANK THEM
THANK THEM FOR THEIR SERVICES
AND AND WHAT THEY'VE GIVEN SO
MUCH AS WELL AS HER FAMILY
MEMBERS.
SO I COME TO THE DISCUSSION
TODAY IF YOU PERMIT ME KIND OF
LIKE SO SO WHAT IS THE WHY I
OFTENTIMES ON AMENITIES AUDIENCE
OF PEOPLE LOOK AT ME AND SAID
WHAT ARE YOU HERE YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT ARE YOU DOING WHAT YOU
BRING JUST VOICE.
I THINK A DEMOCRAT AND I THINK
THAT.
.
I THINK THAT IT IT COMES OUT OF
THE IDEA THAT THERE REALLY IS NO
CONNECTION BETWEEN ARTS AND AND
AND THE MILITARY.
SO MAYBE TO MY.
COMES TODAY ELECTED MAYBE
DISPEL THAT A LITTLE BIT BUT
ALSO SHARE WHERE I THINK IT'S A
LOT IS NOT TRUE THE WHERE
THERE'S A GREATER OPPORTUNITY
FOR THAT.
BUT AS STATED.
MONEY WAS NO LIVE INSIDE SPENT
THIRTY TWO YEARS ON ACTIVE DUTY.
AND I COME TO IS COME TO SUCH A
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF HOW I
TRANSITION WHEN I ACTUALLY CAME
INTO MILITARY ACTIVITY MILITARY
AT THE POST VIETNAM TIME.
AT ODOS THIRTY YEARS I'VE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE.
DRASTIC CHANGE IN THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
MILITARY AND THE COMMUNITY IN
GENERAL BUT ALSO HEARTS I THINK
IN SPECIFIC.
SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS.
FRAME MY COMMENTS ARE OWNED ON
THESE OCCASIONS MOSTLY AROUND
THE IDEA OF THIS BEING A
COMMUNITY DISCUSSION.
AND THE REASON I DO THAT IS
BECAUSE TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AROUND OUR MILITARY BASES ARE
TRULY THE HOMES.
OF OUR SERVICE MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AS YOU PERHAPS KNOW
EIGHTY PERCENT.
A MILITARY SERVICE MEMBERS LIVE
IN THE ACTUAL COMMUNITY DO NOT
LIVE ON THE BASIS.
AND THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT POINT
AND WE ESTABLISHES NOTION OF
COMMUNITY AND COMMUNITY
DISCUSSION.
WHAT HERE'S OF REAL BOTTOM LINE
I THINK I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH
YOU TODAY AS I BELIEVE THE ARTS
IN THE MILITARY COMMUNITY HAS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY?
TO SERVE EACH OTHER AND ARE AS
NEVER BEFORE AND EVEN GROW
STRONGER ARTS IN MILITARY
COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S MY PASSION AND EVEN
STRONGER ARTS IN MILITARY
COMMUNITY IN SERVICE TO EACH
OTHER.
NOW IN I I LIKE TO OPEN DE THE
COMETS WITH THE LITTLE
PORTRAYING A PROBABLE DISPOSED
TO YOU MY BIAS FOR THE ART BUT
BUT I DO IT IN ORDER TO CREATE A
METAPHOR. FOR MY DISCUSSION.
TWO ROADS DIVERGED IN A WOOD.
AND I TOOK THE ONE LESS TRAVELED
BY.
AND THAT HAS MADE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE. THESE ARE THE WORDS
BY ROBERT FROST WE ALL REALLY
RECOGNIZE.
BUT I'LL FOR SLIGHT TWIST ON
THESE WORDS TO CREATE A METAPHOR
FOR WHAT'S HAPPENING BETWEEN
ARTS IN MILITARY COMMUNITY.
WELL ALL COULD LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AS WELL.
INSTEAD OF DIVERGING I THINK THE
ROADS OF THE ARTS IN THE
MILITARY COMMUNITIES OF
CONVERGING THE TOWEL COMMUNITY.
AND IF THE ARTS AND MILITARY
COMMUNITY SEIZE THIS MOMENT WE
CAN MAKE ALL THE DIFFERENCE.
IT'S A TOPIC THAT MANY OF US
UPON HEARING MY CONSIDERATION
VERY ON RELATED AS I STATED
EARLIER.
BUT THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
THAT THERE'S BEEN A LONG HISTORY
BETWEEN ARTS AND MILITARY.
THE LONG WINTER OF SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN IN SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. WHEN THE COULD
CONTINENTAL ARMY SPENT IN
CAPTIVE BALLOTS FORD. WAS
INTERRUPTED BY A PRESENTATION OF
THE PLAY KATO.
COMMISSION BY GEORGE WASHINGTON
HIMSELF FOR THE TROOPS.
THEN THERE'S THE GRAY GHOST ARMY
OF WORLD WAR TWO.
A FACT OF MILITARY SECRECY UNTIL
IT'S DARK DECLASSIFICATION IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX.
SPECIFICALLY THE TWENTY THIRD
HEADQUARTERS SPECIAL TROOPS WAS
AN ELITE FORCE WHOSE SPECIALTY
WAS TACTICAL DECEPTION.
KNOWN AS THE GHOST ARMY A TROUPE
OF SOLDIERS DOUBLED IN EUROPE'S
THEATER AS A TROUPE OF ACTORS.
THEY CREATED INFLATABLE TANKS TO
DECEIVE GERMAN MILITARY. IT IT
TOO IS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW THE
ALLIES EMBRACED HIS ARTISTRY OF
THE ART.
I THINK WE'RE NOW AT A MOMENT
WHERE THE TWO COMMUNITIES CAN
AGAIN SERVE EACH OTHER. ALBEIT
THIS TIME ON THE HOME FRONT.
THE OPERATIVE QUESTION ONE MIGHT
ASK IS HOW DO WE GET TO THIS
POINT HOW DID ARTS IN THE
MILITARY. GET TO A POINT WHERE
THEY CAN FIND VALUE IN SERVICE
TOGETHER.
LET'S DEAL WITH THE FIRST ONE
WHAT BRINGS A MILITARY SERVICE
POINT OF CONVERGENCE.
I THINK IT'S A TREMENDOUS SET OF
CHALLENGES AND DEMANDS BEFORE
THEM.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND ONE MORE
THAN TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION US
TROOPS HAVE DEPLOYED.
THEY'VE SEEN A HISTORIC AN
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF MULTIPLE
DEPLOYMENTS.
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED SHORTEN TIME
AT HOME BETWEEN THE DIPLOMATS.
MORE RETURNING HOME WITH
SPECIFIC MENTAL AND MORAL
INJURIES.
TWENTY TWO VETERANS.
TWENTY TWO MILLION VETERANS OR
IN THE US TODAY. AND OVER ONE
PERCENT OF THAT IS OF OUR
POPULATION.
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND M.
OF VIETNAM VETERANS.
THEN THERE'S A FAMILY SIDE OF
THE STORY.
THERE ARE ONE POINT TWO MILLION
CHILDREN OF ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY
SERVICE MEMBERS.
THE AVERAGE MILITARY CHAO WILL
MOVE TEN TIMES DOING THEIR
PARENTS CARILLO.
FAMILIES LIVE OFF THE MILITARY
INSULATION IN THE CIVILIAN
COMMUNITY AND I THINK THAT'S A
POSITIVE BY THE WAY.
NEARLY TWO MILLION CHILDREN HAVE
EXPERIENCED APPARENT DEPLOYMENT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ONE.
DIPLOMATS AVERAGE EIGHT MONTHS
THAT'S REPRESENTED THAT REPEATED
ANIMALS OFTEN WHAT DO A FAMILY
MEMBER HAD HOUSEHOLDS.
IT'S OPERATIONAL TEMPO AND THE
RESIDENT RESIDUAL OF FIFTEEN
YEARS OF NEAR CONTINUOUS COMBAT.
HAS PUT A STRESS ON THE FORCE
HAS NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
AND SLEPT MANY WITHIN WITH
INVISIBLE WOUNDS OF WAR.
INVISIBLE WOUNDS LIKE PTSD TBI
BUT WHICH MANY DO NOT SEEK
TREATMENT FOR FEAR OF NEGATIVE
STICK STIGMA.
BUT EVEN IN THE FACE OF THIS OUR
TROOPS ARE EXPERIENCING AND
EXPRESSING THE VALUE OF THE ARTS
IN HELPING THEM HEAL AND COPE
WITH THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
DEMANDS.
OF BEING BROUGHT UP ON THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
THE ARTS IN MY OPINION OFFER A
NON STIGMATIZED ENVIRONMENT.
WHERE VETERANS CAN CHOOSE THEIR
OWN METHOD OF HEALING? AND CAN
GO AND DEAL WITH AND CREATE WHAT
I CALL POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS.
AND THAT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT.
BECAUSE VETERANS DO NOT WANT TO
BE SEEN AS VICTIMS THEY WANT TO
BE SEEN AS STRONG AND CAPABLE.
SO I JUST PUSH THE WORD BECAUSE
I'VE COMPENSATED WITH THEM AND I
REALIZED THAT WHAT THEY'RE
REALLY SEEKING HIS POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS STRENGTH.
NOW HOW DID ARTS GET TO THIS
POINT OF CONVERGENCE.
HISTORICALLY HAS ANY ART
HISTORIAN A ROOM WOULD TELL YOU.
THE BIG OUR EVOLUTION COVERS A
NEOLITHIC AND HOW HELLENISTIC
PEERAGE THE RENAISSANCE AND ALSO
CONTEMPORARY ART PERIOD OF
EXPRESSION.
BUT THE PRACTICE RESULTS OF THE
ARTS BIG EVOLUTION IS AT THE
ARTS HAVE PROGRESSED TO A POINT.
THAT WITHIN THE MILITARY
COMMUNITY ARTISTIC EXPRESSION IS
BEING UTILIZED AS A TOOL TO
HEAL.
MOBILE. AND SUSTAIN RESILIENCY.
AND ADVOCATING FOR THE VALUE OF
THE ARTS THE NATIONAL ASSEMBLY
OF STATE ARTS AGENCIES LIST FIVE
ESSENTIAL ARGUMENTS FOR THE ARTS
THE FIRST ONE IS. THE ARTS IN
RICH THE AMERICAN ECONOMY
FESTIVAL ECONOMIC ARGUMENT FOR
THE ARTS.
THE ARTS OFFER SOLUTIONS FOR
RURAL AMERICA.
THE ARTS OFFER COST EFFECTIVE
HEALTH TREATMENT THAT WORKS AND
YOU'LL HEAR A LOT ABOUT THAT
TODAY AND SOME OF THE PROGRAMS.
THE ARTS IMPROVE EDUCATION
VESTED EDUCATION ARGUMENT.
AND FINALLY THEY SAY THE ARTS
OFFER A NET GAIN FOR THE
GOVERNMENT.
BUT IF NUMBER FIVE IS TRUE AND I
THINK IT IS.
I BELIEVE THE ARTS COMMUNITY CAN
NOW ADD A SIX VALUE OF THE ARTS.
I CALLED IT THE ARTS OFFER
BENEFITS TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
THEY CAN BE A TOOL TO ENABLE
HEALING. BUILDING AND SUSTAINING
THE READINESS AND RESILIENCY OF
THE FORCE
AND THAT GETS SET READ IS SO
THAT'S WHY I'M KIND OF IT THE
TABLE MODEL OPERATIONAL GUY.
AND I HAD A EXPERIENCE THAT
SHOWED ME THAT POTENTIALLY I
WOULD BE CARRYING VETERANS.
OUR SERVICE MEMBERS BACK INTO
WAR THAT HAD NOT TOTALLY HEALED.
BECAUSE THEY HAD INVISIBLE MOVES
AND THAT'S WHEN I BECAME ENGAGED
IN IS BECAUSE THAT WAS A VERY
MEANINGFUL PART FOR ME.
THIS IS THE MOMENT IN TIME AS I
SHOULD WITH YOUR EARLY OR I
THINK ARTS OFFER SOLUTIONS TO
THE CHALLENGES OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS FACE. AND BY EXTENSION
THE SECURITY OF OUR NATION.
BUT.
THIS AS I STATED IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS IS A COMMUNITY
DISCUSSION.
AND THE VALUE OF THE PROGRAM
SUPPORTING.
VETERANS AND ARTS HEALING LIVES
THROUGH CREATIVE EXPRESSIONS IS
NOT LIMITED TO THE MILITARY
PORTION OF OUR COMMUNITY.
THAT'S JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG OF COMMUNITY
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND EMOTIONAL
HEALING THAT ART CAN SUPPORT.
HERE'S HERE'S WHERE IN MANY OF
MY TALKS ON THIS SUBJECT ARE
NORMALLY ASK THE AUDIENCE.
WHAT DOES THE BATTLE OF
FALLUJAH?
FORT LAUDERDALE AIRPORT.
SEVEN HOOKED ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
AND THE BOSTON MARATHON. TELL US
ABOUT THE CURRENT REALITY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
IN ONE AND WORD ANSWER TRAUMA.
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE AWASH IN
TRAUMA.
JUST LIKE OUR SERVICEMEN WERE
EXPERIENCED IN THE BATTLE OF
FALLUJAH.
AND THERE ARE NO SIGNS OF IT
LETTING UP.
JUST THINK OF THIS.
OF THE OF THE TWELVE LARGEST
MASS SHOOTINGS IN AMERICA.
SEVEN OF THEM HAVE OCCURRED
SINCE THE BATTLE OF FALLUJAH
OCCURRED.
THE MILITARY IS STILL FACED WITH
BALANCING THE HIGH OPERATIONAL
TEMPO WITH INCREASED TRAINING.
THIS LOAD OFTEN FALLS
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON STATE
NATIONAL GUARDSMEN AND
RESERVISTS.
AND HERE'S ANOTHER KEY POINT.
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY LONELINESS
IS PROJECTED TO BE THE NEXT
HEALTH CRISIS.
THE ARTS OFFER SOLUTIONS TO BOTH
THE MILITARY AND CIVILIAN
COMPONENTS OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
EFFORTS THAT ARE CONTRIBUTING TO
THIS SOLUTION AND PROBABLY
SUPPORT THOSE AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL IT'S
PURSUING.
THAT IS MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
YOU SEE I RECENTLY PARTICIPATED.
IN THE THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL. OF SUMMIT THAT WAS HELD
IN SAN DIEGO FOR THE CREATIVE
FORCES INITIATIVE.
I LEARNED A VETERANS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO STATED. THE ARTS
SAVE THEIR LIVES.
SO WHAT ARE SOME OF THOSE
INITIATIVES THE FIRST ONE IS A
NATIONAL INITIATIVE ARTS AND
HEALTH IN THE MILITARY WHICH
SEEKS TO ADVANCE THE ARTS AND
HEALTH HEALING AND HEALTH CARE
FOR MILITARY SERVICE MEMBERS.
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AND THEN THERE'S.
VETO INDICATED THE VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION ARTS AND
HUMANITIES HAS A PILOT PROJECT
THAT'S EVALUATING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE OUTCOMES.
THEY'RE FOCUSING ON CREATIVE
ARTS THERAPIES AND OUR
PARTNERSHIPS IN PATIENT CENTERED
CARE OF. PLANNING.
THEY'RE ALSO MAPPING OUT LOCAL
ARTS RESOURCES AT EACH SITE.
AND I MENTION THESE BECAUSE I
THINK THEY OFFER PATERNS FOR
MANY OF THE STATES AND THE NEXT
ONE. THE NATIONAL ENDOWMENT FOR
THE ARTS CREATIVE FORCES
INITIATIVE IS A UNIQUE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN DOD AN NEA.
AND BELIEVE ME WHEN YOU GET DOD
ANY ANY A AND A ROOM TO AGREE.
YOU'VE AFRICA THING GOING. BUT I
THINK IT ALSO REPRESENTS A
MODERATE AND PATTERN FOR A LOT
OF OF STATE ORGANIZATIONSWHO
MAY WANT TO PURSUE IT.
THIS INITIATIVE WAS LAUNCHED BY
ANY A AND DOD AND TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. THAT MANY OF THE
NATIONAL INTREPID CENTERS OF
EXCELLENCE.
PARTICULARLY WATER READS THAT'S
LOCATED IN THE FASTER AND NOW IT
HAS EXPANDED TO SEVEN DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS AND I'M PROUD TO SAY
ONE OF THEM IS HERE IN.
CALIFORNIA WITH SAN DIEGO.
IT EXTENDS THERAPEUTIC ART
ENGAGEMENTS INTO THE COMMUNITY
OF PATIENTS
ONE OF THE THINGS WE REALIZE AND
RECOGNIZE IT THAT FIFTY PERCENT
OF THE VETERANS WHO NEED
TREATMENT DON'T EVER GET THE
TREATMENT.
AND THEY DON'T GET INTO THE
MEDICAL WORLD IN THE IN THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL TREATMENT BECAUSE
OF THE STIGMA ASSOCIATED WITH
IT.
I THINK THE ARTS CREATE THAT
AVENUE AND METHOD AN ALTERNATIVE
WHERE THEY CAN SEEK THAT
TREATMENT ON THEIR OWN AND NOT
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT STIGMA.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN ANY A DOD.
STATE AND LOCAL ARTS AGENCIES
AND AMERICANS FOR THE ARTS WHO
SERVES AS ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE
PROJECT.
AND FINALLY I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE NATIONAL
LIEUTENANT GOVERNORS
ASSOCIATION'S PARTNERSHIP. WHICH
OF THE STATE MILITARY AND
VETERANS ART INITIATIVE.
ALSO SUPPORTED BY AMERICANS FOR
THE ARTS.
THERE ARE THREE GOES ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS INITIATIVE THAT I LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT.
POLICY DEVELOPMENT WHICH IS AN
EFFORT TO HAVE EACH AND EVERY
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR PARTICIPATE
IN A MEANINGFUL WAY. BUT ALSO
ALLOW THE NATIONAL GOVERNORS
LEADERS GOVERNOR'S ASSOCIATION
TO WORK WITH EACH LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO
PARTICIPATE AS WELL.
THERE'S ALSO A RESEARCH
COMPONENT TO THAT TO PROVIDE
STRATEGIES TO ENCOURAGE COURAGE
A BUDGET ALLOCATION SUPPORT.
THE THE LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT
GOAL TO THAT GOAL SEEKS TO
IDENTIFY ELECTED AND APPOINTED
OFFICIALS IN EACH OF THE STATES.
AND TERRITORIES TO CHAMPION THIS
WORK IN ADVANCE THE INTERESTS OF
STATE MILITARY AND VETERAN
AFFAIRS INITIATIVE.
AND THE THIRD OBJECTIVE.
INGOLD THIS IS TODEVELOP
RESOURCES THAT ARE RELEVANT AND
USEFUL FOR LOCAL ARTS GROUPS
ELECTED AND APPOINTED OFFICIALS
TO USE. TO JUSTIFY AND PROMOTE
THE STATE MILITARY VETERANS ARTS
INITIATIVE.
THE NATIONAL LEADER A LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR'S ASSOCIATION IN
AMERICA FOR THE ARTS WOULD
PRODUCE VARIOUS PUBLICATIONS TO.
PUBLISHED ELECTRONICALLY IN
PRINT HIGHLIGHTS MATERIALS AND
HIS SUCCESSES ON HOW ELECT
OFFICIALS KEPT DISSIPATED.
SO LET ME CONCLUDE WHERE I
STARTED.
THANK YOU SENATE ALLEN VICE
CHAIRMAN XU. AND ALL THE OTHER
SIMPLY MEMBERS AND LEGISLATORS
AND COUNCIL TOOK A CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS VITAL AND
ESSENTIAL COMMUNITY
CONVERSATION.
THAT IT IS JUST THAT. A
COMMUNITY DISCUSSION ABOUT
VETERANS AND THE ARTS HEALING
LIVES THROUGH CREATIVE
EXPRESSION.
THANK YOU SO VERY KIM.
THANK HIM.
VERY COLD VERY INTERESTING.
HAVE YOU FOUND RIGIDLY A FEW
FIRST GENERAL.
.
WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN THE HAN
VEGAS SERVE CULTURAL ROADBLOCKS
YOU HAVE MET?
WITH BOTH SIDES.
PAT HAVE THERE BEEN SOME MONTHS
HAVE BEEN SINCE SOME SURPRISING.
CHALLENGES.
IDEA YOU MAY BE OBVIOUS FOR US
TO CONSIDER AND THE OBVIOUS
CHALLENGES THAT MIGHT EXIST ON
THE DOD SIDE BUT MAYBE ON THE
OUTSIDE TO.
CAN YOU FLESH SOME OF THOSE
CULTURAL DIFFERENCES OUT HOW
YOU'VE BEEN HELPING A PERSON.
IT ALWAYS ONE TO LIGHT A CANDLE
FOR YOU CURSE THE DARKNESS RIGHT
SO.
I THINK I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
THE THE THE THE GREAT CULTURAL
SIMILARITY.
OF THE MILITARY FOR MOST OF THE.
A YOU KNOW SERVICE MEMBERS
ABOUT SERVICE RIGHT THEY WANT TO
GIVE BACK GOING TO CONTRIBUTE TO
SOMETHING GREATER THAN
THEMSELVES.
AND INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH I FIND
IN THE ART COMMUNITY MOST
INDIVIDUALS GOING YARD BECAUSE
THEY TOO WANT TO SERVE THEY WANT
TO GIVE SOMETHING FOR THEY ALSO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE SUCH A GIFT
AND A TALENT WITHIN THEMSELVES.
BUT THEY DO SO WITH THE IDEA OF
GIVING BACK. RIGHT.
SO I THINK IF WE CAN HIGHLIGHT
THE FACT THAT THERE'S MORE ARE
THERE'S A LITTLE COMMONALITY IN
TERMS OF THE CULTURE.
AND AND GO INTO THE DISCUSSION
WITH THAT I THINK IT HELPS US
GET TO THE NEXT STOP POINT
SOMEHOW MAKE CARS. I THINK THE
FIRST POINT OF OF THE DILUTED
TOO WHEN I TALK ABOUT
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS.
WHAT PARENTS WANT MOST
IMPORTANTLY FROM THOSE WHO ARE
PROVIDING ANY TYPE OF CARE IN A
TYPE OF TREATMENT FOR THEM AS A
RECOGNIZE THE IDEA THAT THEY ARE
NOT BROKEN BUT THEY ARE TRYING
TO? TO REGAIN US LEVEL OF
STRENGTH THAT THEY HAD PRIOR TO
THAT.
SO THAT CULTURE OF STRAND.
NOW ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT
FOR THE MILITARY THAT BECOMES A
WEAKNESS BECAUSE.
THERE WAS A STUDY THAT
INDICATED.
THE FIFTEEN THINGS THAT SERVICE
MEMBERS WANTED THE COMMUNITY
KNOW ABOUT THEM.
NUMBER SEVEN WAS IS THAT IT'S
HARD FOR US TO ASK FOR HELP AND.
SO THAT CULTURE OR THE MILITARY
HAS TO BE OVERCOME BUT I THINK
IT ALL COMES BY THE IDEA THAT
THE ARTS DISS THE STRENGTH NOW
OF THE OF THAT. THE ARTS PROVIDE
AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE THEY CAN GO
WE AND SELECT.
AND SHOES WITHOUT BEING
STIGMATIZE.
AND I THINK THAT ASPECT OFOF
WHAT THE ART OUR CULTURE OFFERS
IS IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
I THINK THE ONLY DARK SIDE OF
THE QUESTION.
AND I THINK THAT THE IMPORTANT
THING IS AND I USE A MEDICAL
UPON METAPHOR FOR THIS DO NO
HARM.
I THINK THE CULTURAL ASPECT IS
TO RECOGNIZE THAT IF YOU HAVEN'T
WORKED WITH THE POPULATION.
TRAINING AND AWARENESS OF ABOUT
WHAT'S CLEAR IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT AND I'M SURE YOU HEAR
A LOT OF THOSE WHO ARE WORKING
IN THOSE PROGRAMS LATER ON AND
TESTIMONY TO TO GIVE EVIDENCE TO
THAT.
I HOPE THAT ANSWERED CAN'T THANK
YOU ENOUGH.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
HIM.
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
SHARING IT. LISTENING TO YOU
ACTUALLY REMINDED ME OF THEM.
A SEGMENT THAT IWAS LISTENING
TO ON PUBLIC RADIO.
WITH A MEMBER OF THE ARMED
FORCES WHO WAS TALKING ABOUT.
SOME CHALLENGES HE WAS DEALING
WITH WITH.
A YOUNG GIRL WHO WAS.
.
AND DYING AND.
EMPATHY.
WAS A WORD THAT HE KEPT BRINGING
UP.
AND HOW HE WAS FIGHTING BACK.
HE MOTIONS AS IT RELATES TO HOW
HE WAS FEELING ABOUT.
THIS YOUNG GIRL BECAUSE HE HAD
BEEN TRAINED TO NOT WANT TO
FEEL.
BECAUSE EMPATHY WAS CONSIDERED A
WEAKNESS.
AND YET THE VERY FACT THAT HE
HAD. THESE EMOTIONS ACTUALLY
ALLOWED HIM TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THE YOUNG GIRLS PARENTS.
AT HER FUNERAL BECAUSE SHE DIED.
BUT IT MADE WE THINK ABOUT WHAT
YOU WERE SAYING IN THE NEXUS
BETWEEN THE MILITARY COMMUNITY
AND THE ARTS COMMUNITY BECAUSE
ON THE ONE HAND THE ARTS
COMMUNITY IS ALSO ABOUT.
INVOKING EMPATHY INVULNERABILITY
AND ALLOWING PEOPLE TO FEEL SAFE
AND UNCOMFORTABLE SPACES. AND
THE MILITARY WE SOMETIMES DON'T
WANT TO THINK ABOUT THOSE
THINGS.
AND SO HOW CAN WE COLLECTIVELY
DO A BETTER JOB OF TRYING TO
BRIDGE THOSE GAPS BECAUSE I'M.
OF THE BELIEF THAT IT'S OKAY TO
FEEL COMFORTABLE UNCOMFORTABLE
IF YOU'RE IN A SAFE SPACE THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO WORK THROUGH THAT.
AND OBVIOUSLY THE ARTS ARE.
.
IT'S A WAY FOR VETERANS FOR
EVERYONE BUT FOR THOSE IN THE
MILITARY TO. TO CONNECT TO SOME
OF THOSE.
FEELINGS AND EMOTIONS.
THAT HOPEFULLY OUR OUR CHECKERS
FOR SOMETHING ELSE THAT COULD
ULTIMATELY LEAD TO THE PTS.
THE. POST TRAUMATIC STRENGTHENED
HOW DO WE KIND OF LOOK.
TO DE STIGMATIZE.
SOME OF THOSE.
FEELINGS AND SPACE SAYS THAT WE
TRY TO SEPARATE.
FROM THE MILITARY EXPERIENCE.
WELL I WOULD SAY THAT.
.
PROBABLY. THIS IS WHERE THE ARTS
ALMOST STRONG COMPARED TO A LOT
OF THE OTHER PROGRAMS.
I'M FASCINATED TO WHEN I LOOK
AT SOME OF THE THE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS WITHOUT WITHIN ALL THE
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES.
THAT PUT PUT VETERAN SHARE WITH
ME IS THAT.
THEY NEED A PLACE WHERE THEY CAN
GO IN FIRST OF ALL HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THEMSELVES
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES TO THE
CHALLENGES SHE DID FEEL THEY
DON'T HAVE ANYONE TO TO TALK
WITH ABOUT WHAT THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCED.
AND SO I I THINK THAT IF WE CAN
CONTINUE PROGRAMS AND AND THOSE
ARE OF.
PROGRAMS I THINK THAT THE ART
REALLY HAS A STRONG POTENTIAL TO
HELP WITH.
THAT ALLOWS THE THE SERVICE
MEMBER OF THE FAMILY MEMBER I
WAS MENTIONING.
AT THE BEGINNING HERE. THAT IT
ALSO GETS INTO THE EDUCATION OF
ARTS BECAUSE IF YOU GET IT TO
THE CHILDREN YOU ALSO GET THE
PARENTS AND OFTENTIMES I'VE I'VE
FOUND. A LOT OF VETERANS HAVE
GOTTEN INTO ART PROGRAMS BECAUSE
THE CHILDREN BROUGHT THEM INTO
THE ARTS PROGRAM.
SO I WOULD SAY THERE TO LOOK
HOLISTICALLY. IS IT WOULD BE MY
ANSWER TOOK TO LOOK TO LOOK
HOLISTICALLY CROSSED WHAT PARTS
OF PROVIDING NOT JUST AT THE
SERVICE MEMORABLE BUT ALSO CARE
GIVER BUT ALSO. THAT THE CHAO.
AND THAT'S WHY I WENT TO THE
POINT OF MAKING THOSE STATISTICS
AND MY DISCUSSION BECAUSE.
THE CHILDREN ALSO A PART OF THIS
AND AND I WOULD JUST SAY ALSO
THAT.
IT'S NOT JUST THE.
PTSD TBI END OF THE SPECTRUM
THAT THAT YOU WE ADDRESS
SOMEWHERE. A LOT OF THESE
CHALLENGES COME WILL FUND
TRANSITION FROM THE MILITARY
RIGHT AND GOING BACK INTO THE TO
TO CIVILIAN LIFE.
IT ALSO HAS TO DO WITH LIFESTYLE
I MEAN THAT THE CHALLENGES THEY
FACE HAVE FINANCIAL IMPLICATIONS
IT HAS SUICIDE IMPLICATE ME DOES
A LOT OF. ASPECTS OF THE
SPECTRUM THAT.
THAT THAT ART CAN ALSO ALLOW
THEM TO HEAL IN THE HEALTH AND.
I HOPE I ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION.
THANK YOU YES.
INFANT. CONTROVERSIAL OKAY I
THINK YOU BRIDGES CEMETERY BAY
FOR SUGAR.
YOUR INSIGHTS AND AND I MOST
IMPORTANTLY APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK.
IN THIS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
CONFLUENCE
ZONE PARA AND WILL BE LEARNING A
LOT MORE ABOUT IT IS AS WE GO
ALONG TODAY SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT OVERVIEW. AND LET'S NOW
MOVE TO OUR SECOND PANEL WHICH
INVOLVES VETERANS VOICES
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES FOR
VETERANS ENGAGED.
WITH THE ARTS AND I THINK WHAT
WE PROBABLY WANT TO DO JUST
GIVEN THE AND.
THE NUMBER OF.
AN ANALYSIS YEAR HOW MANY SEATS
WE HAVE.
GREEN OF THE CARE.
ISRAEL DID YOU END UP COULD YOU
POSSIBLY WORK FROM OVER THERE
SAMMER. HISTOGRAM.
NO QUESTION RESERVE.
CAN WE SERVICE FOR HERE.
YEAH YEAH.
OR IS OR SHOULD WE.
THEY WANT IT SO YOU CAN'T YOU
SEE I HAVE TO BE THE TABLE IS
ARE YOU SAYING HE DOES BECAUSE
HE KNOWS HE'S.
OKAY WELL SPECIFIC AREAS ON IT
DOESN'T IT GIVES YOU GO TO A
COZY WE HAVE FOUR. PEOPLE ON THE
PANEL. HA SO. BUT YOU KNOW THESE
ARE ALL. VETERANS THERE USE THE
TIGHT QUARTERS.
THIS COULD HURT HIM. LET'S
LET'S HEAR LET'S WILL WILL BRING
UP ADAM STONE WHO'S A RETIRED
MARINE GUY WHO IS A MEMBER OF SO
SAY WE ALL.
WE ALSO HAVE PHYLLIS MILLER I
RETIRED US NAVY AND AN ARTIST
AND CREATOR FOUNDER OF THE.
VETERANS ARE AT VENUE.
CHRISTOPHER LA VERO WHO'S A
RETIRED US ARMY FOUNDER OF
LAWYERS FOR PEACE THEATER IN A
PRISON AND THE VETERANS PROJECT
IN DIABLO DANCE.
AND ALSO AMBER HOY US ARMY
RETIRED ARTIST ARTISTS PROGRAMS
MANAGER FILES FROM THE CALL ARTS
INSTITUTE IS THIS TUBE TYPE
BICU HAS A. UNIQUE A
GRANDPARENT.
.
NOW ALL OF THESE FOLKS FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING ARE WERE ACTIVELY
DEFLATED IN VIETNAM IRAQ AND OR
AFGHANISTAN.
AND.
SOME MORE DRAWN TO OUR.
AT AN EARLY AGE THEY WENT ON TO
SERVE THEIR COUNTRY AND THEN SAW
CREATIVE EXPRESSION IN DIFFERENT
WAY ONCE THEY RETURNED. TO
CIVILIAN LIFE SOME OF THEM
DISCOVERED ARE YOU COULD IF
THERE BE FOR THE FIRST TIME IS
WAYS OF.
POLICE TO COMMUNICATE ABOUT
THEIR FEELINGS ARE SOMETIMES
UNIMAGINABLE EXPERIENCES AND.
I'M AND AND WHICH ULTIMATELY
HELP THEM TO BOTH RECONNECTING
HE ON THE FORCE ARE NOW TRYING
TO SHARE THOSE EXPERIENCES WITH.
THEIR FELLOW VETERANS IF WE'VE
COME BACK FROM COMBAT UNTIL THE
PART WHERE LIKE CITED HERE YOUR
PERSONAL PERSPECTIVES IN ON THE
GROUND PERSPECTIVES OF AS YOU AS
VETERANS.
CONCERT WITH YOU ADAM YES SIR.
.
BOB STONE ONE THANK YOU FOR THE
ARMY TO BE HERE TODAY AND I'M.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF SO SO SO
WE ALL TO EXIST WITHIN SAN
DIEGO.
.
I'M SORRY. I'M HERE WITH THEIR.
WITH FOR THE RIVERS AND SO SAY
WE ALL IT'S AN ORGANIZATION
WITHIN SAN DIEGO AND HELPS
PEOPLE TELL THEIR STORIES TO
TELL THE BETTER.
.
TO WORK WITH A LOT OF PROGRAMS.
A LOT OF GROUPS DIED.
OUR TALK ABOUT A LOT BUT I DON'T
GET A CHANCE AT THE VOICE THAT
HEARD. AND ARE FROM ONE OF OUR
FOCUSES ON VETERAN COMMUNITY.
TOM IT'S BEST FOR ME TO DESCRIBE
WHAT INSTEAD OF DESCRIBING WHAT
WE DO. IS TO READ WHAT I HAVE
BEEN. BUT I'VE DONE.
UNTIL IT WHERE DID YOU WHERE DID
YOU SERVE SENT AND. I CERTAINLY
CORPORATE TWENTY YEARS FROM
NINETEEN NINETY THREE TO TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN I WAS IN IRAQ
AND AFGHANISTAN WILL COMBAT
TOURS THROUGHOUT THE WORLD. AND
ABOUT MUCH MORE THE PEACEKEEPING
MISSION THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
THIS STORY IS ONE OF THE STORIES
THAT SO SO WE ALL HELP ME CREATE
AND THAT SINCE BEEN PUBLISHED
AND RADIO TELEVISED.
THROUGH MY SCOPE I SEE HIM
STANDING THERE.
ON THE BRINK OF OBLIVION.
IMAGINING HIS* PLEASE
EXISTENCE.
WHETHER TO TAKE THAT STEP.
HE SWAYS WITH THE MILD WHEN
ALLOWING ITS PRES TO CARESS HIM
LIKE A MOTHER ROCKS HER CHILD.
HE LOOKS OVER HIS SHOULDER. AS
IF TO SEE IF SOMEONE IS THERE TO
GIVE ENCOURAGEMENT.
THERE IS NO ONE.
I IMAGINE HE IS ALONE IN THIS
WORLD AND THAT THIS IS ONLY WAY.
THAT HE TURNED TO LOOK IN HIS
EYE HAS CHANGED NO LONGER IS IT
FAIR BUT THAT.
OF DETERMINATION.
HE TAKES THE STEP IDLING CLOSER
AS IF TO STOP HIM I SCREAM IN MY
HEAD FOR HIM TO GO BACK. MY HAND
INSTINCTIVELY REACHES OUT AS
THOUGH I COULD PUSH HIM
BACKWARDS FROM FIVE HUNDRED
YARDS AWAY.
I CLOSE MY EYES CRINGING AT THE
ANTICIPATION OF THE COMMOTION
THAT IS ABOUT TO OCCUR.
DEAFENING SILENCE.
I STRENGTHENED MY RESOLVE AND
LOOK BACK THROUGH THE SCOPE
WATCHING HIM WALK TOWARDS ME.
I HAVE TRAINED FOR TWENTY YEARS
TO SURVIVE IN A COMBAT SITUATION
HOW TO FIGHT HOW TO READ OTHERS
TO DETERMINE IF THEY ARE A
THREAT. I HAVE TRAINED FOR
DECADES TO STRENGTHEN MY MIND
ANDBODY I'VE MASTERED THE ART
OF HAND TO HAND COMBAT I CAN
ACTRESS TO MY RIFLE AND SITES
ARMED WITH NEAR PINPOINT
ACCURACY. I HAVE LEARNED TO NUMB
MY EMOTIONS BY THE LOSS OF MY
CLOSEST FRIENDS.
AND SING WHAT MY OWN RIFLE CAN
DO TO THE ENEMY.
I CAN SHOOT A MAN IN THE CENTER
OF THIS CHEST FROM NEARLY FIVE
HUNDRED YARDS AWAY. AND PUT MY
KNIFE THROUGH HIS THROAT SO
CLOSE I CAN COUNT THE NUMBER OF
CAVITIES IN HIS MOUTH.
I HAVE GONE THROUGH
PSYCHOLOGICAL PROFILES BEFORE
AND AFTER EVERY COMBAT TOUR JUST
TO ENSURE I CAN STILL BE
CONSIDERED.
SAYING.
HE WALKS TOWARDS ME ALL MY YEARS
OF TRAINING MIGHT DECADES OF
EXPERIENCE MANAS
LIKE SMOKING A BREEZE I'M LOST
IN THE SEA OF A MOTION. THERE HE
WAS A CHILD NO OLDER THAN MY OWN
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD SON WALKING
TOWARDS ME.
BUT NOT TO ME.
HE'S WALKING TO A DISCARDED
VEHICLE LEFT IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
ANCIENT MIND FILL. A
LEFTOVER-FROM A PAST FOR A
CONSTANT MONTH
REMINDER OF THE HORRORS THIS
COUNTRY HAS SEEN.
HE WALKS WITH PURPOSE. KNOWING
THAT IF HE MAKES MAKES A TO THAT
SHATTERED WHOLE CORRODING IN THE
SAND HE MIGHT BE ABLE TO FIND
SOMETHING THAT DIDN'T SELL TO
THE TALIBAN HE KNOWS. THAT THE
PRICE IS HIGH.
THE BIGGER THE ITEM THE MORE
DESTRUCTIVE CAN BE THE BETTER
OFF HE WILL BE. AN OLD ARTILLERY
SHELL COMPETING FOR A MONTH BUT
ANYTHING SALAS COMPUTING FOR A
DAY POSSIBLY A WEEK.
HE KNOWS THAT THE MARINES
GUARDING THE SMALL OUTPOST JUST
FIVE HUNDRED YARDS AWAY ARE
AUTHORIZED TO SHOOT AND KILL
ANYONE THEY DEEM A THREAT. HIS
LIVELIHOOD DEPENDS ON WHAT HE
FINDS.
JUST AS THE WEAPON HE WEARS
ACROSS HIS BACK IT HIS WAY TO
SURVIVE.
HE'S BEEN RAISED HERE AND HE
KNOWS THAT THERE IS SAFETY IN
THE FIELD. SEEN SO MUCH DEATH.
MANY HAVE TRIED BEFORE HIM THE
BILL THE STREWN WITH SIGNS OF
THOSE WHO LEFT FELL.
SHREDS OF CLOTH HERE A CRATER
THERE EVEN IF SHE WERE TO.
HE KNOWS.
WHERE DEATH ONCE WAS
HE IS SAFE?
PORTLAND MY CAN ONLY EXPLODE
ONCE.
HE RIDES AT A CRATER AND JUMPS
INSIDE RESTING FOR A MOMENT
KNEELING DOWN AS IF TO PRAY TO
HIS GUIDE.
TO GIVE HIM STRENGTH TO CONTINUE
HIS JOURNEY AS HE HUNKERS DOWN
INTO THE DEPRESSION.
I SEE MY OWN CHILDREN.
PLAYING AT THE BEACH
BUILDING SAND CASTLES BEARING
EACH OTHER. LAUGHING AS THEY
WANTED TO JUMP RUN AND JUMP AND
HOLES NOT MUCH DIFFERENT THAN
THE ONE THE BOYS BURSTING IN
NOW.
ONLY THREE HUNDRED YARDS FROM MY
POSITION.
FROM THIS DISTANCE I CAN EASILY
HIT MY TARGET.
THE WIND IS SLIGHTLY BLOWING
FROM RIGHT TO LEFT THE SUN IS
BEHIND ME. EVERYTHING ALL
SHADOWS AND HIGHLIGHTING MY
TARGET.
AND ACTUALITY WOULD BE AN EASY
SIDE.
CAN BE JUSTIFIED UNDER THE
CURRENT RULES OF ENGAGEMENT.
AS I SIGHED IN ON THE BOY. I
MAKE THE APPROPRIATE ADJUSTMENTS
TO MY RIFLE.
I PROGRESS THE PISTOL GRIP.
BONUS SLIGHTLY TOWARD ME.
ANSWERING THAT THE STOCK OF THE
WEAPON IS COMFORTABLY IN MY
SHOULDER.
I REST THE BARREL OF THE WHAT MY
WEAPON IN THE PLM MY FOREHAND
ALLOWED TO JUST REST THERE.
WAITING UNTIL THE MOMENT IS
NECESSARY.
MY TRIGGER FINGER HOVERS NEXT TO
TRIGGER.
WAITING FOR THE MOMENT.
MY SHOOTING POSITIONS PERFECT.
NO ONE NO ONE WOULD QUESTION WHY
I PULLED THE TRIGGER.
I'D MORE THAN LIKELY GET A FEW
GOOD JOBS AND WHILE FROM THE
YOUNGER LESS SEASON MARINES WHO
TALK OPENLY ABOUT SEEM TO SING
ACTION AND ONE IN THE SHOULD
SOMETHING OTHER THAN A PAPER
TARGET. YOUNG MARINES WHO HAVE
BEEN RAISED THAT PART OF THE
TELEVISION SCREEN PLANE MODERN
WELL WARFARE AND SIMULATED WARS
AROUND THE WORLD.
WHO ALSO TEND TO TREAT LIFE AS
JUST ANOTHER SIMILARITY?
BUT THERE IS NO RESET BUTTON NO
PAUSE AND NO CHEAT CODES.
I HOLD MY POSITION WATCHING THE
TARGET WITH MY FINGER NEXT TO
TRIGGER.
HE LIFTS HIMSELF OUT OF HIS HOLE
AND STANDS AT THE THRESHOLD.
HIS PRIDE IN THEIR FIFTY YARDS
AWAY.
BUT I MIGHT AS WELL BE ONE
HUNDRED ONE THOUSAND EVEN TEN
THOUSAND. FOR THE DISTANCE ISN'T
THE PROBLEM.
IT'S WHAT'S BETWEEN AND
UNDERNEATH.
HE TAKES A STEP AND BEGINS TO
WALK AS HE MOVES HIS EYES ARE
EVER VIGILANT SHIFTING SEARCHING
FOR TELL OF SOMETHING SOME KIND
OF DANGER.
BUT STEP AFTER BUT STEP HIS BODY
TENSES THAT MIGHT BE HIS LAST.
I GUESS SEEM CLEARER NOW.
THE SWEAT OF HIS BROW THE DIRT
ON HIS FACE. EVEN BEGINNING OF
MANHOOD AS A SLIGHT WISPY
MUSTACHE STARTED TALKING ABOUT
THE SLIP.
I CAN ALSO SEE THAT HE IS NO
STRANGER TO WAR.
A RAGGED SCAR RUNS FROM WHERE
HIS LEFT EAR SHOULD BE.
TO THE CORNER OF HIS MOUTH.
HE'S MISSING TWO FINGERS FROM
HIS LEFT HAND AND I POSTULATE.
THAT HIS ENTIRE LEFT SIDE OF HIS
BODY IS BATTLE DAMAGED IN SOME
WAY.
POSSIBLY. THE AFFECTS OF A LAND
MINE HE WAS PORTION TO WALK AWAY
FROM.
MORE THAN LIKELY.
BECAUSE I'VE SEEN TOO MANY
TIMES.
WHEN HE WAS AN INFANT HIS MOTHER
SHOW THEM FROM THE DANGER
PROTECTING HIM WITH HER BODY.
LEAVING SCARS CLOSELY IT JUST
TWENTY FIVE
YARDS AWAY FROM HIS PRIZE.
S. PACE IS SLOW AND METHODICAL
CHOOSING EACH STEP CAREFULLY.
I CAN REMINISCE OF MY CHILDREN.
WHEN I SEND THEM TO BED FOR THE
EVENING THE SLOW INTENTIONAL
WALK DOWN THE HALL HOPING A
REPRIEVE MIGHT COME FOR ME
ALLOWING THEM JUST WATCH ONE
MORE SHOW.
NO REPRIEVE EVER COMES FOR ME.
NOR WILL THAT BE FOR THE BOY WHO
WENT RISK WHERE EARLY IN MY
SIGHTS.
HE'S ONLY YARDS AWAY THE
PREVIOUS LABOR WITHIN TS GRASP
MY BODY STIFFENS READY TO FIRE.
HE CLIMBS INTO THE MANGLE THE
MASS OF THE VEHICLE IT'S ANCIENT
ARMOR SHIELDED FROM MY GAZE.
THE WORLD ENVELOPES ME.
BEHIND ME I CAN HEAR THE DISTANT
SOUND OF MUSIC PLAYING ON THE
RADIO MARINES ON A BREAK FROM
THE WHAT LIES OUTSIDE OUR WALLS
ARE PLAYING CARDS ON.
HIDE THEIR MINDS.
THE SMELL OF BAKED CHICKEN BEING
PREPARED THE EVENING MAILBOX UP
TO ME
AND FOR A MOMENT I CAN RELAX.
TECH.
THE SECONDS SLOWLY PASSES.
WHEN I SEE THE EXCEPT THE BOY
EXITING THE VEHICLE I AM
FUNNELED BACK INTO MY INTO THE
REALITY THAT LAY IN FRONT OF ME.
AND IS HANDED THE WOODEN BOX
FILLED WITH MISCELLANEOUS WIRES
AND PIECES OF SCRAP METAL.
RESTING ON TOP IS HIS PERSONAL
FORTUNE A CYLINDRICAL SHAPED
OBJECT RESEMBLING AN OLD SOVIET
MORTAR SO.
THE BOY DOESN'T WASTE ANY TIME
HE BEGINS CROSS IN THE FIELD AS
POSSIBLE AS FAST AS POSSIBLE
ATTEMPTING TO RETRACE HIS STEPS
THAT HAVE BROUGHT HIM TO THIS
TREASURE TROVE.
THUD THUD DIED EMPTYING AND
FILLING UP MY HEART IS NOW
KEEPING TIME I TIGHTEN MY
POSITION TO ENSURE I CAN GET A
CLEAN SHOT THE BOY HAS NOW
BECOME THE ENEMY NEVER MIND THE
RIFLE HE WEARS ACROSS HIS BACK
EVERY SIX YEAR OLD IN THIS
COUNTRY HOUSE ONE.
THE MORTAR SHELL IF SOLD TO THE
TALIBAN COULD BE USED AGAINST
THE MARINES AND SOLDIERS IN THE
FIELD. HE MOVES QUICKLY I JUST
FOR SPEED MY FINGER SLIPS INTO
THE TRIGGER WELL AND I COULD
FEEL THE WARMTH OF THE STILL AS
I PLACE LIKE PRESSURE. MY WEAPON
IS READY HE REACHES A CRATER
WHERE I IMAGINE HIM PRAYING AND
ABRUPTLY STOPS.
HE'S FROZEN.
NOT A MUSCLE IS MOVING I CAN
FILL THE BARREL OF MY RIFLE
BEARING DOWN ON HIM.
HE'S MOTIONS
BEADS OF SWEAT ROLLED DOWN HIS
BACK BACK HIS NECK.
HE'S BREATHING HEAVILY.
HE STANDS FOR WHAT SEEMED LIKE
ETERNITY.
CLICK.
I APPLY MORE PRESSURE TO MY
TRIGGER. HE SLOWLY LOWERS THE
BOX OF GOOD DOWN FROM HIS CHEST
AND LOOKED TOWARDS THE SKY.
CLICK.
I PLACED MY THUMB ON THE SAFETY
READY TO UNLEASH THE DOGS OF WAR
POEM.
THE OUTPOST SIREN STARTS WELLING
AND EVERY MARINE FROM AROUND THE
COMPOUND.
STOP WHAT THEY'RE DOING OF
BRUSHES THE PRIMER WITH RIFLES
AND HAND TO DEFEND OUR POSITION.
IT TAKES THE CLOUD. OF SAND AND
DEBRIS FROM THE EXPLOSION TEN
MINUTES TO FINALLY SETTLE.
AFTER A FEW MINUTES DAHLE
CLEAREST SOUNDED AND EVER GOES
BACK TO WHAT THEY WERE DOING
BEFORE. THE MUSIC STARTS. AND
THE GAMES PLAY.
BUT I HELPS WE LOOK OUT ACROSS
THE BILL OF OBLIVION.
I TORN ABOUT MOTION SWELLS I'M
CONFUSED WASN'T ME NO MY WEAPON
IS STILL UNSAFE WHERE IS THE BOY
HE'S GONE.
I.
I'M THANKFUL.
IT WASN'T ME. I DIDN'T HAVE TO.
I WOULD HAVE IF I COULD HAVE BUT
THIS TIME THIS TIME IT WASN'T MY
CHOICE
MY SOUL THOUGH EMPTIED.
STILL INTACT.
I AM ANGRY AND DEMORALIZED I
UNDERSTAND WHY THE POINT MADE
THE TRACK ALL THIS CHILD WANTED
TO DO WAS TO LIVE TO SURVIVE I
THINK OF ALL THE CHILDREN THAT A
PROSELYTE PATH. THE ONES ON THE
SIDE OF THE ROAD BACKING FOR
CHANGE THE ONES IN REFUGEE CAMPS
WAITING AND NEVER ENDING LINES
EVEN THE ONES THAT HAVE STOLEN
FROM ME.
THEY ALL HAD ONE THING IN COMMON
THE WILL TO SURVIVE THAT BOY WAS
DOING ALL HE WANTED TO DO TO
SURVIVE HE WAS LOOKING FOR A WAY
TO SURVIVE FOR MORE THAN JUST
TODAY.
JUST SO WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO WALK
THROUGH A MINEFIELD TOMORROW.
AS I WALK OFF THE PLANE A FEW
MONTHS LATER I SEE MY CHILDREN
STANDING THERE. AT THE EDGE OF
THE RUNWAY.
I COULDN'T HELP BUT THINK OF THE
BOY IN HIS TRACK AND ALL THAT IT
HAPPENS.
I HAVE KILLED.
I HAVE HEARD OTHERS.
JUSTIFIED OR NOT.
BUT I ALSO LOVED AND CARED FOR
MY ENEMY AS I HAVE LOVED AND
CARP MY OWN CHILDREN.
NOW HERE THEY ALL ARE.
RUNNING TO ME.
THANK YOU.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S SO SAY WE ALL
DOES FOR ABOUT COMMUNITY.
WE GIVE THEM A VOICE.
HERE.
BUT THE SURGEON APPRECIATED IF
YOU.
ALRIGHT.
MISS MILLER HERE SIR.
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR ITS HOSPITALITY. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE HONOR OF BEING
HERE.
OF FOR HAVING A LISTENING EAR.
BECAUSE MANY OF THE VETERANS
THAT I SPEAK FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF. A DOES ANYONE
CARE. OF OUR WE USE SOME TYPE OF
FOLLOW TRINKET TO BE ON THE
MANTLE. MANTLE OR DESK AND PULL
DOWN WHEN IT'S BECOMES A HOLIDAY
TO. GIVE KUDOS TO US AND I USE
IT GOOGLE'S IN THE.
CLICHE.
IT IS A PHILOSOPHY IN THE NAVY
DID.
WE ALWAYS LIKE TO LIVE BY IT IS
BETTER TO APOLOGIZE.
THE AND ASK FOR PERMISSION.
AND I SAY THAT IS HOW THE BIRTH
OF THE VETERANS ORG VENUE WAS
FOUNDED AND STARTED.
THROUGHOUT THE VETERAN COMMUNITY
I'M A IN AN OUTPATIENT AT THE
WEST LOS ANGELES VA HOSPITAL.
AND IN MY AND COUNTERS WITH THE
WONDERFUL DOCTORS THERAPISTS.
ALL THE ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF IN
AMONG THE VETERAN COMMUNITY.
THERE WAS A COMMON GOAL.
BUT THERE WAS A DISCONNECT. IN.
BETWEEN EACH COMPONENT.
AND THROUGH AN EXPERIMENT.
I LAUNCH THE VETERANS ARE VENUE.
I WAS CHASTISED BECAUSE I DIDN'T
GO THROUGH PROPER PROCEDURES.
AND I WAS CHALLENGED TO FIND DEL
IS THERE A MARKET REALLY FALL
FAR.
CAN I RELATE TO THEM TO SAY ART
IS NOT A LUXURY PART IS
ESSENTIAL ART IS A VERY
COMPONENT.
THE BIG BREEDS.
REFLECTION TRANQUILITY AND
THOUGHT.
VETERANS WHO HAVE BEEN TRAINED
CONDITION. AND UNDER THE RIGHT
CONDITIONS EMOTIONS.
SENSITIVITY. MINDFULNESS AND
ALL OF THOSE ITEMS ARE NOT PART
OF THE DECORUM IN THE MILITARY.
ONCE YOU LEAVE THE MARYLAND
MILITARY.
YOU REALIZE THAT YOU BECAME
HUMAN AGAIN.
AND THROUGH ART. THAT IS THE
BRIDGING OF THE GAP.
THAT IS ALSO A COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE COMMUNITY. OF
CIVILIANS WHO HAD NEVER SERVED.
BUT YET APPREHENSIVE. BUT YEAH.
EVASIVE.
AND I HAVE PUT A ONE. ALREADY
EXHIBITS WERE BOTH COMMUNITIES
THE VETERANS IN THE CIVILIANS.
THE COME TOGETHER. LOOKING
UNIQUE ART. AND FROM ONE MY LEFT
EAR FOR MORE RIGHT HERE IT COULD
BE A CIVILIAN ASKING ME.
WHILE THIS IS VERY INTERESTING I
DO KNOW VETERANS FEEL THIS WAY.
BOB HOW DO YOU TALK TO THEM.
FROM THE VETERANS BROKE
PERSPECTIVE ALL USE ONE OF THEM.
WHOLE I DIDN'T KNOW THAT THEY
CARE THEIR HERE. THAT THEY WANT
TO KNOW ABOUT US.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE VETERANS
WHO OR.
REPRESS SCENE IN OF SUBMERGING
INFORMATION NOT ASKING FOR HELP
BECAUSE HE TOO AFRAID TO ASK FOR
HELP OR TO INDEPENDENT TO ASK
FOR HELP. AND THROUGH THESE ART
VENUES THEY EITHER GET ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN OUR.
EVEN THOUGH THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
EXPERIENCE WITCHES AN OPEN MIND
IS ALL I ASK OF ANY OF MY ART
VENUES THROUGH. A FUND TERMDID
I GIVE. IN INTENTIONALLY USE.
IN ORDER TO KEEP.
PEOPLE DISARM FROM LABELS AND
THIS VENUE IS CALLED PAINT AND
SIP.
A FUN.
FLAVOURS OF TEA FINGER FOODS
PARTS SUPPLIES. AND THEY SIT
DOWN AND I WE ILLUSTRATE ALL S.
YOU'D HAVE IS AN OPEN MIND.
AND THE APPREHENSIVE THE
VETERANS. AND THE THERAPIST AT
THE BOTTOM LINE THE IN THE OF
EACH PLANE INCIDENT.
THE THERAPIST THE DOCTORS ALL
NOTICE
THAT THE VETERAN AFTER THE
EXPERIENCE WITH THE PAIN ZIP IS
VERY RECEPTIVE TOWARD. MEDICAL
TREATMENT COUNSELING AND SO
FORTH BECAUSE THE CREATIVITY.
KNOCKS DOWN THE WALLS OF BEING.
DIVISIVE ARE BEING OF WITH HILL
OR THE PTSD SYNDROMES AND SO
THEREFORE THE HEALING PROCESS OF
ART. AT. THE BATES THROUGH
CREATIVITY.
AND THROUGH THESE PAINS SIPS I
WAS ABLE TO PROVE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN TWO THOUSAND NINE
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN. TO THE
EARLY DATE OF CURRENT THAT PAIN
SOUPS OR ESSENTIALS.
MANY OF THE STAFF I'D I DON'T
WANT TO NAME ANY NAMES WHO WERE
VERY VERY RESISTANCE TO IT SO
THEREFORE I DID NOT RECEIVE ANY
SUPPORT. TO THE POINT WHERE
BEING A VETERAN.
AND STAYING TRUE TO THE ART.
I'VE ACTUALLY PAWN JEWELRY TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN.
AND I'M VERY PROUD TO DO THAT
BECAUSE IT HAS TO GET DONE IN
THE MILITARY WHENEVER WE HAVE AN
ASSIGNMENT. UNDER ANY CONDITION
IT HAS TO GET IT DONE.
AND SO I FEEL THAT THIS IS A
MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH
BECAUSE.
ONLY ONE THIRD PAINS SIT.
IT DID BRING ME TEARS WHEN.
A VETERAN AROUND ELEVEN O'CLOCK
AT NIGHT CALLED ME. AND SAID
THAT IF SHE HAD MISSED THAT
PAINS.
THAT SHE WAS GOING TO TAKE A LOT
OF VALUES IN THEN SO.
CIVIL.
SHE SAID THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHEN IS THE NEXT ONE. I GO
THROUGH THE VA FROM TIME TO TIME
WHEN IS THE NEXT ONE.
AND SO I STRUGGLE WITH MAJOR
ORGANIZATIONS THAT. WOULD SAY
WHILE YOUR MISSION IS WELL
MEANING.
YEAR TWO SMALL.
HOLD VETERANS ARE REALLY NOT
INTERESTED IN ART. AND I WAS SAY
YOU WANNA BET.
SO.
I FORM THE VETERANS OUR VENUE AS
AN ARTIST BECAUSE MY.
MY MOTHER WAS IN THE ARMY.
SHE WAS A COLONEL.
AND FROM THAT POINT. FORWARD
HELD HER THROUGH THE DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES IN THE YEAR OF
NINETEEN FORTY TWO AND THEN
SOME.
AND AS AN ARTIST MYSELF BEFORE
THE MILITARY I HAD ALREADY
EXPERIENCED THROUGH ARTS IN A
CULTURE DESIGN.
AND THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
THE CITY HALL. ALI EXHIBIT MY
WORK FOR FIVE YEARS. AND THE
FILL VETERANS AMONG THE
COMMUNITY. GOT TO KNOW ME.
PHYLLIS MILLER HIS PARTED THE
ARTISTS THE PAINS.
SO RIGHT NOW AT THIS POINT. I AM
PLEASED TO BE HERE TO ILLUSTRATE
THAT.
MY PAIN SOUP. RIDGES THE GAS
BETWEEN THE CIVILIAN AND THE
VETERAN COMMUNITY.
MY PAIN RESERVE VIDEO RIGHT. YOU
AND SHOW ALL AYE HE SAID EMAIL
ON. THAT'S IT YEAH I THINK
THAT'S IT EXACTLY HOW WE GOT IT
WE GOT HERE.
BY THE WAY WHERE WHERE YOU
PHYSICALLY LOOK AT YOU SO IS IT.
THEM MARROW ONLY SANTA MONICA SO
GREAT OKAY US AND LOVE THE
WESTERLY VA IS MY. LOVE THE
SINNER TO THE COMMUNITY OF THE
VETERAN OBSERVER THE ART GALLERY
AND THE ARTS PART VENUE THAT
THIS SITUATED VIA HIS IDEAS IT.
I HAD I. GET THIS TIME I GOT
PERMISSION. TO USE SOME OF THE
FACILITIES AT THE VA TO HOLDS
THE PAIN SO. NO OKAY I OKAY ARE
INSTANTLY AND AND WE'RE GONNA IS
IT IN THE VIDEO YES OKAY YES I
WANT TO HAVE A VISUAL OKAY. ON
FINISH IT IS THEY'RE SENDING A
DEGREE URINARY HERE I'M JUST.
SO YES FEDERAL AGAIN THERE WERE
AWARE OF US I'M STILL DOWN IN
SAN DIEGO AND OFF WE THE JURY
FIND YOUR COLLEGES NOW
CONFERENCE.
I AM SIDES ARE YOU USING. FOLLOW
THIS VIDEO IS OF TWO DIFFERENT
PAIN SIEVES.
AND.
PAUL ONE OF THE WOMEN THERE WAS
THE ONE TO CALL ME THAT NIGHT
BUT I'M NOT GONNA. SAY YOUR NAME
IF YOU ARE TREASURE
CONFIDENTIALITY LIVES. THE VENUE
HERE IS ILLUSTRATING A GATHERING
AT THE PAIN SIEVE AND THE WHOLE.
PROCESS SO ENJOY IT. PLEASE
THINKING OKAY.
IGN
.
MMHM.
MMHM
.
I I DO WANT TO SAY THAT.
YEAH. EIGHT SIP OF MEN AND.
HE'LL.
VETERANS.
AGAIN THE.
BE A.
THAT THE MALE VETERANS.
HEAD
HIGHER EXPERIENCE
WITH THE MAIL THAT I.
CHOI.
WAS ABLE TO
TO.
DEAR.
BASED.
TWO LAWYERS WITHOUT ANYBODY'S
AUTHORIZATION.
THREW ON A PAIR.
IT WAS LIKE THIRTY SIX MAN
SHOWED UP.
FOUR HOURS ABOARD PIZZA THE ART
SUPPLIES AND THEY ENJOYED IT.
AND OF FROM THAT STANDPOINT.
BY I'M BEFORE YOU.
ARE HOLD THAT ANYWAY.
CAPITAL CAN BE AVAILABLE THROUGH
US.
TO FORTIFY THIS HEALING PROCESS.
THINKING FRANK PROCURE ALREADY
WHICH IT WHERE THEY SAID BY. UP
THREE FOURS WE HAVE LIMON OF.
OF GREEN TEA NOTE NO ALCOHOL OF.
BUT MAYBE IT MORE THE GUESTS TO
COME.
MATT ARE VERY NON
UNTIL THEM INGREDIENTS IT WAS
FOLLOWED. WITH A SAMPLE SWEETIE
TREATY OF THEIR INCOME IRON.
OKAY ALL RIGHT FANTASTIC WHAT'S
ON STRAIGHT NIGHT IDEA AND AND
THIS IS THIS IS ALL THAT OF THE
VA THIS THAT FELLOW WILL. WHEN I
WHEN I FIND A SPACE I HAVE A
PAIN SAID ANYWHERE ANYWAY
POSSIBLE CRIME BUT IT'S BEEN A
LOT OF TIMES AT THE VA. AND THEN
FROM THOSE PAY INCENTIVES.
.
I'D ENGAGE EACH VETERAN MANY OF
THEM ARE FINE OR SEASON ARTISTS.
BUT THAT JUST WANT TO BE THERE
JUST TO PAINT. EXCELL THEREFORE.
MY EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN TO HOLD
FURTHER THE FURTHER LEVEL TO
EMPOWER THEM FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO REFINE THEIR
ART WITH THE BUSINESS ACCURATE
TOOLS OF FINANCE. AS WELL AS TO
GET THEMSELVES TO BECOME
FINANCIALLY SELF SUFFICIENT AND
WHILE OUR IT BRINGS IN
TRANQUILITY. AND EVOKING THE
SENSES BECAUSE AGAIN ART IS NOT
A LUXURY.
WE KEEP THINKING.
OKAY THRILLER.
YES WE HAVE A SHORT VIDEO TO
SHOW.
WHILE HE'S DOING THAT.
MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER LA VERO
I'M A PARTICIPATED IN THE
DIABLO.
VETERANS DANCE PROGRAM AND THE
FOUNDER OF WARRIORS FOR PEACE
THEATER.
THE P..
SHOWS THAT.
FALL CONNECT
BETWEEN US AS VETERANS AND.
YOU ARE.
THE JOURNEY'S.
NBAE NAME IS.
THE ARTISTIC DIRECTOR.
WORK.
VOTERS. DO IT IN THEIR OWN.
FIND.
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE OTHER
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO ARE.
STRUGGLING
IN THEIR OWN WAY.
FRIEND.
THE WAY TO.
MANY.
THAT WE ARE TO.
DOING THIS.
NUMEROUS
PROGRAM.
I FELT
WELL I LIKE TO START BY SAYING
IT'S AN HONOR.
FOR ALL OF US TO BE UP HERE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CARING
ABOUT THIS VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
ISSUE.
WHO'S GONNA START BY TELLING YOU
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH ART AND MY
MILITARY BACKGROUND.
I NINE ELEVEN LIKE MOST OF YOU I
WATCHED IN HORROR AS THREE
THOUSAND AMERICANS WERE
MURDERED.
AFTER SEEING THIS I VOLUNTEERED
TO GO TO AFGHANISTAN.
I WANT TO PAY BACK.
I WANTED TO BE A PART OF THE
OPERATION TO HUNT DOWN AND
DESTROY THE PEOPLE WHO ATTACKED
US.
FINALLY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE. MY ARMY RESERVE UNIT WAS
ACCEPTING VOLUNTEERS.
BUT AFTER BEING MOBILIZED WE
WERE DIVERTED TO IRAQ Y. SERVED
IN MOSEL FOR A YEAR WHILE
ATTACKS THE SECOND INFANTRY
DIVISIONS. STRYKER BRIGADE
COMBAT TEAM OUT OF FORT LEWIS
WASHINGTON.
MY JOB WAS TO SAFEGUARD
CIVILIANS ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
AND I WAS ABLE TO PROVIDE
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE TO OVER
TWO THOUSAND DISPLACED REFUGEES.
SERVING OUR MILITARY.
AT BEING A PART OF THE GLOBAL
WAR ON TERROR.
WAS THE MOST SEMINAL EXPERIENCE
OF MY LIFE.
IT ALSO GREATLY AFFECTED ME.
I WAS IN COMBAT ALL THE WAY UP
UNTIL THE WEEK I FLEW HOME. AND
I COULD NOT GET THE WAR OUT OF
MY HEAD.
IT WAS LIKE IT PLAYED LIKE A
MOVIE INSIDE MY HEAD NONSTOP.
CONSTANT REOCCURRING IMAGES OF
DEAD CHILDREN HAUNTED ME. I WAS
HYPER VIGILANT AT ALL TIMES I
WAS ALWAYS ANGRY I COULDN'T
SLEEP I WAS DEPRESSED.
AND IT FELT LIKE THE WAR WAS
LIKE A LEAD BLANKET LYING ON TOP
OF ME SUFFOCATING ME.
IT WAS AS IF MY BODY WAS HOME
BUT MY MIND AND SPIRIT WERE
STILL IN IRAQ.
I COULDN'T ESCAPE THIS PAIN AND
ONE NIGHT I DECIDED THE ONLY WAY
TO BE FREE FROM IT WAS TO TAKE
MY LIFE.
I SELF MEDICAID WITH A BOTTLE OF
JACK DANIELS AND SET MY LIVING
ROOM WITH A LOADED GLOCK PISTOL
IN MY MOUTH.
I STARTED TO PULL THE TRIGGER.
IT WASN'T THAT I WANTED TO DIE.
IT'S JUST THAT I COULDN'T BEAR
LIVING ANYMORE.
SOMETHING STOPPED ME AND THE
NEXT DAY I WANT TO THE OAKLAND
BUT CENTER AND I GOT HELP.
I RELUCTANTLY ADMIT THAT AT
TIMES IT FEELS AS IF THE WAR
BROKE ME.
THERE IS A LOSS OF INNOCENCE
THAT YOU CAN NEVER GET BACK.
I WAS EXTREMELY PROUD TO DEFEND
OUR GREAT NATION AND I WOULD DO
IT AGAIN WITHOUT HESITATION.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT OUR WAR
FIGHTERS ARE NOT MACHINES.
WE'RE HUMAN BEINGS AND WAR IS
NOT AN ACTUAL HUMAN ENDEAVOR.
WHEN YOU SPEND A YEAR OF YOUR
LIFE OF PEOPLE ACTIVELY TRYING
TO KILL YOU EVERY DAY.
IT CAN TAKE A TOLL ON YOUR SOUL.
SO FOR THE NEXT TEN YEARS I
TRIED EVERYTHING. I COULD EVERY
FORM OF THERAPY. TO BECOME WHOLE
AGAIN.
I BATTLE WITH DEPRESSION AT
TIMES I WAS OVERCOME WITH
DESPAIR.
THAT I FOUND DIABLO THAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN A DECADE I FINALLY
BEEN AT PEACE.
DIABLO TAKES VETERANS ON AN
INTENSE JOURNEY LIKE NO WHETHER
IT'S A JOURNEY OF DISCOVERY. A
JOURNEY OF FACING YOUR DEMONS IN
WAYS THAT NO OTHER FORM OF
THERAPY CAN.
A MODEL OF EXPLORING MOVEMENT
AND DANCE.
AND THE WAY THAT FREES US HAS
ENABLED ME TO LET GO OF MY ANGER
SEE THE BEAUTY IN MYSELF AND
OTHERS.
AND HAS PROVIDED ME THE TOOLS TO
LIVE A POSITIVE PRODUCTIVE LIFE.
SPECIFICALLY DIABLO USES A MODEL
THAT REPLICATES THE SENSE OF
TRIBE. THAT MANY VETERANS LONG
TO HAVE AGAIN.
IT THEN BUILDS ON THE TRUST THAT
WE HAVE WITHIN THIS COMMUNITY
AND CHALLENGES US.
MENTALLY AND PHYSICALLY IN WAYS
THAT MAKE US REALIZE THE
BARRIERS.
BUT IF SHACKLED OUR LIVES ARE
MERELY ILLUSIONS AND THAT WE
HAVE THE POWER. AND RESILIENCY
TO OVERCOME THEM.
THEY'RE ONLY A COUPLE TIMES IN
MY LIFE.
WHAT I FULLY FELT THAT I WAS
LIVING IN THE MOMENT?
COMBAT.
I PERFORMING WITH DIABLO.
I HAVE.
FINALLY FOUND TRUE CATHARSIS.
OUR PROGRAM HAS BEEN SO
SUCCESSFUL THAT WE'RE INVITED TO
THE KENNEDY CENTER IN WASHINGTON
DC. FOR PERFORMED A SOLD OUT
CROWDS IN THE NATION'S MOST
PRESTIGIOUS FORMING ARTS CENTER.
I THINK IT'S JUST IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS PART BASED
PROGRAMS AS A MEANS OF HELPING
OUR VETERANS TO DEAL WITH THE
REINTEGRATION ISSUES AND HELP
THEM WITH THE PROCESS OF
HEALING.
PARK BASED STRATEGIES HELP
IS AT THE FOREFRONT OF
SUCCESSFULLY INTEGRATING THESE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS INTO THE
VETERANS COMMUNITY.
OUR GOAL IS TO MAKE THIS INTO A
NATIONAL PROGRAM.
BUT WE WANT TO START HERE IN OUR
HOME STATE.
WITH TWO MILLION VETERANS
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LARGEST
VETERANS POPULATION IN THE
COUNTRY.
SADLY.
THE INSANITY OF WAR IS STILL A
DEFINING CHARACTERISTIC OF OUR
SPECIES.
WHEREAS WAR REVEALS THE UGLY
SIDE OF HUMANITY PART.
IS THE DEFINING CHARACTERISTIC
THAT REVEALS THE POSITIVE SIDE
OF HUMANITY.
DIABLO PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR OUR WAR FIGHTERS TO REGAIN
THEIR HUMANITY
HE'LL FROM THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS
OF COMBAT.
AND MILITARY DEPLOYMENTS.
IT'S A MODEL THAT ALSO PROVIDES
A BRIDGE TO THE CIVIL MILITARY
DIVIDE.
LESS THAN HALF OF THEM EXCUSE
ME.
THE LESS THAN HALF A PERCENT OF
THE U. S. POPULATION HAS TAKEN
ON THE ENTIRE BURDEN. OF
FIGHTING OUR WARS IN THE LAST
SIXTEEN YEARS.
OTHER THAN MILITARY FAMILIES
VIRTUALLY NO ONE IN AMERICAN
SOCIETY IS AFFECTED BY THESE
WARS AND THE GAP IN
UNDERSTANDING. ARE VETERAN
POPULATION IS GROWING WIDER.
THIS IS PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE IN
ORDER TO SUCCESSFULLY
REINTEGRATE OUR VETERANS BACK
INTO CIVILIAN SOCIETY. THAT
SOCIETY HAS TO HAVE SOME STAKE
IN UNDERSTANDING OF THE VETERAN
POPULATION.
THE DIABLO MODEL DOESN'T JUST
HELP OUR VETERANS LIKE MYSELF
FEEL BUT IT PROVIDES A CATALYST
OF UNDERSTANDING FOR THE
CIVILIAN POPULATION AS WELL.
SEEING US PERFORM HEARING OUR
STORIES AND ENGAGING US IN THE
QUEUE AFTER THAT PERFORMANCE IS.
ALL HELP FURTHER THE
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT VETERANS
GO THROUGH WHO WE ARE AND WHAT
WE NEED AND HOW YOU CAN HELP.
THE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT ANYTHING
DOESN'T NO GOOD UNLESS IT'S
CONTEXTUALIZE IN A BROADER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PROBLEM.
IT PROVIDES PEOPLE WITH A BASIS
ON HOW TO ACT UPON THAT
KNOWLEDGE.
DIABLOS COLLABORATION WITH
CIVILIANS IN VETERANS PROVIDES
THIS CRUCIAL PIECE.
IN CLOSING I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT
THERE ARE THREE MAIN ISSUES ARE
AREAS. WE NEED HELP.
THOSE AREAS ARE LEGITIMACY
FINDING.
AND EXPANSION.
WE ASK THAT YOU HELP LEGITIMIZE
PART AS AN EFFECTIVE MEANS OF
HELPING VETERANS.
WE NEED BETTER ACCESS TO PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC FUNDING.
AND WE NEED HELP WITH EXPANDING
THIS PROGRAM BEYOND THE LOCAL
AREAS TO GIVE OTHER VETERANS
WIDER ACCESS TO THIS.
AND THESE OTHER PROGRAMS.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT THE
GREATEST GIFT.
BUT YOU CAN GIVE ANOTHER HUMAN
BEING IS THE GIFT OF LIFE.
AND JOCK KIND ARE DIRECTOR
JENNIFER CHANG OUR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND THEIR DANCERS HAVE
GIVEN ME THAT GIFT.
THIS WORK HAS SAVED MY LIFE.
I WAS ALMOST ONE OF THE
STATISTICS THAT TO READ ABOUT. I
WAS ALMOST ONE OF THOSE TWENTY
TWO A DAY.
THIS WORK.
THIS JOURNEY THIS PROCESS.
HAS CHANGED MY LIFE DIDN'T SAVE
MY LIFE AND WE WANT TO SHARE IT
WITH OTHER VETERANS.
SO PLEASE SUPPORT US IN THIS
ENDEAVOR TO POSITIVELY AFFECT
THE QUALITY OF LIFE OF THOSE WHO
ARE DEDICATED TO KEEPING OUR
COUNTRY SAFE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR.
ALRIGHT.
ONE NEXT YEAR FROM MEMBERS.
YEAH.
FROM SOUTH DAKOTA.
ALSO SERVED IN IRAQ.
YEAH.
HELLO I'M MEMBER WAY THINK YOU
FOR LETTING ME SPEAK TODAY.
I WAS IN THE ARMY FOR EIGHT
YEARS.
AND.
I'M AN ARTISTS I WORK AT
CALOTTERY INSTITUTE OF THE
ARTIST PROGRAM MANAGER I'M A
COMBAT VETERAN.
I A DEPLOYED TO IRAQ IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX.
AS AN AMMUNITION SPECIALISTS
THERE ARE FOUR WOMEN IN MY
UNITS.
ONE OF WHICH I WORKED WITH AND
SO BEING A WOMAN IN THE MILITARY
PRESENTS ITS OWN SET OF
CHALLENGES AND ONE OF THEM BEING
THAT THERE'S NOT VERY MANY OF
US.
WHEN PEOPLE IMAGINE A SOLDIER
THEY OFTEN DON'T THINK OF
SOMEONE THAT LOOKS LIKE ME. AND
THERE ARE SO MANY STORIES OF
WOMEN NOT BEING RECOGNIZED FOR
THEIR SERVICE I'M SURE YOU'VE
HEARD OF THEM AND PEOPLE. ASKING
WOMEN VETERANS AT THE VA AFTER
THERE TO PICK UP THEIR HUSBANDS
OR.
AND. THEIR IN THEIR FATHERS
SOON RECENTLY ASKED ME IF I WAS
A DOCTOR AT THE VA WHICH THAT'S
AN IMPROVEMENT I GUESS MAYBE.
I MET WOMEN VETERANS AND AFTER
SEPARATING FROM SERVICE THEY
MUST WAIT THE EXPERIENCES FROM
THEIR MINDS.
LIKE IT NEVER HAPPENS THEY DON'T
GO TO THE VA FOR RESOURCES
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO.
AND BEING A WOMAN IN THE
MILITARY CAN BE A LONELY
EXPERIENCE AFTER COMING BACK
SOMEHOW BECOMES MORE ISOLATED
AND.
A FEMALE VETERAN IS THE TWO
POINT TIMES MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
HER OWN TO TAKE HER OWN LIFE IN
A CIVILIAN WOMAN.
I AFTER I CAME BACK FROM IRAQ IT
AND TALK ABOUT IT I WAS TWENTY
ONE YEARS OLD AND IT TOOK ME
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AFTER MY
DEPLOYMENT TO START MAKING WORK
ABOUT THE MILITARY.
AND SERVICE. AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE IS A NEED TO SHARE.
AND IF THERE'S ONE THING THAT
I'VE LEARNED IS THAT WE'RE NOT
JUST TALKING ABOUT VETERANS
MAKING OUR WORKERS TALKING ABOUT
IT ON BUILDING A COMMUNITY AND
ST ACTIVE WITH THAT COMMUNITIES.
AND ABOUT STAYING ALIVE.
THE FOLLOWING IMAGES IS NEXT TO
IMAGES ARE FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO ART COMMISSION.
THAT EXHIBITION NOT ALONE I HAD
THE EXHIBITION WAS IN PART
FUNDED BY THE CDC VETERAN
PROGRAM.
HERE'S ANOTHER IMAGE OF MY WORK.
AND WHAT WAS MOST IMPORTANT TO
ME. ABOUT THIS SHOW WAS THAT I
GOT TO MEET MORE ART AS SOON
VETERANS THROUGH THE CREATION OF
THE SPACE.
EXHIBITIONS CAN BE A PLACE TO
SHARE IDEAS AND STORIES AND ASK
QUESTIONS. AND MY IN BOX FILLED
WITH MESSAGES FROM VETERAN WOMEN
EXPRESSING THAT THEY SAW MY WORK
AND HEARD MY STORIES. AND FOR
THEM IT WAS ON POINT
I'D FEEL GOOD FOR THEM TO KNOW
THAT SOMEONE WAS MAKING WORK AND
THAT THEIR EXPERIENCE WASN'T AS
ISOLATED AS I ONCE THOUGHT.
THIRTY THESE IMAGES I KIND OF
SAW.
THEIR GRASSROOT OF VETERAN OUR
PROGRAMS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
AND ONE SUCH UNOFFICIAL PROGRAM
WAS AND I UC BERKELEY AYE AARON
TOOL THE CERAMIC TACK OPENED UP
ONE OF THE UC BERKELEY I
WORKSHOPS. I CERAMIC TECH OR
SHOT. AND FOR TO EGG WEEKS WE'VE
MADE WORK WE DESCENDED UPON
BERKELEY WE HAD NO MONEY TO FUND
THIS PROGRAM.
BUT WE MADE IT HAPPEN AYE WE
SLEPT IN EVERY NOOK AND CRANNY
OF AARON'S HOME AYE WE MAKE
PAPER WE THREE POTS.
AND WE PUT ON AN EXHIBITION
GALLERY AYE WE WENT WE HUNG OUT
AYE WE WENT CAMPING RATE DINNER
AT THIS POINT I WAS LIVING IN
OHIO AND FINISHING MY GRAD
PROGRAM. AND.
OVER A YEAR LATER I GOT A JOB
AT CLARKE INSTITUTE AND I
INVITED VETERANS TO MAKE PRINTS
AND OUR SPACE AND WE SHARED
IDEAS AND COLLABORATE AND.
AND WE HAD FUN.
AND THIS IS AN IMAGE.
TRUE CAMERON THE ARTIST BEHIND
COMBAT PAPER COMBAT PAPER IS
PAPER MADE OUT OF MILITARY
UNIFORMS.
TRUE WAS AWARDED A FELLOWSHIP
THROUGH MY ORGAN IS
ORGANIZATIONS COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT PROGRAM AND WORK WITH
ANOTHER NONPROFIT CALLED
PLANTING JUSTICE.
CLINTON JUSTICE EMPLOYEES MAN
TRANSITIONING OUT OF PRISON.
THEY WORK TOGETHER AND USE
JURIES TECHNIQUES TO MAKE PAPER
OUT OF PRISON UNIFORMS.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE PARENTS
THAT VETERANS AND FORMER
PRISONERS WORKING TOGETHER ON
BUILDING A COMMUNITY ENSURING
AND SKILLS.
I VETERANS HOW TO DO IT DESIRE
TO SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
TO HELP.
AND ALSO DEEPLY DEEPLY
INTERESTED AND HOW VETERANS
AFTER THE USER GI BILL AND HOW
THEY'RE OUT OF SCHOOL. AND THEIR
PROFESSIONAL ARTISTS HOW DO THEY
SUSTAIN CAREERS ONE ACADEMIC
JOBS ARE THIN IAN HOW CAN WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT VETERAN. IN
OUR CAREERS.
SO THIS IS A PICTURE OF THE
PRINT STUDIO WHERE I WORK ON WE
LAUNCHED OUR FIRST VETERAN
RESIDENCY PROGRAM LAST YEAR. AND
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT I BROUGHT
TO COLLAGE. I MANDATE I MANAGE
SEVEN RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND THE
VETERAN ART PROGRAM IS ONE OF
TIME.
BECAUSE PRIMARILY A PRINTMAKING
STUDIO WE HAVE AT SHE IN THE FOG
THE SCREEN CRANIUM LETTERPRESS
AND NEW MEDIA. ARE FOR SOME
VETERANS IT WAS THEIR FIRST TIME
WORKING IN THIS MEDIUM.
THIS AWARD PROVIDED THEM WITH
THE STATE SEN.
A CLASS AND OBVIOUSLY THE
STUDIO RESIDENCY AND ALSO AN
EXHIBITION IN OUR GALLERY SPACE.
THE CURRENT OWNER NAM.
YEAH YEAH.
KIND OF I WANTED WELCOME CENTER
NIELSEN JIM NIELSEN IS WONDERFUL
MEMBERS THE STATE SENATE THE
DEAN OF THE SENATE.
AND A GREAT CHAMPION FOR
VETERANS FORMER CHAIR OF THE OF
THE VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VICE CHAIR BELIEVE. AND
WERE WERE ON A PANEL HERE
SENATOR RELATING TO VETERANS
VOICES USER. PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES OF VETERANS ENGAGE
OF THE ARTS AND WE'RE HEARING
FROM AMBER.
I WAS PRESENTING HER EXPERIENCE
IS THE IRAQ WAR VET.
CITIZENS MY LAST SLIDE AND I
JUST WANTED TO REITERATE THAT
THIS IS SO MUCH MORE THAN
VETERANS MAKING ARE WORTH IT'S A
SURVIVAL PLAN.
SO MANY VETERANS I'VE TALKED TO
AND DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY WOULD
HAVE DONE WITHOUT THE ARTS
PROGRAMS IF THEY ACCIDENTALLY
FELL INTO WARRIOR RIDING A
WRITER'S COMBAT PAPER THAT ARE.
BECAUSE IT PROVIDED A COMMUNITY
AND OUTLETS AND SMEWHERE TO BE.
AND IN ONE WAY OR ANOTHER THESE
PROGRAMS ARE VERY CONNECTED IT'S
KIND OF A NETWORK.
AND.
WOULD AS WINTER GRASS GOING
NOTICES SOME VETERAN ARTISTS
SHIED AWAY FROM THE WORK BEING
CATEGORIZED AS VETERAN ARTS THEY
WERE AFRAID THAT THEY'D BE
CONSIDERED ART THERAPY OR
HOBBYISTS. I ASKED A MENTOR HOW
SHOULD UNPACK THIS IS THIS IS
SOMETHING I SHOULD BE WORRIED
ABOUT. ANY TOLD ME THAT THAT WAS
RIDICULOUS THAT ALL ART IS ART
THERAPY AND S. HEAT THE WORK
THAT YOU MAKE IS NOT THERAPEUTIC
THING YOU'RE DOING IT WRONG.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK
TODAY.
OPEN HERE.
BOB A FANTASTIC PERSPECTIVES WE
REALLY FAST TO APPRECIATE EACH
AND EVERYONE OF UNICOR SUCH
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES TO.
COULD CHRISTOPHER CAN I START
WITH YOU AS I LOVE TO JUST ASK
YOU BET YOU DO YOU SPOKE A VERY
ELOQUENTLY ABOUT JAVELIN I I'VE
GOT A COUPLE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THAT BUT. I I KNOW YOU ALSO WERE
THE FOUNDER THE WORDS FOR PEACE
THEATER AND I LOVE YOU SPIEGEL
ABOUT THAT TOO.
SURE.
.
I DISCOVERED ACTING AS A FORM OF
CATHARSIS TO DEAL WITH SOME OF
MY ISSUES COMING BACK FOR MORE.
AND SOME OF MY THEATER MATES AND
FOR ME THAT THERE IS A GROUP OF
IRAQI ACTORS THEY WERE INVITED
TO THE OREGON SHAKESPEARE
FESTIVAL IN THE FORM.
APPARENTLY THEY WERE THE FIRST
GROUP OF ACTORS IN IRAQ THERE
WERE EVER ALLOWED TO PERFORM
SHAKESPEARE LIVE.
SO I THOUGHT WHAT AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY IF I CAN GET SOME
IRAQ WAR AMERICAN IRAQ WAR
VETERANS LIKE MYSELF.
TO PARTNER WITH THEM AND DO A
JOINT PRODUCTION AS A MEANS OF
BRINGING THE TWO GROUPS TOGETHER
TO HEAL.
AND GREAT IDEA BUT THERE WAS NO
MEANS TO GET IT DONE.
SO FIGURES LATER AYE I FORMED MY
OWN THEATRE COMPANY WARRIORS FOR
PEACE THEATER. AND HAS BASICALLY
TWO FOLD MISSION ONE WE USE
SHAKESPEARE THERE AS A FORM OF
CATHARSIS ARE VETERANS.
AND THE THE LARGER GOAL THE NEXT
PHASE TO BRING.
BUT FROM OTHER COUNTRIES.
TOGETHER WITH VETERANS FROM OUR
KIND AND DO A JOINT PRODUCTION
AS A MEANS OF HEALING AND
BUILDING P..
I'M TALKING SPECIFICALLY.
VETERAN VETERANS FROM COUNTRY
EITHER BEEN AT WAR WITH OUR HAVE
TOP RELATIONS WITH. THE IDEA
HERE IS THAT IF WE THE VETERANS
WHO FOUGHT THESE WARS CAN COME
TOGETHER IN PEACE THEN WHY CAN'T
EVERYBODY ELSE. IN MY PHILOSOPHY
IS ARTS TRANSCENDS POLITICS AND
BRINGS PEOPLE TOGETHER.
AND SO NOW WE ARE WE'VE BEEN WE
WERE DOING.
WORKSHOPS WHERE PEOPLE COME
TOGETHER AND EXPLORE SHAKESPEARE
AND IT PROVED TO BE A PROFOUNDLY
HEALING CATHARTIC EXPERIENCE.
TO GIVE A COUPLE EXAMPLES IN
RECENT.
I HAVE. PRIVACY DONORS PLAYS
WITH PARTICULAR GROUPS VETERANS
SURE.
WELL WHERE WE CURRENTLY ARE.
AND PRODUCTION PRE PRODUCTION
TO DO A FILM ADAPTATION OF
JULIUS CAESAR.
AND AT AND A STAGE PRODUCTION AS
WELL IN FACT AND WE TO BE
COLLABORATING WITH DIABLO TO ADD
SOME DANCE PIECES INTO IT WHAT
JULIUS CAESAR AMONG OTHER THINGS
A STORY ABOUT WAR TO WORRY ABOUT
THE TRAIL AND ASSASSINATION AND.
LOSS AND.
IT.
OUR COUNTRY'S BEEN WAR FOR
ALMOST SEVENTEEN YEARS AND HIS
OF THIS IS ABOUT PLAY ABOUT WAR
SO MY FOR MY THINKING IS WHAT WE
MODERNIZE IT. AND CAST A LOT OF
VETERANS WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
THESE WARS BECAUSE WHAT THEY CAN
BRING.
TO THAT IS INCREDIBLE THE
BREADTH OF UNDERSTANDING OF
HAVING EXPERIENCED COMBAT IN WAR
IS SOMETHING THAT NOT EVERYBODY
CAN DO. WE ALSO WANT TO
MODERNIZE IT AND BENT.
GENDER MEN SOME ROLES.
AND GIVE SOME OF THE MORE
TRADITIONAL ROLES LIKE MARC
ANTHONY TO TWO WOMEN ACTORS.
WE WANT TO HAVE A VERY
ETHNICALLY DIVERSE CAST.
AND SO THAT WERE JUST
MODERNIZING IT AND IN MANY
POSITIVE WAYS.
AND THAT ALL U. S. VETS IN THIS
PARTICULAR FRICTION ARE. AND IT
CRACKED AND CIVILIANS. RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT.
CURRENT.
YEAH PLEASE ANTHONY IF I MAY
INTERJECT MYSELF THERE'S A
MISSILE WHERE YOU KIND OF HAD A.
.
WARM SPOT WITH ME.
AT FIFTY THOUSAND INSPIRATION
AND.
MY REMARKS.
MAJOR SPEECHES OR JUST EVEN ONE
ON ONE.
I OFTEN QUOTE SHAKESPEARE'S
EXAMPLE OF IN JULIUS CAESAR AND
BRUTUS AND CASSIUS AND YOU'LL
APPRECIATE THIS ARE. DECIDING
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO DEAL WITH
THE INVADING ARMY.
AND.
.
CASH IS SAYS NO WE'LL GET IN THE
DEFENSIVE POSTURE AND COUNTER
ATTACK AND THEN BROUGH SAYS NO
AND IN SHAKESPEARE'S LOVELY
WORDS THERE'S A TIDE IN THE
AFFAIRS OF MEN WHICH YOU'VE
TAKEN AT THE FLOOD.
AT LEAST A FORTUNE OMITTED ALL
THE VOYAGE OF YOUR LIVE SHOW BE
BOUND IN THE SHALLOWS IN THE
MISERIES.
TO ME THAT WAS ALWAYS APPLICABLE
TO HOW WE LIVE OUR LIVES TO. NOT
LIVE OUR LIVES AND SHELVES IN
THE MISERIES
AND THE. THAT THAT JUST REMINDS
ME OF OF THAT VALUE. AND THAT I
WANTED US TO SPEAK ALSO FROM MY
EXPERIENCE THE BOARD OF PRISON
TERMS AND HOW ARTS AND
CORRECTIONS REALLY. IT WAS IT IS
VERY HELPFUL. IT KIND A
DIMINISHED FOR MANY MANY YEARS
BUT WE WERE ABLE TO IN THE LAST
THREE OR FOUR YEARS IN THE
BUDGET. MAKE A COMEBACK AND TOOK
IN THE LAST I THINK TWO YEARS
SELF.
I I SURE APPRECIATE YOUR. LEFT
WHAT WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND
BRINGING THAT KIND OF THERAPY.
TO OUR VETERANS.
THIS IMAGE AND SAID SENATOR
NIELSEN ALSO THE VICE CHAIRMAN
BUDGET COMMITTEE.
AND SO. YOU KNOW THAT ONE OF THE
MANY.
THINGS HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
HERE IS WHAT WE CAN DO TO
SUPPORT MORE THESE PROGRAMS.
CONTINUED CAN YOU SPEAK TO FIVE
YOU SPOKE VERY ELOQUENTLY ABOUT
YOUR OWN EXPERIENCES KENNEDY WE
SPEAK TO.
OF THE LIFE OF SOMEONE ANOTHER
VETERAN YOU'VE WORKED WITH AND
THEY'RE ONE OF YOUR RESPECTIVE
PROGRAMS WHO HAS BEEN PROFOUNDLY
TOUCHED BY.
THESE ARTS PROGRAMS ANY ANY
PARTICULAR ANECDOTE OR STORY
FROM SOMEONE ELSE I CAN. PROVIDE
I'VE HAD EXPERIENCE WHERE.
PSYCHOLOGISTS AT THE WEST LOS
ANGELES VA. HAVE EXPERIENCED
THREE PARTICULAR VETERANS WHO
HAVE BEEN TO THROUGH THREE PAIN
SIMPSON SAID THAT THEY ARE MORE
RECEPTIVE THEY'RE LESS COMBATIVE
AND ARGUING WITH ME. HERE CALM
SO THAT NOW I CAN REACH IN.
AND FURTHER IN AND AND ABLE TO
COUNSEL.
SO THROUGH THE PAIN SIMPSON AT
THE SAME TIME ONE VETERAN WHO
WAS LIVING OFF OF. UNEMPLOYMENT.
AND HE WAS A VERY TALENTED
ARTIST AND I WAS ABLE TO.
THROUGH MY ART SESSIONS IN
ADDITION TO PAINS SIEVE TO
INCORPORATE THE BUSINESS
ACKERMAN AND ABLE TO LEAD HIM TO
DO CERTAIN TESTS OF IMMEDIATE
INFORMATION. HE WAS ABLE TO
LEVERAGE HIS ART.
OF FINE A SMALL STUDIO AND
BECOME.
FINANCIALLY SELF SUFFICIENT.
SO AND THAT'S A SINCE OF NO
INDEPENDENCE NGUYEN MANY OF US.
I CAN SAY I HOPE YOU GUYS CAN
CHALLENGE ME ON THIS.
A VETERAN PERIOD IS SORT OF AN
INDEPENDENT PERSON.
OF GETTING UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
IS IS OKAY FOR THE NEXT THREE
DAYS WHAT YOU EXPECT TO BECOME
SELF SUFFICIENT YOU'RE VERY. OF
YOUR PRIDE ALONG WITH THE OF THE
SKILLS THAT YOU HAVE THAT YOU
KNOW THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO EXECUTE
AND SO ONE AND VETERAN.
HAS ED VOID.
PHONE OF DEPENDENCY. THEN
THEY'RE ABLE TO BECOME SELF
SUFFICIENT AND THE EMPOWERMENT
WITHIN AND THAT'S ANOTHER MEANS
OF ART. ARE TO EMPOWER WITHIN
AND THEY'RE ABLE TO.
BRING YOUR LIFE BACK TO FULL
FULL AND BECOME AS A FEEL I WANT
TO BE I WON A TRIBUTE TO THE
SOCIETY. YES I SERVED MY COUNTRY
YES I PAID.
IN THAT IN SOME SENSE PRICE FOR
FREEDOM. BUT I AM NOW STILL
SUFFICIENT SO THROUGH MY PAIN
SINCE ARTS SESSIONS WHERE IT
DEPLETED IN SOME SENSE THE
EMPOWERMENT OF PUTTING ALL THE
COMPONENTS TOGETHER.
HISTORY.
I'M.
GOTTEN GARY'S OURS STONE AYE I
DID I WAS SO STRUCK BY YOUR
STORY KEEP YOU. THE THIS THIS
YOUNG THIS YOUNG MAN THAT YOU
WERE. DIDN'T KEY PRIORITIES OF
THE END OF THE STORY WITH THIS
OR DID HE WAS OR SOME SORT OF
EXPLOSION BASED ON LAND MINES
ARE HE STEPPED ON A LAND MINE
WHILE. OUR. DAY BELONGS TIME AND
I STILL DON'T KNOW IT'S JUST HOW
THE STORY GOES I DON'T KNOW IF.
I SHOT HIM. OR AS PART OF THE
STORY SAYS ONE WAY BY PUT I
WROTE THIS STORY I WAS STILL IN
THE FOG OF WAR. HOUSE STILL
COMING OUT OF ARE STILL GOING
THROUGH THERAPY AND IN NO FOR
SURE.
BY.
THERE IS A PART MATT MY AND MY
OWN MEMORIES THAT I DON'T NO
WHAT HAPPENED THERE. THAT I
DON'T KNOW IF I SHOT HIM MANY
STEP AND HE STEPPED ON A LAND
MINE.
I DON'T KNOW THE STEPPED ON A
LAND MINE AND BECAUSE MY RIVAL
TO GO OFF.
SO THERE'S A SPEAK BUSINESS GRAY
AREA WITHIN THEIR AND I GO TO
THERAPY TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
SPACE OUT IT'S JUST GONE.
BUT BECAUSE.
.
SO IT'S A ALL ADORED THIS
ORGANIZATION HAS HELPED ME CUT
BUT THAT PART OF MY LIFE IN
PERSPECTIVE AND ABLE TO WALK.
NOT WALK AWAY FROM IT IT'S
ALWAYS MANY A PART OF ME.
BUT ITS. WIDE EYES BUT I'VE ROAD
AND TAKE INTERVIEW ONE TIME WISE
THAT IT'S LESS OF A MONKEY ON MY
BACK.
BUT MORE BLOOD MONKEY BECOME
LOCK BOX ASIDE BESIDE ME NOW.
AND I UNDERSTAND IT'S THEIR IN
THEIR STANDS ON HERE THE KIND OF
WORK CAN AND WITH EACH OTHER
FROM THAT ONE.
AND YOU KNOW DO SO SAY WE ALL IT
IS THIS IS. CAN YOU TALK A
LITTLE MORE ABOUT COURSE BUT
WHAT IT DES IS A SORT OF ALL
THE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
REACHES OUT TO THE COMMUNITY OF
BUT. MANY MANY DIFERENT PARTS
THE COMMUNITY THAT LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY ON THE VETERANS
COMMUNITY.
THEM EMIGRATE COMMUNITY AND WE
REACH OUT BY PEOPLE THAT HAVE
STORIES AND HELP THEM TELL THEM
BETTER MUCH AS VETERANS OF IT IF
NOT JUST UTTERANCE BUT. WITH
SORTS EVOLVES SOCIOS WITHOUT IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN WE
STARTED INCOMING.
THE VETERANS WRITING.
GROUP.
SINCE THEN WE.
.
I COMEY HAS PUBLISHED A BOOK.
THAT IS A COLLECTION OF VETERANS
STORIES JUST LIKE MY PERSONAL
ESSAYS MONTH.
WE HAVE PUBLISHED SIX SIXTY
VETERAN WRITERS IN PRINT
PUBLICATION. FORTY FIVE VETERANS
ON RADIO BROADCAST.
WE HAVE WORKED UP OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY VETERAN WRITER
SINCE THE PROGRAM'S INCEPTION.
.
IT CONTINUES HE REACHES OUT AND
BRING TO SEXUAL ORIENTATION THAT
MISSISSIPPI AND GEOGRAPHIC
LOCATIONS.
.
IT'S JUST.
HOW SOME PEOPLE HAVE SAID IT'S?
VETERANS.
ARE INDEPENDENT IN VISUALS.
BUT WE THRIVE IN A TRIBAL
COMMUNITY. AND SO SAY ALL GIVES
US I TRIED.
AS THE GENERAL SAID IT'S.
A GREAT PHRASE I'M A STILL AND
I'M TAKEN FROM POSTTRAUMATIC
STRENGTH.
IT'S AN AMAZING KIND OF GUY.
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE HAVE WITH
EACH OTHER WE HAVE CERTAIN
WORKSHOPS AROUND OF ROUND TABLE
WITH ONE ANOTHER WHERE SOMEONE
HAS BROKEN DOWN. AND WAS NOT
ABLE TO CONTINUE ON. AND I TOOK
COMMUNITY A TRIBAL COMMUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO REACH INTO AND. TOUCH
EACH OTHER AND HELP THEM BRING
THE MUSCLES OUT OF THE DARKNESS
AND AS A CONSEQUENCE
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN ALL OF US
ON A REGULAR BASIS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN SOMETHING'S
COMING UP LIKE ON MY WAY IN HERE
THEY'RE ALL ASKING ME ARE. YOU
GOT THIS MAN YOU GONNA GET GOING
TO GET AHEAD OF THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITY.
NOW WELL LOOK WE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE ALL THE
TESTIMONY FASTENING STUFF I'M
THREE ONE OF THE SORT I WANNA
KNOW MORE ABOUT YOUR
PEACEKEEPING WORK OF WHAT WOULD
YOU SERVE YOU WERE THOUSAND
SOMALIA ARM INTO DOESN'T BY
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. ARE.
AND JUST DIFFERENT ASPECTS
PLACES AROUND THE WORLD EIGHTY
AND NINETY SIX.
SO IT JUST KEPT ON GOING.
WHILE AND THEN AN AMBER YOU'RE
YOU'RE OF MUNITIONS EXPERT I
MUST OF BEEN A WHILE IT'S MY MY
UNCLE JIM WAS A WAS A MIND
SWEEPER IN KOREA AND TELLS ME
ALL THESE CRAZY STORIES ABOUT
THAT BUT.
YEAH STORIES THAT I'M SERIOUS.
I'M SURE YOU HAVE OF.
AND THEN YOU'RE DONE I WASN'T
MARRIED JUST UP THE ROAD FROM
OHIO UNIVERSITY ACTUALLY.
.
YOU HAVE NEAR TACKLE LOGAN WHICH
IS SET UP AND THAT FROM A THIRTY
THREE THERE.
SO I'M TO GO. GO BOBCATS I GUESS
WHAT WHAT WILDCATS IS AT THE
BOBCATS BUT GETS IS THE.
OHIO UNIVERSITY WELL THANK YOU
DID YOU TALK ALL FOUR OF YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK WITH OUR VETERANS IT'S
IT'S.
IMMENSELY IMPRESSIVE IN AND WE.
YOU KNOW WE ALSO ENCOURAGE YOU
AS YOU HEAL YOURSELF. FROM YOUR
OWN EXPERIENCES OF THANK YOU
THANK YOU THIS PANEL. UPON SO SO
IS IT AS A NEXT THE FOLLOW ON
AND WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM OUR
NEXT PANEL HAS TO DO WITH LOCAL
ENGAGEMENT AND WE'VE GOT A
NUMBER OF VETERANS WHO ARE ALSO
GOING TO. PRESENT ELIZABETH
WASHBURN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
COMBAT ARTS SAN DIEGO WHICH I.
AND HAD DONE SOME WORK WITH ADAM
AS WELL REGINALD GREEN U. S.
NAVY RETIRED.
VOLUNTEER INSTRUCT WITH THAT
ARE.
MAMBO HERNANDEZ SAMUEL HERNANDEZ
OF OF OF RETIRED MARINE AND.
MUSICIAN TEACHING ARTISTS FROM
THE DEL MAR ASSOCIATION CULT
AWARENESS AND ALSO. REBEKAH
EVANDRO WHOSE.
MUSIC THERAPIST IN AND WORKS TO
CAMP PENDLETON AND THE
CONCUSSION CARE CLINIC SO WE
WELCOME YOU ALL. A CENTER ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WAS ALLUDED TO
WE HAVE.
KNOWN DEFENSE IS A GENERAL HE
SAID WORKS.
FOR THE CREATIVE FORCES
INITIATIVE WHICH IS A JOINT
INITIATIVE OF THE NATIONALITY
ARTS DEPARTMENT DEFENSE IN
WASHINGTON DC. AND HE SPOKE VERY
ELOQUENTLY EARLIER ABOUT
POSTTRAUMATIC STRENGTH.
RIGHT AND THE.
THE WAYS IN WHICH THE ARTS IN
THE HEALING ARTS CAN CAN PLAY
WELL A ROLE IN IN IN AND
STRENGTHENING VETERANS AND. AS
THEY COME BACK FROM DRAMATIC
EXPENSES AWARD THAT'S A LOT OF
WHAT HAS BEEN THE THEME OF.
OF TODAY'S DISCUSSION SO LET'S
START WITH THAT WE DEAL AS MATH
AND WE VERY MUCH WELCOME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AT MY THE WAY I'M
MISTER STONER AND YOU YOU STILL
HERE.
THE EARLY WALKER.
SO IT IS WHAT IT IS OKAY WITH
THE I LOVE THE IF IF WE COULD
JUST TAKE A LOOK AT HIS BOOK.
AND WE PROMISE TO GIVE IT BACK.
OKAY YES MISS MISS WASHBURN VERY
GOOD AFTERNOON BEFORE I BEGIN
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING AND.
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH WATCH BURN
ON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
COMBAT ARTS SAN DIEGO. COMBAT
ARTS IS A NON PROFIT.
ART ORGANIZATION THAT SERVES
POST NINE ELEVEN COMBAT
VETERANS.
AND TREATMENT FOR POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER AND TV I.
IN ADDITION WE SERVE TEENS
INCARCERATED IN JUVENILE HALL.
OUR PROGRAM INCLUDES ART
CLASSES ART SHOWS.
MEN TOURING PUBLIC ART
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND CULTURAL TOURS.
WE SERVE AROUND A HUNDRED
VETERANS YEAR AND OVER A CLOSE
TO A THOUSAND BY JUVENILES.
MY BACKGROUND IS IN A VISUAL
ARTIST AND ART TEACHER WHO'S
BEEN WORKING IN SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITIES TEACHING OUR AND
FACILITATING PUBLIC ART PROJECTS
WITH UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES FOR
OVER FIFTEEN YEARS.
SPECIFICALLY A BEEN WORKING WITH
WOUNDED WAR VETERANS FOR A LEAD
IN YEARS.
AT FIRST GLANCE ART MAY NOT SEEM
LIKE A LIKELY COMPANION TO A
SOLDIER. BUT I'VE MORE STAR
STORIES AND A TIME TO TELL TODAY
ABOUT THE TOUGH MARINES.
FINDING A LOT OF RELIEF FROM
MAKING ART AND MAKING ART HELP
THEM TO REGAIN A SENSE OF
PURPOSE AFTER THE INTENSITY OF
WAR.
ONE EXAMPLE IS MARINE SERGEANT
AARON RARE WHO SERVE TWO COMBAT
TOURS IN IRAQ AS A TURRET GUNNER
AARON'S PTSD SYMBOL SYMPTOMS
STARTED DURING A SECOND
DEPLOYMENT WHERE HE BEGAN HAVING
INTENSE NIGHTMARES THAT LEAD TO
CHRONIC INSOMNIA.
BY THE TIME AARON GOT HOME FROM
A SECOND DEPLOYMENT WHO IS
NOT-ONLY NOT SLEEPING. BUT ALSO
BEGIN ISOLATE TO AVOID ANXIOUS
SITUATIONS THAT INCLUDED THINGS
LIKE GOING TO THE GROCERY STORE
DRIVING BEING IN PUBLIC AREAS.
AND EVEN THOUGH HE WAS HOME AND
OUT OF HARM'S WAY HE WAS UNABL
TO TURN OFF THE HYPERVALENT
VIGILANCE THAT HE HAD DEVELOPED
WHILE HE WAS ON HIS COMBAT
PATROLS IN MISSIONS IN IRAQ.
INTERACTING WITH HIS WIFE AND
FAMILY WITHOUT SEVERE ANXIETY
AND AGITATION BECAME DIFFICULT
AND HE BEGAN DRINKING HEAVILY.
THANKFULLY HE SOUGHT OUT
TREATMENT AND A NAVY SPONSORED
PTSD CLINIC WHICH IS WHEN HE
ENDED UP IN ONE OF OUR CLASSES
AND. THAT'S WHAT HIS ARTWORK
THAT HE DID.
IN HER CLASS WHICH IS
INTERESTING EGOS CHOSE THAT.
ART MAKING BECAME A WAY FOR HIM
TO EXPRESS HIS FEELINGS AND
COMMUNICATE WHEN WORDS FAILED
HIM. IN ADDITION THE ACT OF
MAKING ART SLOWED HIS MIND DOWN
AND PROVIDED HIM WITH SOME
RELIEF THAT MADE THE MEET OTHER
REALITIES OF HIS LIFE MORE
MANAGEABLE.
TODAY ERIN WORKS WITH COMBAT
ARTS IN THE SAME CLINIC HE WAS
TREATED IN HELPING OTHER SOME
SERVICE MEMBERS TO USE ART TO
HEAL AND CONNECT.
AND IN ADDITION HE'S REMARRIED
AND IS A FATHER FOR THE SECOND
TIME. THE ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE OF
ART HELPING VETERANS WITH PTSD
TELLS THE STORY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL VETERANS.
WITH THAT WE WORK WITH AND THE
NEUROSCIENTIFIC RESEARCH BASED
ON BRAIN PLASTICITY THAT IS
BEING PUBLISHED SHOWS NUMERICAL
DATA THAT SUPPORTS THE USE OF
ART AND STRENGTHENING COGNITION.
NEW ADVANCEMENTS IN BRAIN
IMAGING HAVE ALLOWED SCIENTISTS
TO VIEW BRAIN ACTIVITY DURING
ART MAKING FOR EXAMPLE OUR
LIGHTS UP A PLEASURE CENTER IN
THE BULLET IN THE BRAIN THAT
RELEASES DOPAMINE. THAT GOOD
FEELING THE DOPAMINE ENCOURAGES
AN INDIVIDUAL TO STAY IN THE
PRESENT MOMENT WITHOUT
FORGETTING THAT REGRETTING THE
PAST
OR FEARING THE FUTURE. THIS
MINDFULNESS STATE HELPS TO
DIMINISH NEGATIVE THOUGHT LOOPS
MAKING ROOM FOR MORE COGNITIVE
HEALTHY COGNITIVE FUNCTIONING
THAT IS NOT WHOLLY RELIANT ON
DRUGS.
THE STUDIES ARE VERY USEFUL IN
SUPPORTING OUR GOAL OF LESS DRUG
PRESCRIPTIONS AND MORE
ALTERNATIVE THERAPIES LIKE ART
BEING PRESCRIBED TO VETERANS.
ART IS A MEDICINE THAT CAN BE
INDEPENDENTLY REALIZE BY A
VETERAN TO HELP THEM THROUGH
MOMENTS OF ANXIETY AND STRESS.
IN ADDITION THE COMMUNITY BASED
ENGAGEMENT ART PROGRAMS LIKE
COMBAT ARTS PROVIDES TO THE
MILITARY AND CIVILIAN
COMMUNITIES PROMOTES NOT ONLY
AWARENESS BUT ALSO OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE TWO GROUPS TO CONNECT.
THE ART PROJECTS ALSO REQUIRE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF SELF
DETERMINATION ON THE PART OF THE
VETERAN THAT OTHERWISE DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MATERIALIZE WHEN
DRUGS AND INSUFFICIENT TALK
THERAPY. ARE THE ONLY SOURCES OF
MEDICINE AVAILABLE. BUT VETERAN
HAS A ROLE TO PLAY IN SOCIETY
EVEN WHEN THEY HAVE FINISHED
THEIR TOURS OF DUTY IT WOULD
BENEFIT EVERYONE INVOLVED IF WE
HAVE HIGHER EXPECTATIONS OF A
VETERANS. AND PROVIDED ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITIES AS OUR THINKS FOR
THEIR SERVICE.
COMEDIAN GAUGE MEANT PROGRAMS
ARE ALSO VERY ECONOMICALLY
FRIENDLY AND TO NOT HAVE A LONG
WAIT TIMES IN INSTEAD OF
OVERWHELMED GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
BEING TAXED.
WITH HELPING VETERANS FIND
ALTERNATIVE METHODS FOR HEALING
CIVILIAN COMMUNITY PRIMARY
PROVIDERS WITH PROVEN TRACK
RECORDS SERVING VETERANS. CAN BE
CONTRACTED BY LOCAL AND STATE
AND AGENCIES TO FILL HOLISTIC
PRESCRIPTIONS THAT THE HEALTH
THIS MODEL OF CARE ARTS ON
PRESCRIPTION WILL LESSEN THE
LOAD OF VETERAN CARE FOR THE
STATE AND CONNECT COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS WITH VETERANS IN NED
OF THEIR SERVICES.
IN ORDER FOR THIS MODEL TO WORK
HOWEVER. COMMUNITY PARTNERS
CANNOT BE EXPECTED TO VOLUNTEER
THE SERVICES OR REYES OF THE
NEEDED FUNDING OF FOCUS ON
DEVELOPING CREATIVE AVENUES TO
PAY FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ALTERNATIVE NEEDS TO BE PART OF
THIS CONVERSATION. WHETHER IT'S
CORPORATE SPONSORS YOU GET TAX
INCENTIVES THE REALLOCATION OF
EXISTING FUNDS OR OTHER
FINANCIAL SOLUTIONS. MOVING FOR
THE NEED FOR ALTERNATIVE CARE
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED AND IS
EVIDENCED BY MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF
OPIATE ADDICTIONS AND SUICIDES
AMONG VETERANS. COMMUNITY ARTS
PROVIDERS CAN BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK TODAY.
THANK YOU AND THANKS FOR THE
VERY ARRESTING OUR.
IT WILL PASS YOU PROLONG FOR A
FEE TO.
BOB WHAT I HEAR FROM. FROM MR
GREEN. REGINALD GREEN THANKS FOR
LETTING ME.
HER LIFE STORY.
WILL START OFF WITH THE VIDEO
FOR A HALF.
OKAY.
PHONE GONNA START I'M.
FOR BEING LIVE STREAM THAT'S
WAY OKAY. RETIRED NAVY THAT.
AND ALSO.
VOLUNTEER INSTRUCTOR FOR THAT
ARE SO I'M GONNA BEGAN WITH THE
VIDEO FOR WHERE WERE YOU TO
POINT WHEN YOU'RE IN THE
SERVICE.
OVER THE PLACE FOR A LOWER
SHOULD.
YEAH I DID.
TWO SEVEN MONTH DEPLOYMENTS.
WHEN I WAS COME BACK SUPPORT SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YOU WANNA COME FROM BLOWS
HIMSELF UP AND MAKE SOME FIRE
THAT. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE
FOR.
ORG IS A VETERAN ORGANIZATION
STARTED TO PROMOTE HEALING
THROUGH ART WE BRING VETERANS
TOGETHER.
INCOMING
GIVE THEM A PURPOSE.
AND
WHEN IT TAUGHT ITS FIRST.
THROUGH TO TODAY WORD OFFERS
MANY FORMS OF ARTISTIC
EXPRESSION ITS MISSION REMAINS.
REMEMBER THIS THE LAST FOR THE
NEXT THOUSAND YEARS IN THE
FUTURE OF FREE ART CLASSES THE
VETERANS
ALL AROUND SO SAN DIEGO. AND
AROUND THE COUNTRY IN THIS.
USING
SNAKES THAT DATE BACK
ANCIENT MESOPOTAMIA THEY SEEK TO
CREATE NOT JUST ART. BUT A WAY
OF ADDRESSING DRAMATICALLY.
PAGE SEVERAL DIFFERENT TYPES OF
CLASSES FROM THE CONCUSSION CARE
CLINIC ON CAMPUS AND. WE ALSO
TEACH CLASSES TO THE ASPIRE
CENTER IN SAN DIEGO BILLION
LOSS.
SOME MILITARY MEMBERS
FIND THEMSELVES.
WHEN THEY GET OUT OF THE
MILITARY THEY LOSE THEIR.
MISSION LOSER YOU KNOW OF SOME.
CAMARADERIE AND ALMOST OVERNIGHT
LEVEL HERE JUST
AND INTO THE CIVILIAN WORLD.
WHAT WILL WE DO YOU KNOW
OBVIOUS?
EVEN THOUGH IT LOOKS FOR THE.
IT REALLY
BUT THEY ALSO GET
TOGETHER WITH OTHER VETERANS
AND THEY'RE GIVEN.
SO THAT MISSION THEY GET YOU
KNOW.
AND YOU KNOW LEARN NEW SKILLS.
MEET OTHER VETERANS.
MAKE THE.
BILLION LIFE.
OPEN TRACK
FORM LIVES
WHEN OUR.
AT A TIME
EVEN IF IT'S
FOR AN HOUR ON A WEEKEND THAT
GIVES.
THING.
THEY CAN LOOK FOR TO MAKE IT.
AND IT CAME.
AND THAT'S.
SO BASICALLY THAT ART IS SO
VETERANS
SERVICE.
CERAMIC IN.
ACTIVE.
VETERANS AND THEIR SPOUSES.
.
I REALLY HAVEN'T HAD MUCH
EXPERIENCE WITH OR.
.
EGGMAN WHEN.
ONE COURSE OF CERAMICS INSIDE
HIGH SCHOOL AND I ALWAYS WANTED
TO GO BACK TO IT.
INSIDE FROM THE NAVY IN THE.
SO AND GOT MY DEGREE AND
EVERYTHING.
YOU KNOW I FOUND MYSELF IN A
DEPRESSIVE STATE.
JUST FROM THE PAINS OF SCHOOL
FOR THE MILITARY AND STUFF SO.
I IN THE OF TAKING A
RECREATIONAL THERAPY CLASS THAT
THE.
VA MEDICAL CENTER IN DALLAS.
THAT WAS MY OFFERS POEM.
ART.
CLASSIC COUNTER.
COME TO HELP ME.
GET BACK INTO LIFE FOR OR
WHATEVER BECAUSE THE WHEN I GET
OUT THE MILITARY.
.
I WAS LIKE IN A DEPRESSIVE STATE
WERE.
JUST WOULD GO HOME FOR LIKE TWO
YEARS I WOULD JUST GO HOME AND.
SLEEP OR WHATEVER AND I WASN'T
REALLY.
LIVING MY LIFE.
.
SO.
WELL I WAS.
TO RECREATIONAL THERAPY PROGRAM.
THEY HAVE SOME ART AND CRAFT OF
PROGRAMS THAT I GOT INVOLVED IN
AND AS I GOT INTO THAT.
IT ENDED INTRODUCED ME TO LIGHT
SCOPE DE AND NOW MAJ PAUSE AND
STUFF LIKE THAT SO I STARTED
SCULPTING TO TAKE MY MIND OFF
THE PAIN AND EVERYTHING LIKE
THAT.
SO INNER SOME.
PROJECTS INSIDE.
SMART SHOWS SOME LOCAL ART
SHOWS AGO SOON AWARDS AND STUFF
LIKE THAT SO ARE REALLY STARTED
GETTING INTO ART. NOT SALSA
BRONZE PIECES.
INSIDE THE ART SHW AND I WAS
CURIOUS SO ON HOW TO.
GET INTO THAT SO THAT'S ONE I.
SO TO FLY HERE EMIT STEVE.
STEVE DILLY.
AND THAT'S HOW I GOT IN INVOLVED
DECIDE TO.
BROWN'S CASTING PROGRAMS FROM
WORKING WITH THEM A LITTLE BIT
AND THEN I START OF
VOLUNTEERING.
BASE A LEAD OF.
FEEL LIKE THAT PROGRAM HAS
HELPED ME TREMENDOUSLY ON.
.
GET HIM BACK INTO LIFE AND.
A KID ITS SUPPLY MIA OUTLET.
.
AND I SAW THAT IT HELPS OTHER
VETERANS TO SO THAT'S WHY IN
THE.
VOLUNTEERING
TO HELP AND LEARN IN THE
PROCESS.
AND WORKING WITH TO VENT OUR.
SO THAT'S BASICALLY THANK YOU.
MA'AM THANK YOU WE LOVE OF MK
FOUR OF YOU.
ALL.
I DON'T HAVE IT HERE.
THANK YOU A GOOD THING TO DO A
VIDEO TO IT IS IS THAT ARE ALL
OVER.
THE PLACE OR IS IT IS IT THE
BASIS AND SAN DIEGO IS IT.
THEY DO STUFF AT THE INSOFAR
SOONER.
AND OLD TOWN IN THE HOUSE.
FACILITY INVOLVED WORK.
I'M IN THEY DO.
IF THERE'S LIKE A BIG GROUP OF
VETERANS BELIEVE THEY DON'T FLY
OUT IN.
TEACH CLASSES THERE'S SLOW
COOKER.
THE WAY FROM TEXAS RISEN. I'M
FROM DALLAS THERE HAVE.
COWBOY FAN. INTO FLAME I'M. WE
WILL HAVE THAT IN YOUR.
ALL RIGHT.
IT WHEN IT DOES THE PRESENCE OF
OUR GREAT GUYS CENTER RICHARD
PAN REPRESENTS HALF BY
SACRAMENTO HERE IN THE LEADS IN
LONDON STATE SENATE GREAT LEADER
HERE TO.
THE DOCTORS WERE ALSO. KNOWS A
BIT ABOUT THE. THE HEALING
POWERS.
SO LET'S NOW GO TO AND.
SOME WILD MAMBO AND ON THIS
WHOSE.
ANOTHER I RETIRED MARINE AND
MUSICIANS
FROM ALL NORTH OF HERE. AND WE
LOOKING FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
A LONG WAYS AWAY AHEAD HEY HEY
HEY LOOK AT PORN TO GO BACK
HOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
.
I'M HERE BECAUSEOF.
DRUMMING WITH.
PATTERNS OF FAMILIES.
THE DEL MAR COUNTY JUDGES BEEN.
GOING DOWN FOR THREE YEARS.
EVERY YEAR GROWS A LITTLE BIT
BIGGER AND BIGGER AND WE'RE
GETTING.
HELLO GOOD RESPONSE FROM PEOPLE
THE FAMILIES.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO.
.
TO DEAL WITH THE VETERANS
WITHOUT FAMILY SUPPORT.
BECAUSE.
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF I DEAL WITH
PTSD EVER SENSE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY.
AND.
I'VE BEEN PLAYING MUSIC.
PSALM A COMBINATION BETWEEN THE
PTSD IN THE MUSIC THERAPY
WORKING FOR ME. AND GET ME TO
THIS POINT I'VE BEEN MARRIED
FORTY SIX YEARS. ALMOST FORTY
SEVEN YEARS NOW.
AND THIS HELP YOU THROUGH LIFE
AND.
THE CERTAIN VIA PART MAJOR IN
VIETNAM YES I SERVED IN VIETNAM.
AND.
.
WE HOOKED UP WITH.
DO NOT DINAKARAN DOING.
THE GRAMMAR SCHOOLS AS WELL AS
I WORKING WITH VETERANS.
AND DO NOT COULD SELF IS
INVOLVED IN TEACHING GUITAR
LESSONS.
AND.
CREATIVE WRITING.
MAINTAIN.
THERE'S PROBABLY ONE MORE THING
THAT I'M MISSING I HOPE I DON'T
GET IN TROUBLE FOR THAT BUT TO%
OUR. TO HAS THAT'S BASICALLY IT
AT THIS POINT.
.
I KNOW THAT.
DRUMMING HELPS RELIEVE STRESS.
IT WORKS FOR ME.
.
I'VE BEEN TO THAT DATE STARTS
BLOCK BEFORE AND.
LEFT DRUM MEAN TO THE SIDE IT
UNTIL I WENT BACK TO PICK IT UP
AGAIN.
AND.
HAD RELIEVED ME FROM A LOT OF
TENSION AND ANXIETY.
THINGS LIKE THAT SO I NOTED WORK
FOR SOMEBODY.
.
IN THE COMMUNITY THERE ARE
VETERANS WITH THEIR FAMILIES
BECAUSE IT'S A FUN TIME.
AND.
.
IT'S AN ENJOYABLE TIME.
AND.
WE GET A LOT OF GREAT RESPONSE
FROM PEOPLE WE HAVE QUESTIONERS
ARE PEOPLE FILL OUT THEIR.
TELL US.
WHAT IT DOES FOR THEM FAMILY
WISE?
VETERAN WISE.
AND.
WE HAVE A GREAT DAY HE'D DE AND.
.
CRESCENT CITY.
STEPHANIE WINNING THAT.
COMES UP WITH ALL THESE
PROGRAMS SO. WE'RE PRETTY PROUD
OF THAT HUNG.
HE NEW A BY TELL ME BECAUSE I'M
NERVOUS.
IF YOU GUYS ASKING QUESTIONS.
WHO'S YOUR FAVORITE DRUMMER.
WHO'S VERY DRUMMER IDEA AND.
YEAH.
YOUR YOU BE YOU YOUR NEW MUSIC
THAT I SAM RIGHT.
IT'S.
ETHNIC DRUMMING THOUGH TO BRING.
LIKE FIFTEEN TWENTY DRUMS AND.
WE MAKE A CIRCLE ON PART OF THE
CIRCLE I DON'T BREAK THE CIRCLE
BY GOING INTO THE MIDDLE OR TO
THE OUTSIDE BUT USUALLY
GENERALLY IN THE SENT. HOME WITH
THE CENTER.
WITH THE CIRCLE TO MAKE.
THE MUSIC HAPPENING STRUCTURE
AND I MAKE IT SO SIMPLISTIC THAT
THOSE CHILDREN.
AND ADULTS COMPLEXION BECAUSE WE
BASICALLY DO ARE I BASICALLY DO.
IS JUST A BASIC COULD I DEPUTY
QUARTER NO.
AND THEN I.
PLAY OVER THE TOP OF THAT ON THE
SOLE BASIS AND IT BRINGS ALL THE
MUSIC TOGETHER.
AND THE CIRCLE. AND WE GO LIKE
THAT FOR OUR AND.
WE BREAK UP IN ABOUT THREE OR
FOUR INCREMENTS AND.
WE JUST HAVE A GOOD TIME AND I.
IT'S WORTH IT'S WORTHWHILE
ACTIVITY IT'S.
GETS THE BLOOD FLOWING.
AND.
COULD SEE FIGURES MOVING IN
THEM.
.
THEY GET TO PLAY DRUMS AND
NORMALLY THEY NEVER WOULD BE
ABLE TO GET TO PLAY AND I BRING
THOSE THINGS AND.
NOBODY GETS A CHANCE TO BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN NON THAT
ACTIVE.
.
DRUMMING CIRCLE SO VERY COOL
DURING HOME ALRIGHT WHEN WE
LET'S HEAR FROM THE NEXT
PANELIST IN AND WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO OPEN UP THE FLOOR
TO. DISCUSSION QUESTIONS.
THROUGH AN EXTRA. PREVENTIVE AND
DROVE AND DROVE.
THE. BAND DRIVE OKAY POUND DEER.
WHO KNOWS I?
IT'S A GET FRENCH NAME I
SUPPOSE.
.
WELL YOU'RE VERY WELCOME AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING YOUR
ABOUT YOUR WORK AT CAMP
PENDLETON ELSEWHERE
YEAH THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN I
GUESS I WOULD LIKE TO THANK. THE
COMMITTEE HERE AS WELL AS HANDLE
ALL THE PAIN OF THE HOMES.
.
PAN M. DISPLAYING AND SHARING
THEIR STORIES TODAY DISPLAYING
THEIR WORK AT SOME VERY PROFOUND
AND. I'M VERY HONORED AND
HUMBLED TO BE UP HERE. AND AND
BE ABLE TO SHARE NOW A PART OF
THE CREATIVE FORCES INITIATIVE
THAT GENERALLY THEN SPOKE ABOUT
ON A BRIEF EARLIER FROM.
AND SO AS FAR AS MY
REPRESENTATION HERE I'M HERE AS
A CREATIVE ARTS THERAPISTS I AM
A BOARD CERTIFIED MUSIC
THERAPIST OUTSIDE MY MASTERS IN
EDUCATION ON THERE ARE
SCIENTISTS WHO HAD A BRIDGE IN
THAT. ON THEIR ULTIMATELY YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THEM HOW YOU
FEELING YOUR DRUMMING IN MAKING
MUSIC AND GAMES AND TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT THE RESEARCH SIDE OF
THAT HE WAS WELL AS A CRATE OF
OXIDE. AND AND SO WHAT CREATIVE
ARTS THERAPISTS ARE INCREASE OF
ARTS THERAPIES ARE AND IT'S
PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE WHO CAME UP
HERE TODAY ARTISTS. DANCERS
THEATER.
MUSIC AND CREATIVE WRITING ALL
OF THESE HAVE BEEN TOUCHED UPON
TODAY IN SOME WAY SHAPE OR FORM
AND SO WHERE PROVIDERS THAT DO
AN APPROVED ACCREDITED. AND
EDUCATION AND DEGREE BACHELORS
MASTERS OR DOCTORAL. OUT IN
CREATIVE ARTS THERAPIES AND THIS
IS USING THE ARTS AS A VEHICLE
AND CATALYST FOR I'VE REACHING
NON MUSICAL NON ARTISTIC. GOALS
AND.
SO THROUGH CREATIVE FORCES WE
ARE EMBEDDED IN THE CLINIC AND
WE DEFINITELY ACKNOWLEDGED ON
THE IMPORTANCE IN THE POWER OF
OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS HAVE
SPOKEN TODAY.
IN THE CLINIC AS CREATIVE ARTS
THERAPISTS AND WE WORK ON
FUNCTIONAL REHABILITATION AS
WELL AS SO MOTOR SPEECH. I AS
WELL AS COGNITION AS WELL AS
MENTAL HEALTH SCHOOLS AND THIS
IS A BEAUTIFUL QUOTE FROM A
SERVICE MEMBER THAT I WAS.
VERY GRATEFUL AND BLESSED TO
WORK WITH MISSES HIS WIFE
ACTUALLY SAYING IT'S TRULY A
MIRACLE. WITHOUT WHAT CREATIVE
FORCES HAS DONE FOR WHO LOUISE
CAPTAIN VELAR RIGHT THERE WHO
WILL SEE AGAIN IN THE
PRESENTATION AND WE COULDN'T
HAVE IN MY FAMILY THE QUALITY OF
LIFE WE HAVE.
WE DON'T EVEN THINK WE ARE
DISABLED ANYMORE WE CAN GO
ANYWHERE WE DON'T SEE THE
DISABILITY WE SEE THE
POSSIBILITY AND THAT TO ME. NOT
FOCUS ON THE CIVILITY THAT FOCUS
ON THE POSSIBILITY THAT'S BEEN A
THEME THAT.
REALLY EVERYONE HAS HIGHLIGHTED
HERE TODAY VERY IMPORTANT IN.
THE DISCIPLINES.
SO IT'S CREATIVE ARTS
THERAPISTS IN CREATIVE FORCES
WHERE IN BAGHDAD.
AS THE GENERAL SAT ON ON
MULTIPLE MILITARY INSTALLATIONS
ACROSS THE NATION THESE ARE
MOSTLY AT THE INTREPID SPIRIT
CENTERS.
WHICH ARE FUNDED BY THE
INTREPID HOP BY FALLEN HEROES
FIND AND THE MOST RECENT ONE OR
TO TO ACTUALLY ARE ON.
GREAT ART THERAPISTS THERE.
AND SO REALLY I USING THE ARTS
AS A CORE PART OF THE
INTERDISCIPLINARY TEAM.
SOMETHING MRS MILLER TODAY SAID
ABOUT ON THE ARTS ON SOMETHING
NICE THERE REALLY IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART IN SO WE REALLY
BELIEVE AND THINK THIS MISSION
AND WE SEE THROUGH THE WORK WE
DO THAT THE ARTS ARE. A NEED TO
HAVE RATHER THAN NICE TO HAVE
AND SO THE WAY CREATE A FORCES
PRESENTS THIS MISSION IS IN
BATTING.
A TEAM SO WE WORK ALONGSIDE
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGISTS
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONS
RECREATION THERAPIST.
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST TO
REALLY PROVIDE THE ARTS AS A
CORE OF THE TREATMENT.
I'M LOOKING FROM A CLINICAL
PERSPECTIVE WE LOOK AT THE ARTS
ABOUT AS A BIOPSYCHOSOCIAL WE DO
ASSESSMENTS WE LOOK AT THE
PATIENT AND THESE ROUNDS AND SO
CREATIVE FORCES HAD THAT ALSO
AND THE SERVICE MEMBER AT THE
CORE BUT REALLY LOOKING AT.
THE DIFFERENT WAYS IN THE
DIFFERENT.
CULTURES IN DYNAMICS AND AND.
THE DIFFERENT LEVELS THAT
EXISTS.
FOR THE SERVICE MEMBER WHEN
THEY LEAVE THE CLINIC AND THAT'S
AND IMPORTANCE OF THE COMMUNITY
AS WELL.
AND LOOKING AT OUR NETWORK SO I
THE CREATIVE FORCES
REPRESENTATIVE AND CLINICIAN I
DO.
CORE CLINICAL WORK ON THE A
CLINIC.
SEEING PATIENTS EVERYDAY.
ALSO I TIE IN WITH THE
COMMUNITIES OF SOMETHING WE'VE
DEVELOPED AT CAMP PENDLETON ALSO
THROUGHOUT MANY OF THE INTREPID
SPIRIT CENTERS IS SOMETHING
CALLED THE CREATIVE ARTS CAFE.
WHERE PATIENTS WERE STAFF AND
CAN COME AT FAMILIES CAN COME
AND PEOPLE PRESENT ARTWORK THAT
THEY'VE CREATED MUSIC THAT THEY
WERE IN?
THEY DO DRUM INTERACTIVE'S AND
THEY DO RELAXATION AND WELLNESS
AND EVERY MONTH WE BRING AND
SOMEONE FROM THE COMMUNITY.
THAT ARE IS GOING TO BE
HIGHLIGHTED NEXT MONTH WHICH IS
WONDERFULLY PAD ON THE LIBRARY
CAN MEN. AND WE'VE HAD THE OLD
GLOBE THEATER.
COMING SO WE REALLY PROVIDE
THAT ARE BEGINNING STAGE OF A
WARM HAND A FROM THE CLINIC TO
THE COMMUNITY.
WITH THE CREATIVE ARTS CAFE SO
THAT POWER PERFORMANCE.
THE CAPACITY IS MORE IN LINE.
WITH OUR DIGITAL RESOURCE
CENTER SOME OF OUR NATIONAL
INITIATIVES AS WELL AS THE
RESEARCH THAT WE PRODUCE SO A
BIG PART OF.
WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE SAYING THE
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE IS STRONG WE
NEED THAT RESEARCH TO BE ABLE TO
SHOW TO GET THAT DIANNE SO
PEOPLE CAN REALLY SEE.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN SEE A MASCOT
BUT YOU CAN'T REALLY SEE. A
PIECE OF MUSIC AND SO REALLY
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SEE AND THE
PROCESSES BEHIND THESE PRODUCTS
OF THE ARTS.
THESE ARE ALSO IN THE BINDERS
THAT WERE ON THE PORTFOLIOS THAT
WERE DISTRIBUTED ONE THAT'S
REALLY KNEW THAT DID NOT MAKE IT
IN THERE. IS THE.
MUSIC THERAPY APPLIED TO
COMPLEX A BLAST INJURY AND
THAT'S A CASE REPORT THE SECOND
AUTHOR ON THAT.
REPORT IS THE PATIENT AND
THAT'S.
CAPTAIN LOUIS SEBELAH I'M SOME
IS GOING TO SHARE TO BRIEF
STORIES.
OF THE ATTORNEY THAT HAD THE
CREATIVE ARTS THERAPIES THIS
PATIENT I WORKED WITH AT THE
NATIONAL AND CHECK THAT CENTER
OF EXCELLENCE AT WALTER REED
WHEN HE. FIRST WAS INJURED AYE
HE COULDN'T SPEAK HE WAS IN A
COMA FOR FORTY DAYS AND AGAIN
YOU CAN READ ABOUT HIS STORY ON
THE OPEN ACCESS
LINK THERE. OUT IT'S A GREAT
STORY HIS WIFE IS ALSO I'M VERY
MUCH A PART OF THAT PAPER IN HIS
FAMILY. AND HE WAS IN A CALM HE
COULDN'T SPEAKING THROUGH THE
AMAZING WORK OF THE
INTERDISCIPLINARY TEAM AT WALTER
REED AND HE WAS ABLE TO.
AMERICA AND REHABILITATE MUSIC
IS SUCH A BIG PART OF HIS
REHABILITATION AND I THINK IT'S.
MOVING FORWARD HE WHAT HE HAD
PERFORMED.
.
NOT ONLY AT THE KENNEDY CENTER
IN THE LINING OF STATE UP THERE
HE'S IN THE. SUMMER LIGHT.
THAT'S HIM RIGHT THERE PLAYING
DRUMS.
FOR THIS INTERACTIVE DANCE
MOVEMENT.
AND MUSIC AND HIS OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST IS RIGHT THERE.
HE ALSO BUT I WAS ABLE TO
PERFORM ALONGSIDE RENEE FLEMING
AND THE NATIONAL SYMPHONY
ORCHESTRA AT LAST YEAR'S
MEMORIAL DAY CAPITAL CONCERT SO
GOING FROM NOT BEING ABLE TO
SPEAK.
TO SINGING GOD BLESS AMERICA ON.
THAT CAPITOL LAWN WAS PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE I'M. AND I HOPE YOU
AGAIN CAN I FIND HIS ARTICLE IN
HIS STORY IT IS OPEN ACCESS
EVERY PIECE OF RESEARCH CREATIVE
FORCES.
PUBLISHES IS OPEN ACCESS.
ONE MORE RECENT ONES COME TO
BRIDGE THE GAP OVER TO.
CAMP PENDLETON MY WORK NOW WE
WERE JUST OF HONOR TO HOST THE
SECOND LADY FOR A.
VISIT A FEW WEEKS AGO.
AND MISS YOUNG MARINE HAD A
SUDDEN BRAIN INJURY AND HE
ACTUALLY WAS STATIONED AT
QUANTICO AND HIS FIRST CARE WAS
OUT WHAT'S A READER WHO'S ABLE
TO START. I'M USING MUSIC IN HIS
INITIAL CUTE PAGES PHASES OF
RECOVERY WHAT'S REALLY NICE
ABOUT THIS NETWORK IN THIS IS A
GREAT STORY TO SHOW THAT. IS HE
CAME HOME HE'S FROM BAKER I'M
CALIFORNIA AND HE REALLY WANTS
GET BACK HOME TOWARD THAT TO HIS
FAMILY. AND SO WE WERE ABLE TO
JUST DO THE HAND OFF FROM WALTER
REED ARMY HE'S BEEN NOW WORKING
WITH ME I'M IN MUSIC THERAPY AS
PART OF HIS. AYE REHABILITATION
AND HE'S ABLE TO BE HOME THAT'S
A REALLY GREAT HOMECOMING STORY
I THINK FOR HIM IN HIS NOT JUST
IN HIS FIGHT AND HIS BATTLE THE
IN HIS REHABILITATION HIS
RECOVERY.
AYE LIGHTS AND WITH A QUICK.
OUT WRITING THAT WAS DONE BY ONE
F OUR MOST RECENT TEAMS OF
SERVICE MEMBERS AND THIS IS A
COMPILATION OF THEIR OWN WRITING
AS WELL AS ON SOME SONG LYRICS
SAVE EXTRACTED TO PUT TOGETHER.
SOME.
SENATE SO OVER TO A NEW HORIZON
AND RISING SIGN.
AT WHAT COST DOES HE ACHIEVE
VICTORY.
THEMES OF SACRIFICE RACED
THROUGH HIS MIND. MISUNDERSTOOD
BY THE HYENAS NIPPING AT HIS
INTENT.
I'M NOT EVEN SURE WHAT I WANT AT
THE MOMENT. BUT SHOULD
CONCENTRATE ON WHAT IS BEST FOR
MYSELF AND MY FAMILY. THIS IDEA
OF IN THE FUTURE WILL HAVE TO BE
FIGURED OUT SOON.
OR MAYBE A DOZEN SOME OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT INTERESTING
PEOPLE STILL DON'T.
I'M STILL HAVING DIFFICULTY
BLOCKING OUT THOUGHTS PENDING
ISSUES AND PAST COMBAT RELATED
EVENTS.
TRYING TO TURN AWAY MAKES ME
THINK OF THEM MORE AND IN
DETAIL.
HEARING HIDING BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO BLAME SOMEONE FOR YOUR OWN
CONFUSION.
CAN YOU FEEL THE RESISTANCE CAN
YOU FEEL THE THUNDER. I KNOW
YOU'RE OUT THERE IN THE
TWILIGHT'S LAST GLEAMING. OFFICE
IS OPEN SEASON.
THE MEDITATION A MUSIC RELEASE
MY STRESS AND PAIN TEMPORARILY.
I'M THINKING OF CHORES PROJECTS
PROBLEMS I NEED TO RESOLVE BUT
MUSIC ITSELF IS AN EFFECTIVE
FORM OF THERAPY.
SINGING SEEMS TO HELP A TROUBLED
SOUL. ONE OF THESE DAYS IT WON'T
BE LONG OUR REJOIN THEM IN A
SONG.
AND THEN JOIN THE FAMILY CIRCLE
AT THE THRONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR WORKERS ARE
VETERANS.
CHRIS SHOULD.
WELL GREAT GREAT STORIES.
THAT THE FLOOR IS OPEN TO THE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS OR
THOUGHTS OR COMMENTS AND.
THEN APPEAR.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE WORK YOU'RE DOING WITH. OUR
VETERANS AND.
THANK YOU FOR VETERANS FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
.
IT WHETHER THINGS PEOPLE HAVE
COMMENTED ON IS.
THE DIVIDE BETWEEN.
MILITARY LIFE AND CIVILIAN LIFE
AND NOT JUST LIFE BUT SOCIETY
EVEN AND THAT.
.
AT AT AND.
IT ACTUALLY HAD OF THIS DIVISION
DEFECT THAT MAY CIVILIANS TO
UNDERSTAND ANYTHING ABOUT
MILITARY LIFE. IS A PROBLEM
BECAUSE MANY OF THEM MAY BE
POLICY MAKERS WHO ARE MAKING
POLICIES AFFECTING OUR. PEOPLE
THE MILITARY ARE VETERANS AS
WELL. BUT SO I KNOW YOU'RE HERE
FOCUSING MAINLY ON HOW THESE
ARTS FOR HEALING BUT I'M ALSO
WONDERING WHETHER SOME OF YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT.
IN TERMS OF ENGAGING THE ARTS TO
ALSO HELP BECAUSE AS VETERANS
YOUR GUY TRYING TO BEAT BACK
INTO.
OUR GENERAL SINCE CIVILIAN
SOCIETY. THE ROLE ARTS CAN PLAY
AND. BUILDING THOSE BRIDGES
BETWEEN MILITARY LIFE ARE FORMER
MILITARY WIFE AND.
KERN SURVEILLANCE SOCIETY AND
YOU CAN TELL ME OF A COMPLETELY
WRONG ABOUT THIS.
I HAVE.
BUT I KNOW I'VE HEARD ABOUT
THIS I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT YOU
THOUGHT THAT MOTHER THAT'S
SOMETHING YOU'VE ENCOUNTERED
WHETHER YOU SEE A ROLE FOR THE
ARTS IN THAT ARE YOU CAN TELL ME
THAT. NO YEAH I COMPLETELY
MISSED THE MARK WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS DIVISION BETWEEN CIVILIANS
AND MILITARY NNOVA.
WHO ME WE HAVE A WE ALSO THE
FROM
TESTIFIED EARLIER TO THING ONE
ANSWER IS WELL TOTALLY
DIFFERENT?
BUT FOR.
CHRIS DARDEN LATER THINK I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU KNOW THAT WHO I
THINK.
BETWEEN THE CIVILIAN LIFE IN THE
AND CITIZENS
AND THOSE WHO HAVE SERVED.
ARI.
IS VISUAL BEYOND WORDS.
MEANING THAT YOU CAN HAVE AN
EXHIBIT AND HAVE BEAUTIFUL WORKS
THERE. INVITE PEOPLE WIN.
TAKEAWAY LABELS.
ONCE YOU'RE IN THERE.
THE END YOUR YEAR EMERGED
INTO VISUAL BEYOND WORDS WITHIN
THEIR IS CONVERSATIONS THEN
THERE'S ENGAGEMENT. THEN THERE'S
DISCUSSION ALL YOUR VETERAN.
AND THE US THE IMAGE SPEAKS TO
THE PERSON SO THEREFORE WITHOUT
ANY PRECONCEIVED OR.
SET UP WOOD LABELS.
OUR IT ALLOW HOLDS VISUAL BEYOND
WORDS ART ART ALLOWS A WELCOMING
OF THE VISUAL SENSES. SO THAT'S
WHAT I MEAN PARTY VOTE THE
SENSES IT REFLECTS TRANQUILITY.
HE CREATES A AND A SUBMARINE.
EMBRACE SO THEREFORE WE'RE
WITHOUT ANY AGAIN. CREE
PERCEPTIONS AND SO FORTH YOU ARE
THEN INVITED BY THE
VISUALIZATION SO I NOTICE AND
MANY OF OUR. ARMED VETERAN
PROJECTS OR JUST THAT THERE
VISUAL. VIGOR THEY'RE NOT ONLY
HEALED THEY DIDN'T THEY NOT ONLY
BRING OUT AND HEAL THE VETERAN.
THE VETERAN ALSO EMBRACE THE
CIVILIAN COMMUNITY BECAUSE. THE
VETERAN IS OFFERING TO CIVILIAN
COMMUNITY BEAUTY TRANQUILITY IN
REFLECTION. THE INFLOW OF
FOREIGN THAT GIVE.
THE CIVILIAN THEN AS.
WELL TELL ME ABOUT YOU HOW DID
YOU COME ABOUT THIS AND THEN
THERE FOR THE LISTENING AND THEN
THEREFORE THERE'S A HEARING. AND
SO I I HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION AND THAT'S VERY HELPFUL
BECAUSE I THINK TOO MANY.
CIVILIAN AND. HAVE.
NO MINIMAL UNDERSTANDING OF WHY.
OF IS THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A
VERY SMALL SUBSET MEANT OF ARE
POPULATION THAT ACTUALLY SERVE
RIGHT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
EXAM AND HAVE HAD EXPERIENCES
THAT.
BUT BEYOND.
PERHAPS THE EVEN THE ADULT THE.
THE IMAGINATION PERHAPS THAT
MAYBE I SHOULDN'T SAY THAT ABOUT
ANY DATE THEN DAY DON'T DON'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT PEOPLE
GONE THROUGH THEY MAY FEEL THE
CIVIL I WATCHED A MOVIE A PATH.
YEAH THAT'S BECAUSE THEY'VE
GOTTEN.
AND TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT
COMMUNICATION THAT SO THAT.
LE SO THAT THE GENERAL SIDE
CIVILIAN COMMUNITY UNDERSTANDS
WHAT WE VAST OF OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS AND OUR VETERANS EARNS
BILL TO COMMUNICATE THAT.
I THINK YOU ARE MAY BE THAT A
MECHANISM TO DO THAT IN THE WAY
THAT NAM.
THAT IS I DO WITHOUT LABELS
ABOUT NOBODY CONCEPTION SO.
INSTILLED IN NC DEAD LEAVES. THE
PATHWAY OF INVESTING IN THE
COMMUNITIES. OVERALL WITHOUT
POLARIZING WITHOUT THE
DISCONNECT. LARGE BRINGS
EVERYONE LOOKS AT LIKE THE LOOK
AT VISUAL APPEALING ITEMS. OF
PAINTINGS SCULPTURES THREE
DIMENSIONAL WAR DANCE THEATER
AND SO FORTH I THINK IF YOU COME
NEAR WITHOUT WORDS.
THINKING I THINK EVEN MUSIC AND
WRITTEN EXPRESSION AS WELL. I
JUST PIGGYBACK OFF THAT FOR MY
MY NUMBER. THAT'S OR WAITING FOR
WE WERE. WAITING FOR YOU. AND I
THINK IT'S A PIGGYBACK OFF THAT
IS LIKE THE IDEA OF LIKE THE
WARM HAND OFTEN. I THINK TOO.
USING THE ARTS LIKE YOU SAID
THERE TOWARD THEIR TRANQUIL AND.
THEY ALLOW A DIFFERENT VENUE
USING.
METAPHORS AND PUTTING THINGS
INTO DIFFERENT FORMER
COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO THE
FAMILIES OF THE SERVICE MEMBERS
CAN HEAR THE BAND THEN IT AND
LEARN A DIFFERENT WAY I HAVE TO
SAY.
JUST THROUGH YOUR YOUR WORDS
TODAY I MEAN I WAS HOLDING BACK
TEARS I'VE HEARD THIS HOW MANY
TIMES AND IT STILL GETS ME BUT.
SOMETHING IN THE WAY THAT YOU
DID THAT REALLY MADE IT EASIER
NOT EASY FOR ME BUT EASIER TED
SORRY. EASIER TO DIGEST.
THAT VARY A SOMBER I EXPERIENCE
AND SO I THINK JUST USING THE
ARTS IN A WAY WE CAN PUT REALLY.
HARDER LESS BENIGN.
THINGS INTO CONTEXT IN A WAY
THAT CAN BE DIGESTED BY THE
GENERAL PUBLIC.
PEOPLE WHO MEAN WELL THEY THEY
SUPPORT VETERAN THIRDS THEY JUST
WANTED TO SAY.
SO IT'S LIKE YOU ARE IS A
CATALYST BECAUSE THEN IT GIVES
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO TALK
ABOUT SOMETHING YEAH YEAH GIVE
THEM OF TALKING POINTS AND THEN
THE PERSON THE CIVILIAN CAN.
TALK TO THE VETERAN AND SEE THAT
THAT VETERANS DISLIKE THEM
ESSENTIALLY PUBLIC HEARING
FARMER FROM INDIANA AND YOU KNOW
WE CAN DOWN AGAIN AND. WE CAN DO
THAT.
THAT'S A.
YEAH PLEASE HAVE.
YOU ARE HERE EARLIER SIR WHEN
ICE WHEN I READ MY PIECE.
WHAT I'VE FOUND IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS AND I'VE BEEN DOING
THIS AS LIKE PEOPLE ARE SECOND
FACILITATE CONVERSATION?
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW HOW TO COME
COME UP AND TALK TO ME WHEN THEY
HEAR ABOUT WHEN I HEAR MY STORY.
THEY HAVE SOME KIND OF RELATION
THERE WILL UNDERSTAND. WHAT A
YEAR TO BE OPEN WITH ME CAN I
ASK YOU QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
NOW?
LIKE WHILE YOU HAD AN ENCOUNTER
BETWEEN THAT.
AT GARY CHILD THAT YOU WERE
ABLE TO REFERENCE YOUR OWN
MORALITY. WITH YOUR OWN CHILD
AND FEELING LEFT FIVE. OTHER
WEEK BROADBRIDGE WOULD BECOME
HUMANIZED AT THAT POINT WERE NO
LONGER THAN THIS.
PERSON DIED. MEDIA OR. THE
MOVIES HAVE PUT THIS KIND OF
ASPECT TO US IT'S NOT ZERO DARK
THIRTY IT'S NOT BLACKHAWK DOWN.
WE ARE REAL HUMAN BEINGS THAT
HAVE A VOICE WE ARE REAL HUMAN
BEINGS THAT HAVE A HARD WE ARE
REAL HUMAN BEINGS THAT HAVE A
SOUL. AND ARE ABLE TO KIND OF
UNDERSTAND WHO WE ARE AT OUR
VERY CORE. WHEN WE OPEN
OURSELVES UP THROUGH SPOKEN WORD
THROUGH.
SCULPTURE THROUGH PART THE
UNDERSTAND WE ARE ACTUAL PEOPLE.
OKAY SOMEONE AND I'M DO YOU
WANNA MAKE A QUICK COMMENT.
SIR.
ME THAT IS A DOMINO EFFECT AND
THEY GOT ME YOU'RE VERY WELCOME.
I WAS ALRIGHT OKAY OKAY. YEAH
PLEASE ME YEAH THIS IS GREAT YOU
INTEREST SUBSEQUENTLY WAS ROBERT
REDUCED CHARGE COMBAT VETERAN
VIETNAM LAURIE.
I CORPS SOUTH VIETNAM.
AND.
WE HAVE THE SAME RESPECT HIM.
WOULD WILLING LIBERTY UNFIT. TO
AN INJUSTICE FORTY ARE GRATEFUL.
BUT I SEE THAT.
I SEE THIS.
WE COME HOME.
IT WAS NOTHING FOR US.
WHEN THEY WERE IN COMBAT WHO
WERE TRAINED TO DO SOMETHING
DOESN'T RING SAID WHO WERE
TRAINED FOR ONE PURPOSE ONE
PURPOSE ONLY TO KILL.
THAT'S IT WE DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ELSE.
NINETEEN YEARS OLD.
WE WE CAME HOME SIR.
WE HAVE THIS WE HAVE NO CREE TO
OUR STUDENTS WE ANOTHER WE SO
FROM PREVIOUS INDEED WE WOULD
WORK WE HEAD.
DO THIS TIME FRAME WOULD.
FOR ALMOST SIXTEEN YEARS OUR
COUNTRY.
WAR OUTPUTTED LIKE THIS I KNOW
pFOR A FACT DON'T FROM
PENNSYLVANIA. PITTSBURGH AMID
THE ARE STILL OFFENSIVE WAS
GETTING READY. TO KNOW.
NO.
FILE.
I SAID SEE THIS.
TO NEW THE TIME FRAME TO COME UP
TO PENNSYLVANIA.
BILL.
IN A FOURTEEN OR SIXTEEN YEAR
PERIOD.
THE BILL.
MORE PENITENTIARY.
WE NEED TO HOSPITALS.
SCHOOLS AND LIBRARIES.
COME WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO DID THE SAME
IDENTICAL THING.
AND IF YOU JUST PICKED THE STATS
BANG BEEN FIFTY FIVE PERCENT.
BOB POPULATIONS OF ALL THESE
PRODUCES WORK BETTER IS FOR WAR.
THE ONE THAT WAS WRONG WITH THIS
ONE DAY A DOCTOR REALIZE HEY.
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG HERE WE
GET A GREAT DISPARITY WE GET A
LOT OF VETERANS ARE PHILIP OUR
PENITENTIARIES.
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THIS.
COULD SHE WOKE UP REALIZE. THESE
GUYS WHO SUFFER FROM SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE TO FIND A GROUP
PROBLEM.
AND FINALLY CREATIVE ARTS CAME
INTO PLAY.
YEARS LATER.
BUT I THINK GO FOR THAT.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE I DON'T FEEL
THROUGH THE CRACKS.
WITH A LOT OF AND I FILL THE
CRACKS A ONE TIME.
I DID I WOULD TO ST.
ILLEGAL DRUGS.
ANOTHER LIE ABOUT IT.
BUT AGREES TO GOTHAM. AND SOBER
ME THANK YOU.
BECAUSE I FOUND THE COLLEGE I
WAS NOT RAISED LIKE THAT.
AND LIKE YOU SAY FRUIT THERE'S A
FALL TOO FAR FROM THE VINE.
I WAS RELEASED TO BE STRONGER
THAN THAT.
I DESPAIR FIRM TODAY AND BELIEVE
THAT.
I AND I I THINK GOD.
FOR YARDS.
I THINK OF MY DOCTORS I THINK OF
MY FAVORITE I THINK OF MY
SESSION WITH MY FELLOW CONGRESS
BY FILIBUSTERS IN ARMS.
BUT I THINK OF MY BROTHER FROM
ANOTHER MOTHER.
BECAUSE IT WAS THAT WE FOUGHT
FOR EACH OTHER.
PUBLISHED TODAY THERE'S A LOT A
BROTHERS  AYE IT HURTS ME. IT
TOOK ME THIRTY YEARS A CRY.
I HAD NO MORE TEARS.
I COULD NOT CRY FOR THIRTY
YEARS.
SOME WOMEN CAN CRY DROP OF A
HAT.
NONNA. IMMUNE TO YOUR SONS
BELIEVE THIS RETELLING OF SONS
THOUGH COMMANDER OF THE CROWD
DON'T TELL ENOUGH TO RETRIEVE
THE DEAD BABY CRY.
THEN LET ALREADY MOTION NOW.
GOOGLE QUITE SURE WHO SHOWN
THOSE IN FACT WON'T TALK ABOUT
THIS IS MY BROTHER FROM ANOTHER
MOTHER ANOTHER CLEARLY STILL MY
BROTHER.
BUT THE CONSIDERED US MY
THESE ARE MY BROTHERS.
I NOTED PAIN ANOTHER SUFFERING.
I KNOW EVERYTHING THEY GONE
THROUGH.
PANEL HERE ME I AM ONE OF THOSE
MEN.
PRAY FOR ME.
HOPE.
DO YOU FEEL FREE.
DON'T TURN YOUR BACK.
PLEASE DO NOT TURN YOUR BACK
LOS.
CLICK IN THE SCREAMER FORTY
SEVEN YEARS.
I LOST MY WIFE.
TWO YEARS AGO.
HIGH BIDDER SIX DAYS AFTER MY
BIRTH.
HOW DO YOU THINK I FEEL?
I GIVE OF SO MUCH.
SO MUCH FOR SO LITTLE.
THEY CALL US MARINES HARD NOSED
THIS THAT WE'RE WE'RE YOUR
MODERN DAY SPARTANS OUT YOU ESOS
TO GO WE GO WITHOUT QUESTION.
BOB WAS NOT THE REASON WHY. OURS
BUT TO DO OR DIE.
THIS COUNTRY HOUSES TO DO SOME
THAT WE DID.
NOT ONLY THAT US BUT THE ARMY IS
WELL THE NAVY I TEASE MISS
MILLER BECAUSE ALMOST ALL FOR
WHATEVER SUPPORTER GROUP. WE HAD
THAT TAXI SERVICE.
DON'T YOU DARE FORGET TO PICK US
UP.
WHO CHILL IN THE AIRFORCE AND
WELL BUT POLICE WERE ALL ONE
PEOPLE?
WE NEED YOUR SUPPORT.
PLEASE HELP US.
THOUGH SOME SAY THINGS VERY MUCH
SIR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT YEAH CREATED THIS IS A
THIS IS NOT A VERY.
POWERFUL AND THEY TODAY.
TIME MANY ANY FILE QUESTIONS OF
THOUGHTS FROM THE FROM THE PANEL
AND WE GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
I. ANYTHING ELSE YOU WONDER CAN
REACT TO.
OKAY.
OKAY WILL REALLY THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR STORIES AND THANKS
FOR THE WORK YOU'RE DOING WITH
OUR VETERANS AND I WOULD REALLY
DO APPRECIATE A GREAT DEAL.
AND WE NOW WANT TO GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOME FOLKS TO
COME FOR AND WHO WANT TO MAKE
SOME PUBLIC COMMENT WITH GUYS
THE PHILLY FROM THAT ARE.
FROM FALLBROOK WHO'S GONNA GET
FOLLOWED BILL I WANT RESIDENTS
BEEN TALKING ABOUT ELIZABETH.
SHIRER WHOSE DATA FROM THE ALL
GLORY PROJECT AND ALSO DIABLOS
WELL RESULTS HERE TO LIVE FOR.
DAVID READ FROM YUBA SUTTER ARTS
RICHARD GRANT FOR ME WAS THAT
ARTS.
JODY I LOOK FROM CITY OF
SACRAMENTO AND.
.
JOHN AND GAS IN CITIES ARGUMENT
ALSO ANDREW OF HONORS. FROM EL
DORADO ARTS COUNCIL SLOW START
WITH STEVE.
DALY I WANT TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE STEVE DALY.
FOLLOWED BY ELIZABETH.
JENNER AND DAVID READ.
NASSER AL.
APRENDA PUBLICLY FOR THE.
YES SIR PLEASE ARE YOU CAN YOU
CAN HAVE THE SENATE SERGEANT
HERE.
BUT DEFLECTED A FEW MOMENTS TO
SPEAK.
NOT OF THAT FAIRLY ABOUT THAT
ARE. WILL WILL TOUCH ON THAT HAS
A VETERANS SERVICE ORGANIZATION
BUT I'D LIKE TO START WITH. I
BELIEVE IN GOVERNMENT.
I BELIEVE IN PEOPLE COMING
TOGETHER COLLABORATING CREATING
NEW QUESTIONS.
I BELIEVE TOGETHER WE CREATE A
BETTER IMPACT ON THE LIVES OF
OUR VETERANS THEIR FAMILIES. AND
OUR SOCIETY AND WE HEARD OTHER
PEOPLE TODAY TESTIFIED TO THE
FACT THAT AFTER NINE ELEVEN THEY
WANTED TO DO SOMETHING. AS AN
ARTIST I FELT IT WAS MY PERSONAL
ARTISTIC RESPONSIBILITY COULD
REACH OUT AND TRYING TO HELP.
VETERANS THROUGH THIS BRONZE
CASTINGS.
.
SRAMS CLAUSES THAT WE OFFER.
WE'RE A PROGRAM OF THE
NONPROFIT SOCIAL ENVIRONMENTAL
ENTREPRENEURS IN CALABASAS
WE STARTED WORKING THE SCENE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO WE CAN FOCUS
ON DEVELOPING AND GROWING IN THE
SERVICE OF OUR OPERATIONS
ASPECTS OF OUR PROGRAMMING. AND
WE CURRENTLY SERVE VETERANS
ACTIVE DUTY IN FAMILY MEMBERS IN
SEVERAL LOCATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
UNDER FOUNDRY FACILITY IN
FALLBROOK CALIFORNIA. ARIZONA WE
OFFER CLASSES FLORIDA VIRGINIA
AND. WYOMING. WE ALSO OF
COLLABORATING WITH THE YUBA ARTS
AND MARYSVILLE ARTS ASSOCIATION
AND WE ALSO RUN ANOTHER CLASS AT
SADDLEBACK COLLEGE. AND YUBA
COLLEGE UP HERE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE UTILIZE THESE ART MAKING
APPROACHES BECAUSE I FOCUS I
COME FROM A CERAMICS AND GLASS
BACKGROUND OF THE PROCESS AND
WHAT THE PROCESS MEANS. AND WE
UTILIZE THESE APPROACHES AS A
MEDIUM. TO FACILITATE
CONNECTIONS THE INTERACTIONS
AMONG VETERANS.
PEACH ARE MAKING SKILLS AS A
MEDIUM FOR EXPRESSION STORY
TELLING COPING ACCEPT IRA.
BILL POSITIVE SELF IDENTITY FOR
THE MAKING SHARING AND DIGNIFIED
PRESENTATION OF OUR.
AND TO CONNECT OUR PARTICIPANTS
TO AND EDUCATE THE BROADER
COMMUNITY THROUGH THE SHARING
EXHIBITING OF WORKS CREATED IN
OUR PROGRAMMING.
CURRENT WORKSHOPS.
WITH VILLAGE AFFILIATED SITES
WITH NATIONAL INTREPID CENTER OF
EXCELLENCE.
CAMP PENDLETON TRIPS
SPIRIT CENTER FOR BELL FOR THE
WAR IN FAMILY CENTER AT BETHESDA
AND THE WARRIOR FAMILY CENTER AT
FORT BELVOIR. AND CURRENTLY WE
DO A BILLS PROGRAM WITH ACHIEVE
TBI CARE PROGRAM AT CAMP
PENDLETON. WHICH IS LOCATED IN
THE NEW INTREPID SPIRIT CENTER
AT CAMP PENDLETON WAS OPEN IN
EARLY APRIL.
AND WE OFFER BOTH LIFE CAST IN
BRONZE CASTING CLASSES.
BRONZE CASTINGS LONGER TERM MORE
COLLABORATIVE PROGRAM TO THE IN
LABOR INTENSIVE NATURE OF THE OF
OUR MEDIUM.
WELL SECURING FITSOF FACILITATE
EXHIBITIONS.
AND CURRENTLY WE HAVE AN
INSTALLATION OF SAN DIEGO
AIRPORT BY THAT OUR INSTRUCTOR
KEVIN LARSON AND THAT WILL BE
OUT IN TERMINAL ONE. FOR THE
NEXT YEAR KNOCKOFF FAT THE
AIRPORT CYNICAL DESCENDING AND
ASCENDING AIRPORT CURRENT.
WE WE SEEK.
OUT TO FIND NEW COLLABORATIONS
WITH EDUCATIONAL CULTURAL AND
VETERANS SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS.
AND WE HAVE SOME IMAGES HERE TO
GIVE YOU SOME EXAMPLES OF OUR
PROCESS AND AND WORKS COMPLETED.
ON THE FINAL PAGE HERE THESE ARE
BELLS THAT WERE COMPLETED.
LAST FRIDAY WITHIN THE CHIEF
GROUP THAT CAME FROM CAMP
PENDLETON IN THESE VERSES WITH
AND STUFF. FRESH OUT OF THE
FAMILY FOUNDRY FLOOR.
I BELIEVE THAT ART IS A VISUAL
LANGUAGE THAT EMPOWERS THE
PARTICIPANT TO CAN'T COME BACK
THE EFFECTS OF MORAL INJURY. AND
THAT AS.
SOMETHING MORRELL INJURIES BEST
DESCRIBED AS LIVING IN A HIGH
STAKES SITUATION.
AND I THINK OUR HELPS GIVE
PEOPLE THE TOOLS.
TO. BETTER ACCESS THAT AND TO
SHARE THAT. IT DOESN'T. IT IT'S
ONLY BETTER FOR THE PARTICIPANT
TO SHARE FROM.
I AM ASKING FOR YOUR HELP TODAY
CONTINUE THIS PROGRAM.
THIS IS GOVERNMENT GOING TO
WORK.
RIGHT NOW.
I BELIEVE IN THE AND I SEE THIS
AND THAT TO SAY THIS IS A GOOD
THING.
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO OFFER.
BROWN'S PORTRAITS FOR DISPLAY
IN ANY OF YOUR OFFICES THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE WE DO WE CAN
DO THAT FREE OF CHARGE OF
COURSE.
AND IF ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
HERE'S MY VOICE PLEASE COME DOWN
AND VISIT US.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE YOU COME.
WE DID WE DID SOME PROBLEMS WILL
CAPTURE.
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK. TODAY. AND
WE CAN IT WOULD BE RIGHT IN
FALLBROOK THAT THE.
FULLER FOUNDER HERE AND WE HAVE
A SECOND.
SO WHICH WILL BE FOR CERAMICS
AND BLAST HIM FOR.
BUT YOU THINK HE WAS DOING.
WELL NEXT HERE FROM ELIZABETH
SHATNER FROM THE ALL GLORY
PROJECT IN THE FALL BY DAVID
READ.
GOOD AFTERNOON MAY I GIVE THESE
FIRES I WAS NOT PLANNING TO
SPEAK SO IT'S QUITE A PRIVILEGE
IF. I CAN GIVE THESE FLYERS I
HAVE FOUR REMAINING HALF SO.
.
PERFECT HIT ME HELP.
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
THE.
GLORY PROJECT IS.
I'M ELIZABETH SHATNER.
MY HUSBAND'S WELL KNOWN ACTOR
WILLIAM SHATNER. AND I GOT
INVOLVED AND THE CHARITABLE.
LA COMMUNITY THROUGH THE
HOLLYWOOD CHARITY HORROR SHOW
WHICH I HELP MY BECAUSE HUSBAND
CO HOST FOR THE LAST SEVENTEEN
YEARS. IN THAT ENDEAVOR. A WILL
SOME OF THE CHARITIES THAT WE
SUPPORTED OR EQUINE ASSISTED.
THE SETUP THERE BE CENTERS FOR
VETERANS.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT SPOKE.
VOTE QUITE CLOSE TO MY HEART
SINCE I'M A HORSE TRAINER
EXPORTS TRAINER. AND UNITED
STATES EQUESTRIAN FEDERATION
JUDGE FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
AND. SO. I WANTED TO DO
SOMETHING MORE.
AND.
AND WHAT. AND IT CAME TO ME USE
WHAT YOU KNOW. REALLY IN THE END
THE CENTER WAS THE WALTER REED
STORY WHEN OUR VETERANS WERE
COMING BACK AND THEY DIDN'T
HAVE.
SHEETSFOR THE THEIR BEDS OR
THEY HAD URINE ON THE FLOOR SO
IT WAS REALLY LIKE WE CAN'T LET
THIS HAPPEN.
I WAS YOUNG DURING VIETNAM BUT
SOMEWHERE IT RESONATED IN ME
THAT WE COULD NOT LET THIS
HAPPEN. TO ANOTHER POPULATIONS
OF VETERANS AND NOW IT WAS. MY
GENERATION THAT MIGHT HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING BUT WHAT CAN I DO.
USE WHAT YOU KNOW WAS THE
ANSWER.
AND IF WE ALL KNEW USE WHAT WE
KNEW.
THE ARTIST THE HORSE TRAINERS
EVERY PERSON THAT HAS A
PROFESSION WITHIN THE COMMUNITY.
WE CAN RECEIVE OUR VETERANS AND
CARE FOR THEM BECAME A PERSONAL
MISSION NOT TO TAKE GOVERNMENT
MONEY. BUT TO STEP UP AS A
CIVILIAN TO TRY TO DO THIS
THING.
SO NOT TO REINVENT THE WHEEL.
I IDENTIFIED LOCATED EQUINE AT.
ASSISTED THERAPY CENTERS NOT
ONLY IN CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES. AND I STARTED
VISITING AND SUPPORTING IF NOT.
MONETARILY IF WE DON'T HAVE
FUNDS THEN THROUGH.
PUBLIC OF RELATIONS MY HUSBAND
LOANED HIS VOICE TO PURPOSE
PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENT. AND
WE'VE BEEN TAKING THAT AROUND
THE UNITED STATES PLAYING AT
HORSE SHOWS ACROSS THE NATION.
SHARING THE SUPPLY TO STEP UP
AND HELP OUR VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES ALL THEATRES OF WAR. IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND HOW.
WE DON'T HAVE TO REINVENT THE
WHEEL.
THE CENTERS EXIST OFTEN THEY'RE
CERTIFIED OFTEN THEY HAVE ART
PROGRAMS ALONG WITH THEIR EQUINE
PROGRAMS THEY HAVE PROGRAMS
WITH.
FOR THE GOLD STAR FAMILIES HAVE
LOST A MEMBER DO MORE FOR.
THEY HAVE.
PLEASE OF CREATIVE PERFORMANCES
WITHIN CAMPFIRE PROJECT POETRY
EVERYTHING YOU'VE HEARD FROM
EVERY PANEL MEMBER. IS WHAT
RESONATED WITH ME WHAT WE GO TO
SPEAK FOR OUR OUR CIVILIANS AND
ARE NOT ONLY OUR CIVILIANS BUT.
OUR.
VETERANS WHO WE NEED TO COME
TOGETHER AND ART.
IS.
THE HUMAN CONNECTION.
THAT CAN BRING US TOGETHER
EQUESTRIAN.
THROUGH PERFORMING NOT JUST
ONE ARE A FORM. BUT IT'S THE WAY
HE IT HELPS US DEAL. WITH THE
TRAUMA.
AND THAT HELPS US IDENTIFY. OUR
HUMAN.
CONNECTION.
THROUGH.
ARE.
PROBLEMS AND WE BECOME THE SAME.
MILITARY.
THEY ALL WERE BORN CIVILIANS.
AND SO WE WELCOME THEM BACK IN.
MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS WELLNESS
PROGRAMS THERAPY PROGRAMS.
DECOMPRESS.
AND.
HELP PEOPLE SURVIVE.
AND THRIVE AND BECOME PART OF
OUR COMMUNITY I'D. HEARD IT OVER
AND OVER AGAIN. FROM VETERANS
ACROSS THE NATION IN THESE
PROGRAMS YEAH I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF SUPPORTING DIABLO.
WITH ALL GLORY PROJECT.
THAT WAS ONE OF OUR.
ONE OF THE VERY WORTHWHILE
PROGRAMS THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
HELP FIND AND GET THEIR STORY
TOLD IN THE KENNEDY CENTER
THINK.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THIS TOO
WILL WILL TAKE A YES PRETTY GOOD
FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR AND IT'S
WONDERFUL TO BE AMONG. THE
TRIBES PREACHING PRINTER.
ARE ONE IF YOU'RE DAVID REED
FOLLOWED BY RICHARD GRANT.
A BASKET RICHARD YEAH JOIN US
FOR CO COLLABORATORS REVENUE AND
MANY CENTER NIELSEN GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN SIR.
I'M DAVID REID I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE YUBA
SUTTER ARTS COUNCIL BASED IN
MARYSVILLE. WE REPRESENT TO
SMALL RURAL COUNTIES WITH A
COMBINED POPULATION OF ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
WITH THE VETERAN POPULATION OF
ABOUT FOURTEEN. THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS IN ADDITION OUR
SERVICE AREA INCLUDES BEALE AIR
FORCE BASE WITH FOUR THOUSAND
MILITARY PERSONNEL. AN
ADDITIONAL TWO THOUSAND CIVILIAN
EMPLOYEES AND I'M PROUD
PERSONALLY TO BE A BILL HONORARY
COMMANDER.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS YUBA
SUTTER ARTS IS CONDUCTED A
VARIETY VETERANS ARE STARTS
PROJECTS FUNDED IN LARGE PART BY
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCILS.
VETERANS INITIATIVE IN THE ARTS
WE CREATED A VETERANS ART PARK.
BUT THE SENATOR HAS VISITED THE
COMPRISED OF VETERAN DESIGNED
AND CREATED MURALS WE FELT
BROWN'S FACE CASTING WORKSHOPS
UNDER THE DIRECTION OF MISTER
BILLION HIS TEAM.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE
CONDUCTED OUR MOST AMBITIOUS
VETERANS ART PROJECT CALLED
PORTRAITS OF VETERANS.
THAT INVOLVED BRINGING IN
PROFESSIONAL PHOTOGRAPHER
INSTRUCTORS TO WORK AND POP UP
STUDIOS ALL OVER THE COMMUNITY
WITH GROUPS OF VETERANS WHO
LEARNED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
PORTRAIT PHOTOGRAPHY. AND HELP
CREATE INTROSPECTIVE IMAGES OF
EACH OTHER OUR POP UP STUDIO
LOCATIONS INCLUDED OUR HISTORY
AND CULTURE MUSEUM.
OUR LIBRARIES SO TO SENIOR
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES ARE
MUSEUM OF THE FORGOTTEN WARRIORS
ARE LOCAL VA SERVICES OFFICE.
THE YUBA COLLEGE VETERANS
RESOURCES OFFICES AND OUR ANNUAL
VETERANS STAND DOWN EVENTS.
SO THE PORTRAITS WERE CURATED
AND DISPLAYED BEFORE DURING AND
AFTER VETERANS DAY IN OUR LOOK
AT OUR OWN GALLERY. AS WELL AS
IN CLUSTERS OF TWENTY TO FIFTY
OF THESE PORTRAITS AGAIN IN THE
LIBRARIES MUSEUMS AND THROUGHOUT
THE YUBA SUTTER COMMUNITY. AND
ALL WE WORKED WITH AND
PHOTOGRAPHED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
VETERANS FOR THIS PROJECT.
HERE JUST A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES.
USER RICHARDS WORK AND. STILL
SPEAKER IN JUST A MINUTE.
HIGH QUALITY.
VERY DETAILED TWENTY BY THIRTY
BLACK AND WHITE PORTRAITS.
ASSEMBLY TAMMY PACK RUNS THE
VETERANS SERVICES OFFICE AT YUBA
COLLEGE NAVY VETERAN. AND
RICHARD FOOT. A COLLEAGUE IN A
NUMBER OF ARTS PROJECTS.
AIRFORCE VETERAN WORLD WAR TWO
ERA. VERY HARPER DRESSER
NOWADAYS. BE MORBIDLY CITY WANTS
IT TO BE HIS OBITUARY
PHOTOGRAPHS. HANNAH RICHARD
COULD BE FAMOUS OR FOR THE WRONG
HIS SENSE.
LE THE CAMARADERIE DURING THE
STUDIO SESSIONS OF DISCUSSION OF
SHARED EXPERIENCES WAS QUITE
PROFOUND WHEN WE INSTALLED THE
PORTRAITS ALL OVER TOWN WE
CREATED. BUT PORTRAITS OF
VETERANS GUIDE SO THAT THE
VETERANS NEWER THEIR PORTRAIT
WOULD BE DISPLAYED THE
SPONTANEOUS CELEBRATIONS WE SAW
IN VETERANS AND THEIR FRIENDS
AND FAMILIES CAME TOGETHER. TO
VISIT THE PORTRAITS ARE QUITE
MOVING AND AGAIN THE DISPLAYS
BECAME KIND OF A RALLYING POINT
FOR THE VETERANS AND THE SHARED
EXPERIENCE OF MILITARY. WIFE
THROUGH THESE THROUGH THOSE
CHALLENGING CIRCUMSTANCES WE'VE
HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT TODAY. CALL
IS A RESULT OF THE RELATIVELY
SIMPLE TASK OF MAKING A
PHOTOGRAPH IN THIS SELFIE WORLD
OF OURS. YUBA SUTTER ARTS IS
RECENTLY APPLIED FOR ANOTHER
VETERANS INITIATIVE IN THE ARTS
AND HOPEFULLY WILL I BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE OUR VARIOUS VETERANS
ART PROJECTS.
THEN AGAIN WHEN CONCLUSION WE
WANNA PAT ARE THANK YOU TO ALL
OF THE VETERANS AND WELCOME
HOME.
AT LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY FRIEND
AND COLLEAGUE AIRFORCE VETERAN
AND PORTRAITS OF VETERANS
PHOTOGRAPHER MISTER RICHARD
GRANT.
THANK YOU SENATORS IT SO A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE AND SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE ARTS AND. THE
PORTRAITS OF VETERANS PROJECT
THAT WE DID IN THE OF THE CENTER
AREA.
AS A PHOTOGRAPHER IT TO A WAS A
PRIVILEGE TO MEET THESE VETERANS
AND HEAR THEIR STORIES.
WE DIDN'T JUST TAKE THE PICTURE.
WE SPENT TIME WITH THEM AND.
THERE PHOTOGRAPHS WERE UP BY.
THROUGHOUT THE TOWN AND WE ALSO
PROVIDED THEM WITH AN INDIVIDUAL
COPY OF THAT DATA.
I THINK IT WAS AN EIGHT BY TEN
PICTURE THAT THE STATE.
EACH INDIVIDUAL RECEIVED.
SO I THOUGHT OF PRODUCTS TO
GATHER HOW I THOUGHT IT WAS A
WAY TO RELATE TO EACH OTHER TO.
BRIDGE THE.
THE FED THE SPAN BETWEEN A
VETERAN IN THE CITY AND AND
CIVILIANS AND I THINK IT WAS
VERY HELPFUL. AND I HOPE THERE
IS SUPPORT AND NOT. DOING THIS
IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU PRODUCER GRANT.
BOB WELL NEXT YEAR FROM. I THINK
IT'S
JUDY EHRLICH AND FOLLOWED BY AND
JONAH GUS.
BOTH FROM SACRAMENTO.
AND IF THEY'RE NOT HERE THEN WE
HAVE AND YOU'VE UNDERSTATEMENT.
MANY OF YOU GUYS.
WHO'S HERE THAT LAUGHING HERE
COME ON UP.
FROM PLACERVILLE FROM EL DORADO
ARTS COUNCIL YES OKAY.
.
SITTING THROUGH OF ALL
EVERYTHING THAT OCCURRED TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS.
ALL OF WORK IN THAT FOCUS THAT
YOU GUYS STILL PUT ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I ARRANGED A LOT OF.
POINTS IN BULLET POINTS THAT
HAVE BEEN COVERED SO MANY TIMES
TODAY AT NOT GONNA SAY IT AGAIN.
I'M BUT I WILL SHARE WITH YOU A
STATEMENT FROM.
SOMEONE WHO PARTICIPATED IN OUR
VETERANS VOICES A WRITING
WORKSHOP.
COME WE'VE BEEN ADMINISTERING
THE VETERANS VOICES WRITING
WORKSHOPS FOR.
SINCE.
TWENTY FOURTEEN ARM.
SINCE THEN WE HAVE SERVED A
VETERANS IN THE REGION RECENTLY
PUBLISHED HER FIRST EVER
ANTHOLOGY OF WORKS.
FOR THEM BY S..
AVAILABLE ON AMAZON.
SOMEOF THE ORIGINAL
PARTICIPANTS ARE STILL
CONTRIBUTING TODAY.
OKAY.
I'M NOW A STATEMENT FROM
CAROLINE WAGNER A PARTICIPANT
AND OUR VETERANS VOICES READING
WORKSHOP.
I AM A DISABLED FEMALE ARMY
VETERAN. RESIDING IN A SMALL
MOUNTAIN TOWN OF POLLOCK PINES
IN ELDORADO.
WRITING TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL SUPPORT OF THE
VETERANS OF VOICES OF WRITING
WORKSHOP.
AS A POST NINE ELEVEN VETERAN.
AND KNOW THEIR MANY PROGRAMS
DESIGNED TO HELP VETERANS WHOSE
HAVE SERVED DURING THE ERA OF
GLOBAL WAR TOOK ON TERRORISM.
UNFORTUNATELY. I ALSO KNOW MANY
VIETNAM VETERANS AND EVEN WORLD
WAR TWO VETERANS. WHO WERE
EXCLUDED FROM FUNDING IN THESE
PROGRAM SIMPLY BECAUSE THEIR
TIME IN UNIFORM WAS SO LONG AGO?
HOWEVER THE EMOTIONAL TO HOLD
THE MILITARY SERVICE CAN TAKE AN
ENTIRE LIFETIME TO CONQUER.
I AM APPRECIATIVE.
THAT OUR VETERANS VOICES PROGRAM
IS INCLUSIVE AMERICA VETERANS
FROM ALL BRANCHES OF SERVICE
FROM ALL AREAS.
WHO ARE MEMBERS OF THE OLD
EROTICA COUNTY COMMUNITY?
AS A VETERAN DIAGNOSED WITH
PTSD.
I SOMETIMES FIND IT DIFFICULT TO
FIND A REASON TO LEAVE MY HOUSE.
OUR WRITERS WORKSHOP. MEETINGS
GIVE ME A PURPOSE IN DESTINATION
ON MONDAY EVENINGS THIS IS
CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT TO AVOID
GOING DOWN THE PATH OF
ISOLATION.
WHICH CAN LEAD TO SUICIDE AMONG
VETERANS WITH PTSD.
VETERANS VOICES HAS GIVEN ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RELEASE THE
STORIES THAT HAVE BEEN BUILDING
INSIDE ME SINCE LEAVING SERVICE
FOURTEEN YEARS AGO.
I KNOW THAT I AM NO LONGER ALONE
IN MY WRITING JOURNEY AND I
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE WHERE IT TAKES
ME.
SHE IS A CONTRIBUTOR TO OUR
ANTHOLOGY AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU KNOW THE
WORK THAT YOU DO.
WELL THINK YOUR BUDDY.
IF AND IF INVEST THE FOLKS IN
SAYS ACKERMAN ARE BACK AND I.
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S PARTICIPATION WITH
SPEND VERY MEANINGFUL WE'VE
LEARNED A LOT.
AND WE'VE CERTAINLY AND WANT TO
CONTINUE TO STAY ENGAGED ALL THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
REPRESENTED AND AND FIGURE OUT
WAYS WE CAN BE AS HELPFUL AS IT
POSSIBLY CAN.
YOU KNOW THAT THE.
BUDGET PROCESS IS CURRENTLY
UNDER WAY AND.
YOU THINGS ARE LOOKING UP FOR
THE ARTS COUNCIL SO FAR AND
TOUCH WOOD. AND CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW HOPE THAT THAT THIS A VERY
IMPORTANT WORK AND COLLABORATE
WITH OUR VETERANS GROUPS WILL
CONTINUE IN.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO GROW AND EXPAND
THESE PROGRAMS THAT MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE FOR ABOUT IT SO WE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT FUNDS
COMING IN AND.
YOUR TESTIMONY.
I AM VERY MOVING VERY A POWERFUL
AND WITHOUT WILL. HEREBY ADJOURN
THIS HEARING OF THE OF THE.
TOOK IN THE ARTS AND THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN TO LAUREN FOR ALL OF
OUR WEAPONS TOGETHER